But Zonia's Hourglass being able to keep
cards like your Elder Dragons alive
after they've been removed by just
having this nice little hidden or two
drop essentially of this gear that keeps
that unit. You're already playing so few
of these units. Making sure that they
get recalled and back to your base
instead of actually getting killed is
such an important part of this deck. But
I've got one more fun one for you here.
Silverfuse. This is another one that's
kind of up and coming recently. And I
would say when I was in Sydney, a lot of
people were not necessarily on top of
this one, but Poppy Aurora is really
coming into the front here. And you
talked about all the tools that are good
against all the Aurora decks, but you
talked about the Order Domain with
Salvage. And this is one of those decks
that's allowed to play this like in the
sideboard, but it's just still playing
the same maintain of the Aurora package,
but has all the removal that comes with
the Order domain.
>> Yes, exactly. Okay, so if you do get
behind, you are able to play things like
Cold of the Week. You can play it nice
and early, too, because you're just
dramping, but that's the only thing
that's the real big downside of it. The
other thing is a lot of players are
sideboarding in divine judgment, which
is a really big part of the deck of you
play your Aurora and then after you play
Divine Judgment, you make your opponent
recycle down to two runes and then two
units and two cards. So, if you have
this Aurora online, you're able just to
continue playing these massive units
while your opponent has no resources to
react to it.
>> I love parts of the deck like Blood
Money that allow you to generate gold
earlier on. So, as you get to the nine
drop dazzling Aurora instead of spending
some power, you use the gold to drop
maybe, let's not say, a nine drop gear.
How about a seven drop in Vanguard
Armory, which also allows you to create
units inside of the deck without filling
unit slots that could be grabbed from
the Dazzling Aurora. So, I like some of
these other strong cards that this deck
does bring. Of course, really just using
Poppy as a vessel to not only have that,
but to have your chosen champion unit
that you can bring out at earlier points
in the game as you're accelerating to
get to the Dazzling Aurora. But, you
know, once again, I've got to ask you,
as we just kind of talked about Ye and
also here with Poppy, what are you
saying is the weaknesses of these decks
as we kind of conclude here, you know,
how do you beat Poppy's version versus
Master E?
>> Poppy Poppy's version, just like a lot
of the Aurora versions, is you got to
get on the board quick. You have to
score points early, and you have to
sometimes be able to do something
against these Elder Dragons. For
example, we see in the body that we play
Unyielding Spirit, for instance, that
says, "Actually, your damage doesn't
matter anymore from Elder Dragon." And
if you're able to then take advantage of
that tempo, then you can potentially win
the game as well.
>> I couldn't have said it better myself.
That's why I didn't. We left it here for
you. And that is going to be our deep
dive here with Dazzling Aurora. So don't
go anywhere cuz we've got some more
coming your way.
Thanks so much. I'm Bear Bryant and I'm
joined here with No Veggies. TSS of
course representing the team here now.
TSS 2 and 0 on the streams by the way.
But congratulations on an amazing
piloted of the Aurora Poppy List. and
she's even supporting you here on your
back and your shoulder. Um you're 4 and
0. That's got to feel pretty good. How's
how's the tournament as a whole right
now feeling for you currently?
>> Feeling good. Feeling great. Um I'm
hitting the match ups I need to be
hitting. Um right now um dodging all the
stuff that I didn't dodge at Sydney
round one. Um so right now we're pretty
good. I'm happy with my play is the most
important part. Um don't think I haven't
made any egregious mistakes and that's
shown so far.
>> Yeah, absolutely. I mean a 200 right
here, you know, using advantage of a lot
of the cards. And I mean, genuinely,
Novey
believer. I'm a Dazzling Aurora
believer, don't get me wrong, but can
you can you kind of explain to me why
this version of the deck is maybe a
little like underrepresented right now
and kind of slept on like why do you
think that is? Cuz I believe that and
I'm not the only one in the room.
>> Yeah. So, um definitely um has some
glaring weaknesses compared to Chaos
Aurora. Um not a lot of draw power. the
units are technically not lower quality
but don't really hit certain parts of
the format that need to be hitting right
now. Like mind splitter is just a house
of a card in in chaos, right? Like but
we kind of supplement it by like playing
a little bit more removal, a little bit
more control. Um harness dragon
obviously is something we flex over
chaos that we don't and we just kind of
have we you kind of have to get
creative. You kind of have to like
you're addicted if you don't see Aurora
you can't panic. You have to be like
okay I don't see Aurora. I'm not I can't
You have to play like you're never going
to draw it. So, you got to be like,
"Okay, if I'm not going to see a Roa,
what can I do to possibly eek out the
game cuz you're going to see it
eventually unless in the bottom 20, but
you need to stabilize."
>> And speaking of in game one, that's
exactly what we saw. Like, you didn't
panic. You played the cards really well.
Ruination being a big card for the deck.
You talk about the removal call of the
week being huge in game two as well. And
I got to say, just I mean, the ordered
domain really showing through in this
deck because I even look at things like
Forge of the Future. It's a non-unit
card that generates a unit to help you
with some tempo, but also has removal
for your opponent's trash pile or
recycles your own units, right? And then
on top of that, the Vanguard Armory. I I
think that's another kind of one of
these examples where because the deck
also kind of generates a little bit of
gold sometimes, you can slam that on
seven, use the gold instead of the
recycle, and you still have the nine if
you find the Aurora later. It's you
really did showcase the strengths of
having order paired with Aurora, which
we just don't typically see a lot of the
time.
>> Yeah. Um it was uh especially in game
two where um the go the my opponent
correctly playing that I didn't let me
pop uh a unit. The actual part I was
more annoyed at wasn't that I didn't get
rid of the unit was I didn't I wasn't
getting the gold. So I really needed
that gold to like insulate Aurora
afterwards and that why I couldn't immed
it was really risky to play the Aurora
immediately and as you saw I was
immediately outed. So I kind of went
into that knowing it was going to happen
but I needed to stabilize the game at
the moment. Um yeah
>> and it worked out for you. So my last
kind of question for you know veggies I
know you have another tournament a rest
of the tournament to get to but on the
team the secret sauce obviously this
feels almost like a little bit of secret
sauce here but I I have to ask you are
you are you hunting for like a victory
win here? Are you someone on the team
going for a bestesto because you're
currently 4 and0 with this Poppy deck.
>> So if anyone knows me uh I am a big
Poppy fan. I love Poppy. I think she's
she is great. She is just dumb as me. Um
you know and honestly like she is the
first lead character I played. I enjoy
her play style and just like I don't
know just the character in general kind
of resonates me. Just the fact that like
she uh all she talks about is like
getting knocked 20 times down and she'll
get still get up. It's like so I kind of
like that. So, you know, uh I I I
resonate a lot with the character. So,
I'm just I need I need the best of
eventually, you know.
>> Just a yortle with a hammer.
>> Just a y with a hammer.
>> Just a no veggies with a dazzling aurora
and a dream. So, currently 4 and0. You
got two more wins and you'll lock in
that day two for sure. So, keep it up
and thanks so much. We're going to send
it over to the desk
>> and I'm round now and I'm honestly so
excited because this next round is going
to feature a legend that I absolutely
love. It's Azir. Azir is back and it's
actually against one of your favorite
legends.
>> Yeah, I do love Misfortune. She was
actually the first character I played in
League of Legends. So, very excited to
see her. Uh despite, you know, Aurora
not always being everyone's favorite,
she is still a lot of fun overall. She
was the one of the original Aurora
players and gamers.
>> So, obviously, this is a dazzling Aurora
variation of Misfortune. You'd expect
nothing less. Does anything stand out to
you here?
>> I mean, of course, we have to talk about
Elder Dragon being the main unit in the
deck being the one that we always want
to see when possible with a few
exceptions for that. Mindsplitter Filter
Dragon being able to take out so many
units at each location and Mindsplitter
being able to to say no to your
opponent's hand are the two key cards in
this deck outside of Aurora itself of
course.
>> And unique to Misfortune is going to be
bullet time. Bullet Time being the
signature ability of Misfortune is going
to give her some optionality to help
clear some battlefields.
>> Yeah, and I really like the split of the
three Flurry of Blades [music] with the
one of Bullet Time because bullet time
does cost power. It isn't as strong as
Flurry [music] of the Blades at time.
Although it has a little bit more
utility to it because you can pay
additional power if you don't have that
Elder Dragon out which can sometimes
delay the inevitable but sometimes win
games as well. But a big thing to
highlight about this deck is it's high
consistency in Aurora. We have the
Scrier's Bloom for instance that allows
us to filter through our deck a little
bit more which is big time for it. Of
course the triple stack deck. We have
seen this card in Chaos consistently as
we are able to filter through our deck a
lot. And then our new card from
Unleashed, the Lunar Boon, allowing us
to discard a card and then draw two
more, giving us that additional
consistency to find our Auroras.
>> Now, let's take a look at the Azir deck,
[music] which honestly, I got to tell
you, it's been relatively consistent
through the two sets. Obviously, Azir
came in in Spirit Forge and introduced
some new tools in Unleash. And we do
have the VI peacekeeper there as an
ambush card that we're seeing a whole
lot of in the order domain.
>> Yep. And then we also of course see some
of the removal spells. We have the
hidden blade for instance and also Cole
the week. Something that we've seen do
very well into some of the main players
in the meta such as Ireelia and Aurora.
So this could be a pretty good matchup
for Azir especially if it's able to get
onto the board early. And I really want
to highlight that it is main decking
salvage which is a key card into these
Aurora decks and these gear decks
overall. We have been seeing players an
uptick of them playing the gear hay in
the main deck and seeing this in Azir is
no surprise at all.
>> Yeah, two main deck salvages is probably
a good meta call right now. Now there
are some new additions from unleashed
including sacrifice but we do have
shadows call which I do like to
highlight here. Shadow's Call is one of
those cards that generates so much
value, especially when you're working
with um you know some token units. I
mean, your sand soldiers are obviously
valuable, but when you're using the Eye
of the Herald, you might be generating
some of your recruits and you could very
easily draw too and just let those
recruits expire.
>> Yeah, we have seen Azir earlier in the
day kind of uh have an issue with not
finding that equipment and the Shadows
Call gives you another option for
finding your equipment.
>> And the last shout out here is going to
be Soul Sword. Uh, that is a great
addition because we know that Azir wants
to get as many inexpensive equipment
onto the field of play to combo with its
legend ability. So, let's take it to the
game board. Let's see. Game number one.
Azir versus Misfortune. I got to tell
you, I'm excited because we're going to
see that like, okay, so the Azir has two
salvages in the main deck. They are
prepared for this opportunity to take
advantage of that. And we're starting
with Arena's greatest as well. They want
to win fast and uh for the Misfortune
player, they might not realize, well,
they almost certainly don't, that they
have in their main deck two salvages
ready to go. So, they're going to try
and win nice and quickly here.
>> Yes, I think this call that we've been
seeing an uptick in Arena's deck or
Arena's greatest be played as the
neutral battlefield, especially in these
decks that do main deck, the gear hate,
is because you are having multiple good
battlefields now that you can play. And
this being on neutral, speeding up the
game before the Aurora deck is able to
sideboard will give you more options
here.
>> All right. And that there is the uh the
treasure trove coming in.
>> It's going to allow them to uh to draw
and channel when it uh gets destroyed,
which it already has.
>> Yep. We weren't even looking for the
pack of wonders there. Instead, just
as quick as possible.
>> Now, we don't have it reflected here. It
is an arena's greatest game. I don't see
either point being scored. in case there
is a discrep.
Well, they're pulling out the pads now.
They're like, "Hey, did we forget to
score some points here? Are we keeping
track of things
>> to do so as well, although not?
>> Yes, always important to do so." So, we
will see those players getting out those
notepads. And it's just part of what
you're used to doing as well is scoring
yourself. It is a little bit different
when you're up on stage and you're
having to call it out in a different way
than what these players may or may not
be used to. But it looks like we do have
that first arena's greatest trigger
being called out here.
>> Yeah, that's good. I'm glad that they're
sorting that out. And for those that are
watching that aren't too familiar,
Rocklo is actually Anazir god. He has a
number of best ofves and I had I was
fortunate enough to meet them in Vegas.
And it's funny, we had a conversation
for a little while about uh using
guardian uh guardian angel GA in the
Azir decks and it ultimately got cut
going into spirit forge because you did
have some of the like the soul sword for
instance as a better option. Uh but it's
very interesting to see that like Azir
while it seems like almost I don't want
to say like the perfect list has been
discovered uh there is still room for
refinement and I mean we see that with
the two salvages which I'm sure in this
match up he's glad he has in the main
board
>> and the Gus coming in going to be
quickly responded with an ong guard
making that above the three might
require for Gus to bounce that back to
hand
>> uh essentially will become a dead card
here but does trade off of the on guard
which could be useful in the future if
we are able to get the Aurora and those
large units out. Being able to trade
with those with Ong Guard can be really
important in the future. So getting that
out of hand isn't the worst thing, but
of course the early scoring is what
Aurora doesn't want to see.
>> Yeah. And of course, you're going to
want to conquer the arena's greatest
first because the Sigil of the Storm,
you don't want to sit and hold that too
often. You will be uh unfortunately
forced to recycle a rune in that case.
And of course with with the Dowsing
Aurora base bounty hunter here, you're
going to want to uh punish your
opponents for getting those early
points. And so, uh, Rock is going to be
very happy sitting on the arena's
greatest.
>> Yes, having that option is really nice.
Of course, you know, in the future,
we're going to have to start going on to
the Sigil of the Storm if we want to
keep up the tempo necessary for beating
Aurora. We will see that Lunar Boon come
out and discarding another Gust, which I
love that discard because a lot of these
units are going to be above that three
might threshold. So, we'll go ahead and
draw two from that as well.
>> Oh, well, never mind. It'll be Defi.
Yes.
>> Wow. Defy comes down, prevents Yeah,
prevents the uh the draw. That's that's
fantastic there because you don't you
don't want them to find the Aurora.
That's one of the strategies, right? You
could prevent them from even finding the
Aurora in the first place. And that is
going to be one of the ways that you
could perhaps uh close out the game.
>> And we might have just seen a
mindslitter potentially in hand. So if
Aurora is found, oh no, it's a last
rights is what I'm saying. I'll see if
there is a mindslitter in the future.
But the one of the big things on the
Aurora deck is
>> if you are able to draw the units, you
can easily do the calculations because
there's only four units in the deck. So
if you have the mind spplitter, you
know, you're always going to be playing
uh Aurora or Aurora into an Elder
Dragon. So all that is really critical.
We do see the sabotage in hand as well,
which could be useful, too.
>> We have we see a call of the week
available as well. So that'll be perhaps
useful later on. And we are going to
have uh Azir Sovereign coming out to
establish his board presence
>> holding two here to three points. You
are going to want to try to rush down
the Aurora player here. It's a good
start for Azir.
>> And we do see that Mindsplitter in hand.
It was
>> correct earlier. So if we do get Aurora
out
>> and there it is. Mind splitter comes
out.
>> And mindsplitter can be reacted to.
However, if you have actions, you cannot
respond with those. So, we will see the
coal the week get taken out of hand,
which is a big piece. Obviously, if we
if we leave coal in the hand, this mines
flare is going to be gone pretty
quickly.
>> Yeah, and if my memory serves me
correctly, that was the only call of the
week in the main deck. And so, that is a
a major loss here for Azir.
>> Yes, very critical in this. However, we
are down on runes once again. We did
recycle two power. So, we won't be
playing Aurora anytime soon here, even
if we were to find it in our hand.
>> We're already holding six, which is I
mean, this is the the beauty of Arena's
greatest. This is going very well. And
so, uh we're going to have to get that
dazzling aura as fast as possible here.
>> Yeah. And even like I said, even next
turn, we're not going to be able to do
it. Um, looking at these locations, uh,
was considering if there were to be an
Elder Dragon out here, move it, but
don't need to. Doesn't want to have to
reconquer the sigil of the storm is what
this looks like of why we're keeping
that there because we have to uh,
recycle one of our runes whenever we do
it. However, the mind spplitter is
waiting. So, we'll see if we, you know,
we kind of have to move it for that
reason because or else we're just giving
our unit for free. Although, we don't
want to recycle. That is one of the
great things about this battlefield for
Misfortune is it forces your opponent to
recycle in those early turns.
>> I wasn't 100% sure. I might have seen a
hidden blade in Rocklo's hand. We'll
have to see what comes of it. I think I
saw Defy as well. So, he does have some
tricks available to him here. So, of
course, you are going to get that mind
splitter point. Get on the board here
for Bounty Hunter.
>> Now, I guess the question becomes,
can you close out this game? Like
obviously, uh, okay, sabotage.
>> Yep. Lots of hand information here.
>> And it's defied.
>> Yep.
>> Might be trying to hide that hidden
blade to be honest with you.
>> Oh yes, for sure. Whenever you can defi
defy a sabotage, you are pretty much
forced to. It just gives way too much
information on top of the discard.
>> Yes. Okay, last rights.
>> And last rights has been a big key card
in this deck overall because you are
running so few units whenever you're
able to conquer and hold. Being able and
also the play of just recycling the two
cards.
>> Uh you're able to put your elder dragon
that died earlier back into your deck
and be able to summon it once again are
the big things. However, it's not really
too useful right now as we haven't been
playing those elder dragons because we
don't have the Aurora quite yet.
You are going to add the additional
might there but uh see okay. All right.
So a little uh additional uh little draw
there.
>> Yep.
>> Mobilize adding an exhausted rune
>> trying to set up for a big turn. But the
big thing is Azir just needs a double
conquer here to finish out this game.
>> Seventh point has been scored. And
remember with the champion unit, the
sovereign, it'll be able to bring over
that sand soldier to try and close out
that eighth point
>> for three
>> BF sword.
>> They're getting bigger.
>> Trigger.
>> Yep.
>> And here they come.
>> Yeah,
>> your army is ready.
>> All that.
>> Let's just see if he has an answer here.
>> It's enough might. Rocklo might not even
need to at all use the hidden blade.
Yep. And we're adding up the might here
from the sand soldiers to see if there
is any possibility of doing anything. We
do see that flurry of the blades in
hand, but with no elder dragon on board,
not going to be able to do much here.
>> There's a scoop.
>> Yep.
>> Well played by the zir player. This is
an arena greatest game, however, and
these are the ones you almost I don't
want to say expect to win, but you hope
to win these games with arena's
greatest. It is a bit more of an uphill
climb from here. And looks like in game
two, we will see the Forgotten Monument
for the Misfortune deck. And really,
Forgotten Monument and Sigil of the
Storm kind of act similar to each other
where they say you really don't want to
go here and they try to slow your
opponent down. However, we saw that not
really be an issue for the Azir deck. I
would say that this battlefield is even
a little bit weaker for the Aurora
player. Of course, the Aspirin's Climb
being the strongest one. So, we'll have
to see what can be done here.
>> That's actually curious. I'm glad you
bring that up. Why do you think they've
chosen to go with the forgotten monument
over something like Aspirin's Climb,
which which you would think in that
second game, a pivotal game would
perhaps close it out a little easier?
>> Well, at the end of the day, you still
have to win two. So, you have to get a
win with both of them. And it makes
sense to go for this when you are going
first where aspirin's climb just slowing
the game down even more. You feel pretty
confident going into it.
Going second here,
we do have the uh Trafarian War camp as
well. That's going to provide uh a lot
of utility to kind of amplifying the
might reach of the token units. And
there we go.
>> Dorne shield into a sand soldier.
>> And something to note here too, we are
on the Trifarian War camp. And because
of that, these Gusts, if they are still
on the main board, there is a potential
that they were sideboarded out as we saw
how they didn't do all that much in the
last game. but they are mo much less
likely to hit if they are still on the
main board. Looks like we have Catalyst,
uh, Flurry, and Sabotage as options here
from the stack deck. And looks like we
might be taking the sabotage because we
know they have gear or potentially gear
hate at this point. Uh, players, even
though we knew about the salvage in the
main deck, if they didn't have it,
players would assume that they had
sideboarded in at this point. So,
playing the sabotage makes a lot of
sense here.
>> And you saw Rockler think for a second
though, I want to defy this and
ultimately decided, you know what? I you
can take a look at this. I got couple
gas. I got shadows call. And you can see
the defy I have that I did not want to
use.
>> And so, uh,
>> I really like this play
>> of not using the defy here. Your hand
really didn't have that high of value
things like, oh, you toss a G, you toss
a defy, it's not a big deal. Instead of
you play defy, yes, you get to save some
hand information. However, you you are
losing a rune, which doesn't feel that
great either. So, I really like the idea
of saying, you know what, you got the
sabotage. That's fine.
>> And it's almost fair to say to some
degree, you know, they probably have a
defy. Like, let's be honest, right? Most
players are playing three of uh when
they when they start to have a decent
hand there. You can almost assume that
they're going to have the defy anyways.
So, yeah, I absolutely agree that thing
will come in handy later on. And then
what really gets you is when you play
that second defy that they're not
necessarily expecting.
>> And we will see what we get here next.
Of course, we have the catal or we saw
catalyst earlier, but we don't have it
in hand. We have another sabotage in
hand, which isn't worth it,
unfortunately. Lunar boons are ready to
go. We need to be able to draw and ramp
something that I don't Another sabotage.
Interesting.
>> Yeah, that's a little soon, maybe.
>> Yeah. Well, the issue is that you're not
really ramping up into what you want to
play.
>> Uh although you don't have the direct
answer, it's interesting when you know
there's no gear hate in the hand. Mhm.
>> Okay. Catalyst of Aons channel two
runes.
>> That's going to progress their game
plan.
>> They hold.
>> Yep.
>> Yes. These lunar runes will probably be
drawing in the next turn here pretty
soon.
>> And that's when we'll kind of expect
potentially for that Aurora to come down
in the future if we actually find it.
We've seen plenty of games now where
Aurora just didn't turn up.
>> And that's one of the things, right,
with Aurora, it has a very binary play
style of like, did I draw it? Did I not
draw it? And it's part of the uh perhaps
frustration for players playing and
playing against Aurora itself. And you
were actually right to call out earlier
where it's like in this case we uh we
happen to know that Rocklo was playing
two salvages. If there is a third on the
sideboard, you would maybe expect him to
perhaps bring it in or uh I mean another
great option too. Uh Ash Focus is a good
option as well. I think in the main
board uh he only had one single call a
week. could consider perhaps more of
those, but we're going to see the second
guardian angel come out. And of course,
it's going to be alongside a sand
soldier.
>> Yeah. And I really like how we aren't
equipping these guardian angels onto the
sand soldiers and saying we have high
you higher value targets that we can use
those for.
>> It's funny, we brought up we brought up
the guardian angels before as well. And
what's interesting about them too is in
in my play experience playing uh Azir
sometimes sometimes if there's no better
option having if you know you have two
out you have one sand soldier with the
guardian it's almost like like a a
reason not to attack that battlefield
right so we'll have to see if uh I mean
clearly I think it's going to go on the
Azir sovereign and then we'll have to
see what the target is for the second
>> it's not always it's obviously it's not
about the might there it's about the uh
the effect for the guardian angel so
we'll have to see how they play this
out.
>> So, we do see Gust in the stack deck and
also going to Ham. We now have two Gust
in the hand. So, we might be seeing some
of these tokens get removed here, which
would be possible at the battlefield. On
top of that though, we are still missing
Aurora and we have dug through a good
portion of our deck at this point.
>> Yeah, this is actually kind of crazy.
And the key thing is as well, um yeah,
with with Gust, if you're able to gust
away these sand soldiers, this kind of
dissipate, right? they kind of just
disappear because unfortunately you
can't play a sand soldier from hand. So
it is a really good tool there. It's not
going to work on the tofaring war camp
but it might also be an option
elsewhere. We have the high the eye of
the herald coming down as well. There
are options and Rocklo is considering
their play.
>> So if you're Azir here, how good are you
feeling?
>> I'm feeling pretty good. I mean if you
haven't seen Aurora yet and you know you
kind of take a good deep long stare into
your opponent's eyes try to figure out
how they're feeling. Maybe you'll feel
better if you're starting to see a
little bit of despair come across the
Aurora player. And there is Arise. This
is going to be a big infusion of
additional power here.
>> Oh yes, Arise. There's so much equipment
out. So, we are getting a lot of sand
soldiers and two of them will be
readied. Although, we're not as
concerned about the readyied part. We're
more about wanting to just create those
sand soldiers to put pressure on the
board. Because at this point, even if we
were to hit Aurora and hit an elder
dragon, well, it's it is just killing a
bunch of sand soldiers at the end of the
day. It'll be interesting to see if
these sand soldiers continue to stay at
their locations or not. Can I get
>> Looks like they we're moving at least
one back here.
>> Yeah, looks like Rox was deciding to
say, "Okay, you know what?
>> We got the points. Let's pull them
back." Playing safe. But you are right.
a Elder Dragon wouldn't be able to
completely wipe the board if he had
thrown all of them into the uh into the
battlefields, but at the same time,
there's there's nothing on the field to
play for for our bounty hunter player.
So, as a result,
>> they got to dig here.
>> And it's it's not Aurora.
>> Yeah, this is just tough as I mean that
is the big part of the deck though.
Sometimes you just don't draw the right
part of your deck and we will see a
fading memories. What will the target
be? It has to be a gear because it can
only hit a unit at a battlefield. So, it
must be some gear.
>> Would imagine maybe. H
>> Oh, good.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Lost rights.
>> Say maybe one of the gas.
>> Mhm.
>> Does receive temporary so we will know
very shortly here.
>> Lot of tok to token management part of
being an Azir player. Uh
>> he dies continuously.
>> Okay. Yeah, it was one of the gas.
uh fading memories. What do you mean?
>> And uh it looks like there's some
clarification about uh the whether or
not the Azir sovereign actually dies
because it does
>> the way the rules work, it does kind of
take on the temporary tag, correct? From
the Guardian Angel.
>> Uh just the gear can be just the gear,
right? That's right. It wasn't in the
battlefield. That's right. It was not in
the battlefield and so the gear was
targeted. So as a result, the Azir
Sovereign does in fact survive.
>> Yep. And we get that clarification
there, which is great.
>> I've not seen it.
>> Is that only one card left in hand for
our Azer player here?
>> It certainly would appear so. I mean, I
don't I don't He doesn't look very
concerned. Maybe that one card is all he
needs.
>> I mean, if I had an army like that, I
wouldn't be too concerned either.
>> That's right. They're protecting the
king.
>> Let's see what happens here.
>> But I think like even
>> Oh, we have a judge call happening now.
It might have been over the interaction
with the guardian the guardian angel and
the temporary effect being applied.
>> For me though, if I'm a zir, I'm feeling
pretty confident here. You have an
amazing board. They have nothing on the
field to play. But you can also never
count out an Aurora player, but at the
same time, if you're playing Aurora, you
would certainly hope it would have been
out by now.
>> Yeah, I needed
>> Oh, yeah. I mean, it has to come down
earlier. Turn three is the dream. Turn
four is almost a necessity. And we are
not quite there.
>> [cough]
>> Both [clears throat] these players
sitting at 40. Critical game for them as
they try to advance to day two.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Both are 4 and0. Both
have had amazing runs here. It looks
like the judge is coming back to provide
the the call.
>> That's what I thought. So the temporary
only activates.
>> Yeah.
>> And it was based on the temporary call.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> You have moved past that point.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay.
It looks like we'll get clarification
here shortly.
Retain temporary for the turn.
>> Rift balance is one of those games
there's always something to learn.
>> Retains temporary.
>> Oh yeah, there's so many interactions.
>> There it goes. So it does get the
temporary temporary.
>> Okay.
>> At the next beginning.
>> Correct.
>> So I can equip again and he stays
temporary forever.
>> I see. Okay. [laughter]
>> Stays temporary forever.
>> Yes. From the
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> Yep.
>> I love that response.
>> I can use this
>> again. We keep seeing the spirit of
riftbound in full play here.
>> An intense match, but you can't help but
laugh.
>> Right.
>> Yeah, sure.
>> Okay, there it is.
>> We've we've seen uh the disarming rate
come down a number of times. And that's
going to be a recruit scoring a single
point.
>> And then I am absolutely sure you're
going to take that sixth point as well.
>> No reason not to.
>> Uh I have damage trigger. making another
recruit here with the eye of the herald.
>> Sure.
>> Try and decide. Yeah, I believe
>> I will
>> needs to be played there.
>> Action happening here and it's going to
be a gust.
>> Mhm.
>> The sand soldier
>> onto that sand soldier.
>> Going to remove the eye of the heralds
as well.
>> Yeah.
>> Um,
>> this is looking a little dire here.
>> Yep.
go to Skunk to seven.
>> So now they are threatening to win the
game on holds on the next turn.
>> Yes. Lots of opportunities available
here for the Azir player.
>> This is amongst the widest boards I've
seen in a while. I've seen it from
Victor every once in a while.
>> Move,
>> but sure.
going ahead and stacking this whole
battlefield here, saying like I just
need to hold one of these. Even if you
do pull an elder dragon from well an
Aurora, do we even have the number of
runes for Aurora next turn? Three, four,
five, six, seven, eight. Yes, we do have
a potential of Aurora next turn
>> if we can draw it.
>> Yeah, but even I I don't see it's
another Gus for War camp. That is going
to be a quick two and
Rocklo getting the win here with Azir
going 5-0.
And it was one of those games where like
the misfortune. It never saw dowsing
Aurora once. Like not once. The deck
right now. He's like, where is it?
>> Unbelievable. It's one of those things
where it's just is it at the bottom of
the deck? He should have he should have
allowed Rockler to shuffle the deck.
Maybe maybe shouldn't be shuffling
himself. It's one of those situations
though. But that's the risk with Aurora.
It's like it's one of those decks that
it really has a single game plan. And if
you don't I mean I was going to say if
you don't execute on the game plan. You
can't even execute on the game plan if
it never ends up in your hand at all.
>> Yeah. You could be the best player in
the world and play Aurora and have a
game like that and there's really
nothing you can do.
>> That's one of those situations where
like you're like well I was destined to
lose. I think I played perfectly. I was
destined to lose that one because no
matter what I wasn't able to to get the
win there. But I mean it's also
important to understand that uh you know
Rocklo had designed the deck to be ready
for this meta. Now, the salvages in the
main board or sorry, in the main deck
didn't didn't have to come out really,
but they were there and he was prepared
if the situation arose.
>> Oh, yeah. The salvage main deck, I'm
sure, have hit multiple things
throughout this tournament and they're
going to hit lots more. And the good
news, there's still a lot of tournament
left to go for them to hit it.
>> All right, we're going to send it over
to the desk with a winners interview.
Thank you so much for that toss. I'm
Bear Bryant joined by the prolific
Rocklo here. currently now 5-0 with Azir
and if you don't know this man everybody
at home he has been playing Azir for
quite some time now you actually own
three best of Azir wins so far so it's
no surprise to me that you've brought
that legend here I don't necessarily
want to talk about the match I'll be
honest it was a little f it was a little
quick but what I do want to ask you is
coming into this tournament you know
Azir seems to be your sort of bread and
butter and why do you think it's
necessarily a good deck right now
because a lot of people think it's an
upandcoming sort of deck and is really
good against the format and I think you
just kind of showed us why it's just
quick enough to get on the board against
these Aurora decks. Why do you think
it's good? I think the deck is great
because it can like deal with a lot of
things and it's like a deck that um is
never the best deck in the format, but
it it can be the can be the best deck in
a specific format because the thing is
uh the deck dies to collateral damage
when for example um uh a lot of seals
were played and uh there were like some
gear removal main deck everywhere left
and right. Uh he was just weaker just
because of that. So I feel like right
now even though a lot of people are
respecting Aurora, they are not trying
to destroy Aurora, they are trying to
rip Aurora from the hand and Azir
doesn't have a big problem with that. So
um I think the deck is great.
>> Yeah, and we even saw how large of a
board state the deck can really get at
this point. And I want to say too, we
talk about a lot right now how Fury is
being a little mis like under
represented in the format right now. You
know, like the fall of Draven like not
being as prevalent in the game. And I
don't know about you, but when I'm
playing Gazir, the less people running
around with thermo beams, the better.
So, it just feels like it's just this
perfect situation where this deck can
really thrive right now. But my last
question I want to ask you is, do you
feel confident right now that you might
take home a fourth best of Azir? You're
currently 5-0. You need one more win to
get to a lockin for day two. How are
your games from the rest of the matches
across the day so far?
>> Um, I'm quite confident uh that I can
get the fourth best of his. I also don't
understand why other people are even
trying to do it because uh every
tournament I was there I topped I was
the highest Azir except for one where I
think I was the second highest and the
other guy won the tournament. So if you
are not confident to win the tournament
with Azir don't don't bring [music] it.
>> Well you heard it here folks from Rocklo
himself moving on 5-0. Thank you so much
for that great interview but we're going
to go ahead and send it back.
>> Bye-bye.
All right continuing the round. That was
a first that was a fantastic first match
that we saw there. And again, this is an
Azir player that is so remarkably
talented, has already won four best ofs
and apparently just wants to collect
more best of Azir.
>> It's a good one to collect some best of
for sure, especially when Azir is not
only just a best of card, it's one that
can actually win the tournament as well.
>> And if you're watching, you're probably
thinking, well, that was a quick round
there. Well, don't you worry cuz we got
more games for you. Let's go to the
decks for our second matchup of this
round here. And we do have a Rexi.
>> Yes, Rexi. Just a great deck overall
because it's a lot of fun. For one
thing, I found I find this deck to be a
lot of fun. The uh bit of gambling in it
of each time that you use the void
burrow void burrower each time. It's a
lot of fun. And also because I like its
utility that it has that you can play
cold beak, you can play hidden blade and
of course the falling star as well.
>> And showed on the screen here is a
daring porro. I mean, we all know what
pros do, but this one here, look how
beautiful that is. Uh, one card I want
to show here is void rush. Now, void
rush is a core component of the Rexai
strategy. Rex eye is a deck that wants
to be aggressive. Now, when it was
introduced in Spirit [music] Forge, it
was all about utilizing void rush, get
those uh get those units on the field of
play, score those points, but that
doesn't mean it does not have other
tricks up its sleeve. It also runs cold
week.
>> Yes. And overall, this deck is very high
tempmpo and it does really well into
decks that it can go under. It scores
points early and often, which is kind of
similar to the Darius aggressive decks
that we've seen in the past. So, seeing
this have a little bit more utility with
it as well as you talked about with the
cold week and the hidden blade. And of
course, I want to highlight inferna
which has been a new card in unleash
that has really put some of these fast
decks over the top. We've seen her
perform extremely well. She does well
over and over again in these fury decks,
>> especially as an ambush card. Going to
the second deck. This is a legend that
you might not see all that often, but
you know who is bringing Ranata. Now,
Ranata has a very interesting build
here. It's one of those uh decks that uh
as again, you want to utilize gold as
effectively as possible. Wages of pain,
which is an absolutely remarkable card,
finally makes its way into a deck here.
Um I love its utility. not only as a
potential hidden card, but we've talked
about so often that three damage is a
threshold that you often have to meet in
order to get rid of high value targets.
Of course, and once again, we want to
highlight the uh prevalence of gear hate
and cardate with the Ash, for instance,
being able to look at your opponent's
hand and banish a card for the meantime.
And of course, we have salvage, which
has been a key part into decks of being
able to to destroy gear, whether it be
Aurora or whether it be equipment as
well.
>> Of course, you do have Ranata, the uh
the chosen champion, which I [music]
mean, it's all about utilizing your gold
to the best ability to pay those power
costs alongside [music] the time warp,
which of course can close out the game.
Now, let's go to the action here. I
believe they're getting ready to get
started, so let's take it from the top.
And we have the Star Spring here. An
excellent card choice overall,
especially for neutral battlefields
because it allows you to essentially
take control of two battlefields if
you're able to take uh the Starring
early because of the balance effect that
it has.
>> And Val's layer is not going to allow
people to reposition themselves,
preventing them from going back to base.
It's a plundering portal getting started
for you know who.
So, one thing that I love about Ranata
is you can kind of often tell how
they're doing by just seeing how much
gold is on their board. The more gold
they generated, the better off theata
player is because they will just get you
with these time warps and of course the
champion itself, too. It's very sneaky.
So if it gets a few points on board, you
have to be very afraid of it because
just if it just gets enough gold and is
able to play those units and play that
time warp, then it can steal wins from
as little as four points.
>> We're going to get our first point here
uh from the plundering Porro and it it
just may plunder. We'll have to see
here. Looks like there's some uh
>> not entirely sure. But one thing I
really like here about uh the the Rex
side play here is you are starting with
two bodies on the field of play. You
want to be as aggressive as possible.
And it's interesting because I don't
think they're like, you know what, I'm
going to go 4 and0 and you know, 4, I'm
going to meet a Ranada. So, this is
actually pretty interesting because both
of them are probably teching for
everything except what this matchup is.
Like, there's no way anyone would be
like, hey, you know what? Oh, yeah.
Round four, we're going to have or round
five, we're going to have Rexi Rada.
That's what's amazing about this game.
When you're chasing best of you, you
can't anticipate what that path is going
to look like. It is a true adventure as
you go. And as a result, we have a very
interesting match here. We already have
two gold tokens being generated here and
uh
>> it looks like we have something
happening on the field of play.
>> Yes. And with the card shop was card
sharp was offered. Would you like a
gold? If you are playing against
Ranatada, the answer is always no. So
great choice here from our Rexai player.
>> Yeah, you don't want to just give Ranata
additional gold where it can do the
damage that it's looking to do to you
here. Rexai considering their turn.
Yeah, the fact that Rinado is able to
get onto the board here so early is so
helpful because all these early points
and being able to just deal points later
in the game is absolutely critical for
her. And Rexi, of course, in order to
win this game needs to be even quicker
than Ranata, who isn't a very quick deck
overall, but does have a really great
start here.
>> Um,
>> yeah, we haven't quite seen their hand,
but uh there's also a lot of uh
accelerate available. We have some uh
like obviously you have Darius that we
saw prior as well which can be readied.
>> So there's lots of aggre we do have a
blood rush being played on the recruit.
>> Yeah.
>> And we'll see if I'll go ahead and take
the vile moss because there's likely a
hidden blade under for this ranata would
be the most likely card but not the only
one.
>> Yeah. I might have missed that hand
motion there.
>> We get
>> I don't think they would have blood
rushed the recruit there unless
my deck. Yeah,
>> might be on the other one. We'll see
shortly here.
>> And I'm going to pass focus to you.
>> So focus being passed.
>> Yeah. So the blood rush was applied to
the
>> faithful manufacturer.
>> Doesn't he have a blood rush? So they're
attacking with
>> So he's asking about that same thing.
>> Yeah, exactly. He might have pointed to
the the recruit to be honest with you.
>> And I like that check there. Yep. The
hidden blade coming down. Really? Yeah.
Rex, one of Rexai's fears, of course, is
hard removal. Oh, I love the Inferno
play here.
>> That's absolutely amazing there. Love
that. And you're able to save the
faithful manufacturer as well. And uh
the Inferno is going to uh pay the
price, but
>> at the end of the day,
>> I will pass it over to you.
>> Board presence is maintained and a vital
point is scored.
>> Getting nothing.
>> Great job there. And of course, we have
a ton of blue runes here because as
Ranata likes to play time warps and also
Rinata champion herself uses blue. So
using those mine runes to be able to get
those points, it makes sense that we'd
have a high amount of mind and not so
many of yellow runes.
>> We got another plundering Porro coming
in.
>> I'll collect that one gold for
conquering.
>> Yep. Granada will slowly but surely have
a whole army of gold behind her. And
that's exactly where she wants to be.
Really, Rexai didn't get that big jump
that it wants to get. Of course, the
star spring play was really good
earlier. And we will see that Ash come
down. One of those golds will go away,
but we'll get a lot of hand information
here.
>> Falling Star, Hidden Blade, and Pike.
And it's Falling Star being removed. An
excellent choice here.
>> Um,
>> here's
vanished.
>> Awesome.
>> Exactly. So the hidden or hidden blade
will still be in hand for the future,
but there are plenty of ways to navigate
that at least. And at least hidden cards
will be known a little bit more as well.
And as we see it is banished is not
recycled. U so if the uh Rexai is able
to hold, then the card will go back to
hand.
>> Let's hope Rexi can build a little bit
of a board here. Hasn't been doing much
burrowing yet.
>> Three for Rexi to base.
>> Here we are.
up here for three and pass focus
>> pass.
>> So our daring porro does have assault
one. So it is at three might and easy
trade with the plundering
>> porroger.
>> Yep. Going to reveal the top two.
>> I'll recycle one.
>> And it looks like my daring por.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. Call the week utilize to
clear the board. State ash leaves the
board.
>> Porro pays the price. Poor poor porros.
>> I don't deserve that. That was too many
poro dust in one game already.
>> It's true.
>> And then I will
>> at least it's not scuttle crab.
>> Yeah, I don't know. Which one do I like
more? Probably scuttle.
>> How many cards have
>> three?
>> Well, I mean, you get to spread the love
across all the porros, but there's only
one scuttle crab, so it gets the all the
love that you could possibly get.
>> Second one and hide here.
>> Exactly. And we will see that hidden
card potentially here.
>> A hidden blade most likely.
That is what would be assumed.
>> What a great card overall.
>> Yeah. And I love the utility of Hidden
Blade because you can target yourself,
you can target them. You have so many
options and that draw is so valuable.
>> Absolutely. And it looks like I can just
get a little glimpse of the hand.
There's an honest broker as the top
card. So, a little bit of hand
information there for us, but although
not too much.
>> I don't know if you guys caught that,
but Sadame gave the camera a little
smile there. I love that. You got to
break the fourth wall every once in a
while.
It's definitely a lot of fun to be up
there of just that extra bit away from
the crowd. You're really able to focus
really well despite the lights and
camera can make some players a bit
nervous, but it can just be fun and just
taking a little bit of a moment to enjoy
it is a great way to go about it.
>> Yeah. So, Ranatada does come in.
>> Now, that one there is capable of
scoring a point for four energy, four
power when it's at a battlefield. We're
not quite there yet. Now, keep in mind
the power can be paid via the gold,
which is part of the strategy here. And
Ranata is one of those legends that can
threaten like these jumps and points.
Like Lucian is very good at that, too,
where you're like, you know, I'm at
five, I might be okay. Then all of a
sudden, you lose the game, right? So, I
think that uh you know, we're getting
set up here for a couple good turns from
Ranata.
>> So, we will go ahead and take another
look at the top two cards and can play
one, recycle the rest with Rengar. We do
have the ability to,
>> you know, have assaults on him or but
the ambush is kind of out of the
question. Of course, we have the carry
on dredger is the other one which this
card has been surprisingly performing
very well this tournament which is a new
unleash card as well as it does make a
bird token.
>> Yeah, I absolutely love the carry and
dreger. I think it's a fantastic card
and uh it's it's great in Victor. It's
obviously great in Rexi here. and
>> keeps that consistent board presence
where allows you to kind of uh take
advantage of uh your opportunity to
score some points.
>> Just saw a falling it's a falling star.
Yeah, that was a falling star.
>> Yep. Falling star comes down taking out
the Roninata nice and quick. There was
no response here from a Ronado player.
It was just a very quick take. Wasn't
even a look at the hand to see if
there's anything that can be done. So,
uh Falling Star hitting a good part of
this combo.
Yeah, there's a degree of confidence in
casting your reactions and actions when
uh you know you're not against a player
playing defy, but there's always tricks
available up people's sleeves.
>> Yep. And Rexai is really right where
they want to be now. We have five points
on the board. We have the battlefields
on our side. There's only an honest
broker on the side being a little bit
too honest if I do say so myself. And
there aren't really great ways for to
come back. wasn't able to really get
those hold points to generate more gold.
And of course, Aronata being blown to
smithetheriness also doesn't help.
>> No. And I mean, the honest broker, of
course, you want to play it a little
earlier. It starts the train of your
gold generation.
>> Okay, Ekko.
>> We do have Ekko coming in.
>> I do love Ekko. Uh he's a really fun
card because you're able to gain
additional
>> uh energy when he dies and it just
allows you to do some funny things at
times. Was he? No, not accelerated or
anything. He was accelerated.
>> Yes, he was accelerated.
>> Trying to count the the mana price uh
mana cost there.
>> Exactly.
>> Waiting for the uh decision to be made
as to whether or not there's a reaction.
>> Uh yes, there is a hidden card on the
board. So, trying to decide if we want
to I mean, if it is a hidden blade, do
we hit the echo or do we hit our own
unit? Nope. It is a pike with the other
potential card that could be hidden
there. Um,
>> Pike is such a versatile card. It's one
of the reasons why it's so commonly
played in Fury. It's one of the best
additions that Fury has had in the set.
Very consistent across
>> combat
>> any legend that's looking to play Fury.
>> Uh,
>> yeah. Your focus. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> And it looks like the
>> I will trade
>> additional cost was paid here for this
pike as well.
>> I have a death there. I'll make it.
>> Yeah. Uh, I also have a death now. I
will recycle echo.
>> Yep.
>> To ready all my room.
Check out make sure that trade is
correct here.
>> Have three energy.
>> So Ekko's been recycled.
>> Uh runes should be readied.
>> Thank you.
>> All right, there they are for Ekko.
Reading those runes once again.
>> So lots more to be done here on this
turn. Now that we have the runes reset,
>> I'll play hostile takeover.
>> All right, hostile takeover being
played. It's going to take control.
>> Um the to clear the turret. It's going
to be Pike.
>> Where does it go? To the battlefield,
right?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah, looks like it will likely be Pike.
Trying to get a trade here of somehow.
>> Yeah, you're good to go.
>> One of the more fascinating cards um for
Ranata.
>> It's a shame that Ranata doesn't see as
much play as some other legends cuz
Hostile Takeover is actually a really
remarkably powerful card.
>> Ranata is a deck list that I would say
is just it's actually really close to
being good. It just needs a little bit
more support to being there. Of course
though, I mean, it's 40 right now. So, I
got to be careful what I'm saying here
because it's obviously not that bad when
we are at this big of a tournament and
we're seeing 40 from Ranatada.
>> Yeah, it's kind of funny. It's like
again, you don't see many Ranatas out
there. And even Sat's like, "Yeah, let
me read that again." Like, I want to
make sure that I remember what that
thing does. And the Pike's ganking
ability there being used to perfect
effectiveness coming on over getting
that additional point. And I mean,
Ranata doesn't have any gold tokens
here.
the runes are. I mean, it's advantage
RNA right now, but uh we have there's
the card sharp. I don't think you're
going to want to give
>> play.
[laughter]
>> I love that reaction to it. Just that no
thanks. I know. So, obviously Rexai has
at least known a little bit about RNA
because oftent times players will be
like, "Oh yeah, I'll take a gold." But
really, card shop sharp is a card if
someone is playing it,
>> usually the answer is no unless you are
very sure that you can do something
better with it.
and I'll draw.
>> All right. And now we're on to Sodame's
turn.
>> Yep. Gets the Pike back as the hostile
takeover has done its time. However, a
lot of value done from the hostile
takeover and we did get those score
twice essentially. So really good
overall play for the hostile takeover.
Does have some runes up still. Did lose
Ekko. So, you know, paid a pretty big
price. The big question is how will we
be able to end this game um without if
we don't have time warp especially
focus.
>> Okay, it looks like uh they're going to
be trying to score the additional point.
Go to six
>> hopeful and
>> hopeful coming down alongside a hidden
blade and this is from the
>> hopeful
>> Rex eye ability
>> and we'll play the hopeful because well
the hidden blade is only going to kill
your own unit and that's not doing all
that much here if you don't need the
card draw. However, it looks like only
two cards in hand. So,
yeah, you know, not too much left, but
there is a lot of units on the board and
Ranata doesn't really play all that many
units. Does have access to a couple
things such as like the thousand tail
watcher, for instance. So, we do have to
be really mindful here of how many units
we send up to these battlefields
>> at six points here. Uh, Satamese
definitely start Oh, goes to the
seventh. So, definitely starting to
threaten to be able to end this game
here. can either hold one of these or
perhaps try to uh cocker two next turn.
>> Yes, use the Rex eye ability there to go
ahead and accelerate that because it
wasn't played from hand which is really
cool that we can see that
>> and also does hide another card here
with that Nox is hopeful. Right. Right.
Yeah.
>> Setting up a bit of a defense here
perhaps encouraging them to go into that
carrying treger.
>> Yep. Not a bad spot. If I could see this
Granada's hand, not too many options.
Once again, we will see the honest
broker go in. And it looks like a quick
point there. We are at seven for Rex
Eye. So, if we can just hold this one
battlefield, we can win the game.
>> It'd be curious to see what that hidden
card. This is when you need a skull.
Okay, so another echo comes down.
>> Gold gives me extra energy.
>> It is accelerated
>> because I'm at five.
>> Great. Right.
>> Yep.
>> Yep. And we will see if the hidden card
is that hidden blade or a bluff
potentially or a pike could be there as
well.
>> A hidden blade and kill.
>> It is heal and blade and oh he chose Nox
is hopeful.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. Going to draw two cards. We
got that blood rush and inferna from
that.
>> That does make perfect sense. You you do
have an additional unit in the base. The
card sharps waiting to get in there.
Could obviously challenge that
battlefield. Why not get some hand
advantage there and prepare to close out
the game on the next turn? So, I really
like this play of not killing the echo
because if we reset the runes here, we
potentially can lose to the time warp.
>> That's actually a great call out there.
Yeah, cuz uh you know who got to six
points there and time warp would have
been a definite threat
>> to take the bait
>> if we had I can't tell what the bottom
runes are. We do have to have four mind
runes to be able to play that time warp,
but that is what this player was likely
looking at.
as Adam is going to consider here how
they can close out the game.
>> I'll use blood rush on bird and recruit
here.
>> Okay.
>> All right. Blood rush going to the bird
as well as the recruit. One of each. It
was played repeated.
>> So is able to do that and take that
first point at bile layer.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. So now we just need one more
battlefield cocker here.
>> So I'll draw a card.
>> Yeah.
>> And then can it be done is the question.
>> And Darius,
>> those are two great pulls. I [laughter]
was going to say if you're going to ask
for anything, you're going to want that
Darius.
>> And he goes to the bottom.
>> Yeah, because we just accelerate here
instead.
>> Yeah.
>> Who would be the
>> I got so excited about the Darius.
>> I got excited about Darius, too.
>> We don't get to see him that often. And
usually when we do, there's a Vex in the
way.
>> 9 10 11 12.
>> Oh, counting up the might here, saying,
"All right, you have to have a dance."
>> Yeah, there it is. Game one.
>> Rexi the void burer getting the job
done. That was a fascinating game.
Really fascinating game. And uh treasure
horde. I mean, obviously, if you're
playing right now, you're going to want
to play some treasure horde. It's going
to allow you to kind of generate a
little more value, get to your game, get
to your uh your kind of final game plan
faster so you can close out the game,
get the win.
>> And we do have uh
>> I'm not sure who decided to go second.
Okay, turn first. First turn, we're
going a plundering puro from Arnata.
>> Yep. A great start for Arnata as per
usual. and we'll see what Rexai has in
response this time having a three cost
unit instead. Oh, looks like that
faithful manufacturer. Oh, here we go to
game two
>> as we will have those updated. Uh the
treasure horde.
>> I was going to say I was a little bit of
a source of confusion there. I was like,
what's going on? I feel like I'm getting
dja vu here [laughter]
>> and that game will be coming up here
shortly. Here we go.
>> Yeah, this looks right. Here we go.
>> I was going to say I feel like I just
finished talking about treasure and here
we are getting started. And I love
Candleit Sanctum, not only in Rexai, but
I just love it as a whole. I love the
agency that it gives players. I love the
decision- making. Back when Kai'Sa used
to play it in set one, I found that to
be so much fun of being able to just
peer through by a couple cards and then
be able to decide what I wanted to play.
And with Rexside, the void bur it does
really well with that, adding a little
bit more agency and consistency to the
deck.
>> Getting started here.
It was a turn one pass from you know who
and Rexi does come onto the field of
play
>> on the opening turn.
>> Whenever you say you know who wait a
second is he just being lazy over here
and then I realize oh yeah that's you
know who is up there on Ranata.
>> Yeah
>> what a great name it it's a fantastic
name. In fact I feel like uh I should be
saying it more often. This is so much
fun. We have the inferna come out as
well. Rexi is going to score a point
here
>> going into the candleit sanctum.
>> Yes. Then we'll go ahead and take a peek
at those
>> under Titan there.
>> Didn't quite see
>> I'll reveal but oh look at that.
>> So
>> the under Titan is there. Yep. Put the
Undert
the other one at the bottom.
>> Manufactur base. I will make
>> is able to play the faithful
manufacturer here. Summon a recruit.
>> Tap two playful and I will
>> Wow. What a great What just happened on
this turn? That was absolutely
remarkable. And it all started with the
uh the candle sanctum as you said you
you kind of gushed over how much you
loved it and you saw it in full effect
there.
>> Yes, absolutely a great start from
Rexai. Really close to the dream start
overall. The best here that Ranata can
do is just play this Echo and hope that
it's going to be able to, you know,
reset the runes in the future to give a
bit more ability. We see the hostile
takeover in hand. We see death grip in
hand. You know, just trying to get a
good look into that hand overall helping
us out a little bit here.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Can you fan him out a little
bit more for us there? Just kind of lean
forward a little back.
>> Rexai's coming back after scoring that
second hold point there.
>> Make him temporary.
>> That's it. Shadows call coming in. Draw
two.
>> Another card that you've talking about.
Really liking that one.
>> I love it. Look, cuz you just you got
Yeah. Send them in. Why not score a
point, draw two cards? It doesn't get
much better than that on a recruit.
>> Um
>> Yeah. Sounds great to me.
You know who it's going to have to make
some magic happen here in these upcoming
turns because this Rex eye is coming out
swinging. Darius shown and there's a
void rush.
>> We love void rush and we finally get to
see it now. We got very excited about
Darius in the past, but Void Rush really
is one of the bread and butter cards of
this deck.
>> Absolutely.
>> One to cast Void Rush.
>> There we go. Void Rush being cast.
>> Going to take a look at the uh reveal
the top two of the deck. It's a hidden
blade and it is a uh
>> hidden blades in my hand.
>> There we go. Yeah, the honest broker.
>> Honest broker. It wasn't the hit that we
quite wanted to see, but it is free, so
it's worth it.
>> Absolutely.
>> Going to call the week.
>> And there's a call the week. Echo is
going to go down here unless there's a
reaction. It's going to be a sacrifice
on the echo.
>> On echo.
>> So he will. So sacrifice being one of
the new cards of the set has done a lot
of work not only in Leblanc which is one
of the most common places we see it but
it being good in Ranata as well makes a
lot of sense as we are able to channel
runes and draw and also just a way to
kill our own echo. We saw how in the
previous game Rexai did not want to kill
that echo because that potential reset
and instead sacrifice says fine I'll do
it myself. [snorts]
>> And he's using this window of
opportunity to also hard cast to consult
a pass generate some value into his
hand.
>> All right, my recruit will die.
>> That always feels a bit bad when you get
stuck in a position where you have to
hard cast it because you can't quite
take a battlefield.
>> That is a tough spot overall.
>> He does have lots of runes up though.
Yeah. Oh, hard cast before we reset on
the echo. So, uh, use the stack in their
favor that way. So, that makes sense.
Yes.
>> Tap two for blundering poro.
>> Plundering porro coming on out.
>> It's got a bit of a wall of enemies
though. I'd be terrified if I'm that
little porro right now. But, I mean,
I'll be honest, of all the porros,
>> I mean, maybe the the veteran porro is
maybe the least afraid looking. But, I
got to tell you, the plundering porro
looks like he's ready for a good time.
And we do have Ash being played, hand
being revealed here.
>> Two fallen stars, Under Titan, Inferno,
Hidden Blade, and the Blood Rush. And
it's going to be one of the falling
stars which is going to get thrown out.
>> Yeah.
>> Which makes perfect sense.
We've seen that card do absolute wonders
in this tournament thus far.
>> Yes. And a reminder that it is only
banished. It is not in the recycle the
trash.
>> You're right. You got to hold to get it
back.
And with this Rexside deck, it's very
possible that we do. And we saw how
Falling Star did so much just killing
the RNA very quickly last game. And
that's why that was the first choice for
you know who right away. And I'm
assuming that this Falling Star will be
played sometime in the future as well,
just because we have the board presence
already. So eliminating their board
presence is all we really need to do.
>> So Honest Broker is going into the
candle at Sanctum.
He
>> is carefully considering how he wants to
reorder these cards.
It is a tough decision overall because
you have to decide are these cards worth
what's you know more what's in my deck
and also too the fact that you can order
these the way that you want too. If you
have two that you do want you can put
them top and bottom decides I don't want
either
>> and hidden blade
>> and looks like we have that under Titan
once again.
>> I'll refuse to play either of them.
>> He's choosing not to play either.
>> Mhm.
>> So I have two floating now.
is taking a look at that hand to see
what else we want to do. Does have
multiple runes available to him
>> here. Pass focus.
>> Let's go up to that fifth point.
>> Go to five.
>> We'll see. Looks likely not using that
treasure horde where you can pay one
energy to make a gold.
Tells us there's other options in hand.
I mean, we saw the inferna as being an
ambush card. We have blood rush as well.
a few options to react to the opponent.
But
>> yeah, and at the end of the day, like
yeah, I mean, getting the gold tok I
mean, you do have the Darius, the
Rengar, and of course the falling stars
that could utilize the gold token,
>> but perhaps he has something better
planned for us in this. Oh, he's the
golden. I was going to say you got a
couple options there. You can use it.
>> Yeah, especially after we know that the
falling star is in hand and there is one
banish as well. So, I really like taking
the gold token here, especially if you
don't have a plan to use these uh runes
in another way.
I'll go two recycle two. I'm going to
fall
>> critically for Oh, there's a falling
star.
>> Yeah, the big thing is Ash is above that
three might threshold. However, it does
uh take out a lot of the units here
pretty effectively and you're going to
get two for one almost for sure if you
don't falling star this. And falling
star, it is technically a one for one,
but when you blast the same unit, it
almost feels like a two for one at
times. But I like this play from the
Rexai player a lot because it just takes
that extra tempo off the board. You
don't want Ranatada to be able to
establish herself at these battlefields
at all. When Ranada holds once, maybe
twice, you're in a really scary
position. And Rexai understands that you
cannot let Raada hold. And we have
another Echo here coming out once again.
>> Yeah, I'm assuming it's going to be
accelerated here. We'll have to see or
not accelerate. Okay, we'll have to see
what uh what the play is here.
>> Lot of cards in hand, lots of options.
It's death grip. Okay, so you're going
to apply that power. You're going to
reset your runes. Give that power to the
plundering porro.
>> I'll react to him by tapping two
>> play and I'll give him
>> the plundering porro. As we said, I said
that the might was really critical here.
And that's why we use that falling star
onto a four might. So being able to give
that additional might to the plundering
porro to potentially look at overtaking
this battlefield could be really strong
here. Let's see if Rexai has an answer
to it. I mean there are a couple options
uh such as like you know if there were
long swords but I don't believe we do
have those
>> in this list.
>> Yeah, that plundering pro I believe was
at seven. You had the uh
>> yeah would have been at seven would have
been seven versus six there as shown in
the display.
>> So yep, plundering and porro does its
job and we'll be able to take the
ranada's first point here and also
create a gold as well.
The treasure uh the treasure horde does
have a hidden card there which does
complicate things ever so slightly. Now
we're going to have to find out what
that is. You don't want that hidden card
just dissipating.
>> Is it Pike? It's a hidden blade. He's
going to target his own unit. Draw two
cards.
>> Get a gold from aes.
>> Yep. Great way.
>> And I saw a call of weak there.
that is going to be uh I mean plundering
pro is not the best target but you have
the board and they don't and maybe you
wipe out that plundering porro and that
call the week comes down and answers
whatever comes out of the hand next we
do see the uh
>> play the other falling star
>> yeah a big hit here with that coal would
be the RNA herself if she does come out
on board we did see her come out last
game and get nuked by a falling star
almost instantly and we know that one
falling star is banished one has been
played so if we are able to hold maybe
we get the falling start back. But
that's what Ranata's really tried to
stop here. That's why we had that
plundering poro play.
>> And there is that Ranatada that we
talked about.
>> Yeah. And on that battlefield, it does
>> it does threaten. I mean, I think they
got enough cards in hand here. There's
the honest broker, but you're going to
want to try to be able to score that
extra point, but not right now. I mean,
you're you're kind of far behind, but at
the same time, you can't allow them
>> to get to that critical sixth point that
then threatens to win the game on the
next turn.
>> Yeah. I mean, it's one of those things.
It's now or never. It doesn't feel good,
but it's an absolute critical part to
just say, "Well, got to go for it now or
else Rexai is just going to be too
aggressive and run me over."
>> Attack recruit here.
>> There's the uh the attempt at the six
point
>> trigger reveal trigger and pike.
>> We do have some options here with the
pike and the birds as I like to call
them.
>> Yeah. And I mean they get the benefit of
tacking as a crew and uh you do have a
nice big board state here and so they
would be bene benefiting from that.
>> Not either.
>> Not taking either.
>> Crimson Pigeons. There they are. Back to
the bottom of the deck.
>> There's nothing wrong with being a 35.
That is an absolutely beautiful stat
line for a deck that wants to go wide on
the board.
>> Rexite.
>> We have the hostile takeover coming down
here. Now
>> I'm still attacking here, right? So
would it be assigned defender?
>> Yes. So he would be assigned defender.
He would lose one might. So he
>> obviously this player has been playing
the hostile takeover a number of times
in this list.
>> Yeah. And it looks like uh Rexi is
likely the target.
>> So to this battlefield, right?
>> So now it's
>> Rexi will join the other side for now.
We're now playing a deck.
And I really love this hostile takeover
on the Rexai because Rexi's ability of
being able to accelerate units that
don't come from hand. So if there was a
way to, you know, play recruits or
something like this, Rexi could
potentially give a way to take this
battlefield back. But now, because the
Rexi is no longer on the Rexai side of
the board, we can now make sure that
there isn't going to be anything really
sneaky coming from Rexi. So a really
smart play from you know who here.
>> All of them.
>> Yep.
>> This is yours.
>> All right. Looks like they're uh
>> um I'll conquer
>> sorting out the results of that play
>> and then I'll trigger candle sanctum.
>> Yeah,
>> candle sanctum being triggered. So I'll
call the weak and a porro.
>> One top, one bottom.
>> Yeah, really looking for these final few
points.
>> Um as does get scary with the more runes
and more gold that she has. Of course,
time warp, but at 7 to one, feeling
pretty good as a Rexai player. There is
that cold the week that you brought up
earlier. really going to try to hold
this battlefield for the win, but also
does have the ability to attack in
later. And there are plenty of
accelerates in this list as well. So,
lots of options here.
>> Completely exhausted on the rune side.
We need a miracle from you know who
here. And if anybody can manufacture a
miracle, it's Ranata.
>> Exactly. So, we do see that time warp in
there. Essentially a dead card in hand
at this moment in time. And it looks
like we will be paying two gold.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. Very nice.
>> And then tap two more for blundering.
>> I I honestly I love Shen uh sand
shifter. That is such a great It's
basically a call to week with a body
which is really kind of cool.
>> Well, not necessarily. You get to target
the uh a unit with negative three might.
>> Three might or less is able to take it
out and exactly worked really well here.
It also does have six might, which is a
big body on board and something that
Ranata kind of misses in a lot of cases.
So, being able to have the six might
body to potentially contest these
battlefields can make a big difference
here if Ranata is to get back into this
game.
>> You're looking for something accelerated
here. Void rush. Is it a pike or no?
It's a Rengar. That's going to do
>> recycle one to play void rush.
>> Does have the ambush mechanic, but
cannot go to an empty battlefield. Has
to go to something that is
>> There's the pike. That's
>> Yep. There is Pike.
>> That's the accelerated need. There we
go. The eighth point.
>> Sadame does get the win here.
>> Goes 5-0. And it's Rexai defeating
Ranada.
>> Can you believe that we have a Rex Eye
that's 5-0? I mean, just one more win to
go to day two. And in our last
tournament in RQ Sydney, we didn't have
any Rex eyes go into the into the tops
uh to day two. At the end of the day, I
love the way Rexside plays. It's an
extremely aggressive deck and I I got to
give my flowers to uh to the to you know
who because Ranata is an incredibly
challenging legend to pilot and uh I
mean if you're chasing that best of
Ronald is a good choice. You don't see
that much meta penetration from Ranata
and at the end of the day Rexi is going
to score those rapid points very fast
which is exactly what we saw there.
>> Really that deck is kind of one of
Ranata's worst nightmares. Ranata really
wants to play into much slower decks
that she's able to establish a board,
hold a bit, sneak in a few points, and
then play that time warp or the Ranata
herself. So, that was a really tough
matchup for a Ranata player. And the
good news is they're still in the
running for day two and still likely in
the running for that best of as well.
>> We have more Riftbound action for you
coming in round six. Let's take it to
break.
>> [music]
>> Does anybody have any hot takes?
Okay, big question time. Aurora gets
played. What do you do?
>> Cry concede.
>> I do thrill the hunt on my binder and
then they can't do anything. Banish a
card. I win the game.
>> Well, as a yellow deck, I grab my uh
whatever the one with the crates on it
and I play that and say I'm choosing the
Aurora. Bye-bye. And then I press call
the week.
>> An Aurora is put on board. What do you
do?
>> Kill it as fast as possible with
everything I have.
>> Uh, cry most of the time, but uh, it
depends. There's a lot of decks that
have ways around it, but it's all up to
chance after that. So, just got to go
for either end the game quickly or deal
with infinite dragons.
>> Not the dragons.
>> Starcross fizz turn to dust. Uh, game
one. Hope I'm high enough on points and
have some kind of an answer. Uh, if not,
I just cry. Game two, hope that I don't
get mind splittered.
>> Uh, hope it's not preceded by an elder
dragon.
>> I shake their hand and say, "Ah, fellow
man of culture." Aurora gets played. I
look down at my cards.
I cry a little bit. I look into my
opponent's eyes and then I look back
down in my hand and cry a little bit.
>> Now, that's why we do hot takes.
I'm joined here with the wonderful
Satame who we just witnessed at the end
of that round five take down that Ranata
Glass deck playing Rexi of all legends
which is pretty incredible because first
of all I also have a Rexai deck a
different version but mine uh but the
fact that you're 5 and0 at this
tournament I think is speaking leaps and
bounds right now because one I think a
lot of people are not really big on the
fury domain right now and two, Rexside
did not have a very good performance in
Sydney. Can you tell me maybe why you're
having a lot of success today? Because
you are 5 and0. You're one win away from
making day two right now.
>> Um, yeah. So, I think for sure, uh, in
this matchup, oh, I've been getting kind
of lucky. I'm running under Titans and
that card's been really good to me
today. Um, I've been flipping it a lot.
Uh, I think for this matchup
specifically, Rexi has to be a very good
matchup into uh, Ranata cuz she can't
really hold into uh, her. Uh yeah. Uh I
think the Sydney list, I'm not sure what
they were on. I didn't exactly look at
it, but I've always kind of had hope
that Rexi would be good. Just drawing
two every turn seems pretty good. Uh
yeah. No, I agree. I mean, void rush
itself, right? I mean, the fact that
it's either you get the discount on the
card or you they go to your hand
regardless, right? So yeah, you give
your opponent a little bit of
information, but um you said under
Titan. I love that card. But you're
right, it can be a little pricky
sometimes if you draw them instead of
reveal them off the top. But I actually
want to focus on your ambush units. You
know, this is kind of a more focus
leaning on like the swarm package that
some people were maybe playing in Spirit
Forge. But the ambush units being
another way to help get your units on
the board or be extra like reactive
defensive tools because I will say
sometimes with Rexi, you know, you get
all these extra discounts, you generate
all this extra energy that you don't you
have enough to keep up and the amish
units feel like a really good slot into
the deck to kind of have use for that.
>> Oh yeah, for sure. I think uh inferna
being two and no recycle um is a little
absurd. It's three damage right on
board. can't be defied. They can't
really do much about it. On Star Spring,
you can even pull your other guy back. I
think Rexi is a lot of pushing low
commitment units up and
letting them die and build up a
backboard and then under Titan you can
slam it down. It's no longer a brick.
It's been working pretty good for me.
>> Absolutely. And you still have things
like, you know, Darius, Trafarian. I I
would say, is there maybe a matchup
you're trying to avoid right now?
Because I can imagine Vex Apathetic
still being a little rough, right?
>> Well, actually, I've been having very
good success into Vex. Um, I think a a
lot of it is the fact that uh I'm
running calls. Um, Rex eye typically I
can take a turn to just develop and then
push up afterwards and that seems to
work really well for me. Um, matchups I
don't like. Draven, uh, I leave things
up at the battlefield. They'll draw
Infinity surprisingly. Vi is pretty bad
for me. Wow. Vi can continuously untap
and pull back and they don't commit
anything to the board and it's really
bad for me. And then, you know, anything
that generates sprites is pretty bad,
too. But I I've been seeing luck not
seeing those.
>> All right, avoid the Lilia for sure. And
you named two other decks that are not
really represented. But so Tommy, thank
you so much for that insight because
honestly, I think you're a great
showcase of Rexi still having some real
force here in the format. But that's
going to be it for this interview.
Thanks so much and good luck on your
round six.
>> Thank you.
>> All right, we are at the cusp of round
six. I'm joined with Ursa Day. How you
doing? I'm having so much fun. I got to
walk around during round five. Get to
talk to some of the players. I chatted
with Gailwinds, who I think was from
round one with Ailia. He is 5 and0 right
now, which is very exciting. Uh, a lot
of the different players are still doing
really well that we've seen today. Um,
>> I think the Poppy did end up losing its
first match, but a lot of players still
going strong today. Yeah, I mean round
six is the one where we can, you know,
you can finalize going to day two with
the 6 record. Uh, which is going to be
really nice. We're going to actually
look at some of the standings as well.
See who's on the cusp of qualifying for
day two. Let's check them out.
>> Let's see.
>> All right. Is that a 50 le rank one?
Terry the cactus hanging out. We've got
Leblanc like you've been saying. Uh this
the Rex eye we just saw last round as
well. Confirmed 50. Uh, we see Leblanc.
I think we saw Flex Duel Han earlier
today, too. So, with that, Yasua, are
there any repeats off this top 10? I'm
not
>> I see Leblanc two times.
>> Two times. Where's the
>> two times?
>> I'm sorry. I must have been looking at
the illusion there. So, [laughter] that
is right. But yeah, having it at second
and fourth. Very nice. We see Civer,
which we haven't seen today. Kha'Zix,
one that I know both of us would love to
see, but honestly, just a lot of
different decks already in the top 10.
Just one win away from qualifying for
day two. Yeah, and I think I talked to
another Kha'Zix as well out there that's
also 5 and0. So, really, really exciting
to see some of these decks that people
just did not expect to do so well. I
definitely did not expect a lease in and
I think if I heard correctly, I could be
wrong that I heard like there's a five
lease in that's not playing Aurora.
>> Yeah, that's what I heard uh from from
the backline. So, we also do have some
others. I do see 15th place. We've got
Vi uh 5 so far, so get one win away from
securing day two. Uh we've seen some
misfortunes like we've seen another
Kha'Zix uh Annie and Aurelia Randy who I
think we saw earlier on the stream too.
>> Yeah, there's a lot of great names here.
Obviously Randy is a well-known player.
Dwall at number 12 is uh the was the
winner of the RQ Houston. Uh and Swag
YOLO 420. Yeah. Uh also 5-0 here who had
got the best of Civer in Atlanta. So
really great player on Civer there. So
many great names.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I think that's right. And so
again, a good mix of like qualified
players and legends that we'd expect. Uh
and then looking at the top 30, a lot of
Aelas. We got a Victor. I see Extreme
Noodles 27. Haven't seen that. Uh we
also saw Rocklo earlier as well, you
know, 5 with the Azir. Very decisive
game.
>> Yeah, it was. And more Leblanc.
>> Yeah, more Leblancs. We see Kaisa
sighting uh with Cari here at 22nd place
with 5. A good amount of Aurelia. Not I
think I think have we confirmed Aelia is
the most popular I think legend today if
not one of the most
>> I'm not sure we've confirmed it today I
know it was yesterday during the PRQ so
it I mean not surprising to see Ireelia
doing so well especially after it did I
mean fantastically at Sydney
>> yeah it's it's got a lot of top aids
between this meta and the previous one
so unsurprising there going into the top
40 as well again all these are the same
record just a little bit of tiebreaker
changes some more Kai'Sa misfortune we
see Pike all right 35th send on there.
>> That is a really great one. I love Pike.
We got to see a Pike earlier, not the
same one, but I really want Pike to do
well. And a rain guard there at 40 is
really exciting as well.
>> Yeah. And uh we did see a Mastery
earlier. Uh 393. I think it's a
different Mastery player, right? Uh but
Noah here. So, uh you know, and the
previous one is at least 4-1. So, a good
record as well. Uh but again, like so
many different legends in this top 40. I
think we've got a couple more 5Os's
potentially, but uh no shortage of
diversity.
>> Yeah, no shortage of diversity at all.
So exciting to see. Obviously, another
Lilia here, actually the exact one that
I was talking about earlier. Uh I mean,
it is so cool to see that these players
are able to come up with these fantastic
decks. 5-0 is definitely not one small
feat at all. And maybe you didn't expect
these leaders to get here, but I can't
wait to see who makes day two at the
>> Yeah, I mean, we've seen uh Lilia,
Master Y, Diane. I mean, also a lot of
the players we've featured on stream,
Gail wins, I missed my Q, uh Allen ZQ,
all of them 50 right now. So, uh you
know, obviously we saw them do well on
stream and they're continuing to do so
off stream as well.
>> Yeah, it is so great. I And they're just
so passionate about these decks as well.
So, really exciting.
>> Yeah. All right, so those are uh some
sneak peeks on to uh some legends to
qualify. Let's go back to us and uh
we've got another match coming up. I
believe we got some uh potential
matchups here. Uh looking at it real
quick, we have Le. I know a lot of
people want to see I want to see what
they're doing, right? They got to be
doing something special.
>> Yeah, they have to be. So, I'm really
really excited about that. I I'm fingers
crossed. We'll have to see if we get to
watch it. Uh but it's going to be really
exciting to see. And also potentially a
misfortune. Yeah. Yeah. We actually are
going to throw it back to a community
vote. So, we'll send it to you guys real
quick. If you guys want to see Kha'Zix
versus Misfortune, a battle of body and
chaos, put A in the chat there. And then
otherwise, if you want to see Leon
versus Aurelia, a battle of calm, press
B in the chat there. Uh, man, I I I
think I'd have to say B. I think B is
the one I'd have to press, but it's
close.
>> You'd go B here. Honestly, I've been so
excited to watch Kha'Zix. Maybe I might
want A, but I don't think you'd go wrong
with either uh A or B. No. So definitely
make sure to let us know in the chat
which one you want to see again. A for
Kha'Zix versus Misfortune and B for Leon
versus Aurelia.
>> Yeah, it's going to be so interesting to
see how these players do it. I mean, I
would love to see what type of le is
five and zero.
>> Yeah. Yeah, agreed. It'd be it'd be very
very nice to see that. But again, I've
had some issues trying to find the best
way to play Kha'Zix as well. Uh
definitely something from match A uh to
see, you know, what kind of uh setup we
have. We've seen a lot of the XP
mechanic uh be used and I think Kha'Zix
is one of the uh legends that can take
advantage of it.
>> Yeah, I think it's really can and we
have I guess seen Kha'Zix in like a
couple different lists just not as
Kha'Zix by itself obviously. I think
Alan ZQ played the champion in Sydney in
his Diana list. We've seen it in some
Annies earlier today, but I'd love to
see how Kha'Zix the
legend does it himself
>> for sure. But it looks like chat has
spoken. We're going to go to match B.
It's going to be Terry the Cactus with
Leon versus Levius with the Aurelia. And
we'll have to see what the secret spice
in that Leon deck is.
>> I can't wait to see what he's cooked up
here. And it is going to be that Leon
list here first. Uh
very exciting.
>> Yeah. Yeah. We're we're [laughter]
little flashbang as we're doing. Okay.
Scanning the cards, seeing what's new.
Uh obviously we've seen no shortage of
Rengar. Uh that's been one of the
[music] I think premier cards from here.
Aurelia uh you know we're going to see
it probably on both sides of the boards
for this one as well. But being able to
have this ambush and play to a
battlefield uh mechanic is good. And
Aurelia since you can choose it with
your legend ability with blind monk uh
you can get that additional buff uh and
might which ends up being you know
pretty steady. Yeah, that will be really
nice. And I'm really excited to see like
how they end up using these Leon buffs.
Uh just because that leader is so good
at setting buffs up on different units.
You also see that it has cards like pit
rookie in here that will also help put
buffs on the units. So I'm excited to
see if they can use it, you know, to end
up winning these games. And obviously
they have been if they're 5 and0.
>> Yeah. So uh yeah, pit rookie for the
additional buff. uh monastery of Herana
uh can be a really good one-sided
battlefield as well, which is going to
be really nice. And uh yeah, so we, you
know, nothing I think too outrageous,
but I think Leon uh can take a lot of
advantages being like a little bit more
aggressive version of uh Master Yi,
which we've seen success with already,
and looking forward to see how it
patches matches up to Aurelia.
>> Yeah, this is going to be really
exciting and it's going to be that
Ireelia list next. We've definitely seen
a couple Ireelas uh throughout this set,
but I'm really excited to see here.
Obviously, we do have that Vex
Apathetic. We've talked about her a lot
today. Uh that mindsplitter, this is
that adaptatron list that we've been
seeing lately.
>> Yeah, like you're just so uh focused on
having gear hate in the main, right? So,
makes sense for that. I'm actually
surprised we only have two copies of
Stellicorn Herder in the main, which
some people say it's it's like your
champion unit sometimes, right? It just
offers so much draw potential, but
>> Scuttle Crab has kind of allowed you for
some better draw from there. And uh but
yeah, it's it's what we've got. So,
we're actually going straight to it to
the match here again. It's going to be
uh the Aurelia versus the Le and we're
going to see what it's all about.
>> Yeah. And it does look like it's going
to be that Monastery of Herana that you
mentioned. It is really nice uh like as
a buff deck to be playing Monastery
Herana. you have to spend a buff to get
to draw one. So if your opponent doesn't
have any way to buff their cards,
>> there is no text on it essentially for
them, which is very one-sided as you
mentioned.
>> Yeah, I love to have a a battlefield
where most of the time my opponent's
just going to say, "Oh, there's there's
no effect for me on this one." So I
think Monair Herana is really good. Um,
you know, there are a good amount of
buff decks. I'm sure you've played
against others with it. But by and
large, a lot of decks are just not going
to get the same draw power that you will
with that monaster.
>> Yeah, completely completely true. And it
does look like we are going to be
getting started here. Uh getting I think
our starting hand and then into our
mulligan hopefully.
>> Yep. So getting that started here. Uh
again, Le, if you haven't seen it for a
while, uh you can use its ability to
exhaust itself and pay one energy to
give a buff to one of your units. So uh
just letting you give that plus one
might to anything. If you have any like
floating runes or if you're not going to
be using all your runes, having a backup
usage for it is pretty nice. Yeah, 100%.
And honestly, I feel like a lot of times
when we think of decks that use the
buff, uh you think of set Le is the one
can that can generate it at will. Well,
somewhat
>> mostly. Yeah. Yeah. More or less. Right.
So, uh I think that is important. We we
do see a dice roll here. We do see uh
Terry rolling the nine there. So, likely
going first
>> and revealing the uh battlefields there.
Yes, once again, Monastery Ferana
against Abandon Hall. Uh Bandon Hall,
one of the newer battlefields. And uh I
think Aurelia has been really enjoying
using this set.
>> Yeah, I think we're going to see it.
Really happy using abandoned hall. Uh
fingers crossed. We'll have to see how
it goes. They are just doing their
mulligans here in Riftbound. It's a
little bit of a unique mulligan in my
opinion. You get to select two cards to
go to the bottom of your deck. You do
not shuffle your deck and you draw the
next two cards. So even if you draw into
something that you're not the most happy
drawing into, you would have done it
either way. So
>> yeah. Yeah. And and honestly, four cards
don't seem like that much, but drawing
going first, being able to potentially
see six cards, right? Uh it ends up
being uh quite quite valuable, I think.
Yeah, I think it's it's in a really good
spot from a consistency standpoint. So,
uh looks like we're starting off Terry
again going first
>> and uh going to be at their two runes
here and playing out the Lonely Porro.
>> Ooh, I think this is one of my favorite
porros, especially with the arts. But
Lonely Porro, if it dies while defending
alone, it does get to have a card draw,
which is going to be really nice to be
able to keep your hand healthy. Um, so
that is really nice. It is just dies
alone, not defends alone. That's my bad.
>> Um, but it is a really nice card. And at
least we do get that first uh turn card.
>> Yeah. And we're going to use our Leon
Legend ability right off the gate there.
So, we're going to be able to be a three
might porro. Uh, we're lonely, but we're
buff. And [laughter] uh we are going to
likely spend the buff there to get that
additional card draw.
>> I didn't know that buff porros were a
thing, but very exciting.
>> Well, they tend to be lonely it seems.
So, it's not it's not all gains there.
But
>> yeah, looking on
>> spend the buff.
>> Yeah, spend the buff there on the
monastery and then getting that valuable
card draw
>> that I mean that Porro is doing a great
job at drawing cards. Uh and then on our
side, I'm excited to see uh what Levius
does here. Obviously, a lot of times or
at least in set two, we saw that it was
very much like a protect the queen,
protect the president deck where it was
completely built around Ireelia and or
Stellicorn Herder like you mentioned,
but there's definitely a lot more units
in the deck now.
>> Yeah. So, we're going to play a scuttle
crab and a lonely porro. So, that one's
a little bit less lonely right now, but
uh has the potential to be lonely in the
future. Going to six runes for Terry
here. uh they could be playing out their
champion uh this turn if they so desire,
but you know, passing with three open
doesn't always have confidence in it,
right?
>> Yeah, you have to like wonder like what
they have when you decide to do that.
There's so many things that could
happen, but it does look like we're just
going to go on and play uh another unit
on on Terry the Cactus's side.
>> Yeah, the wisened elder there. Uh so you
you will get to uh buff it as well and
uh which ends up being really helpful
for it. Uh we're passing with the porro
uh open as well on the monastery just
really asking for you to uh remove it.
>> Yeah. And the the wise and elder when
buffed it does get an extra plus one
might. So that is going to be he's going
to be an extra buff elder.
>> Yeah. So currently at seven or sorry six
might on the elder there. Uh so super
helpful especially in a deck when it's
so easy to apply buffs. Yeah, that is
for sure. Um, let's see. It does look
like we are
looks like we passed with one energy or
one rune up on Terry's side. So, I mean,
there are some obviously cards that you
could see that do only cost one if we
decide to go into that um monastery of
Pirana. One of the one that I'm thinking
about is on.
>> Yep. Yep. So, we're going to play out
the Aurelia champion here. uh it's got
deflect and when you choose a ready me
you get the plus one might that can also
include readying it during the beginning
of the turn so uh you know you get to
start off next turn if you keep it uh
exhausted as a five might unit and again
that's just the beginning of it
>> yeah and she can grow so large I mean
it's kind of insane the amount of might
that you can end up finding on some of
these Ireelas it does look like we still
have those two runes up obviously and
it's going to be really important to
protect her as we continue this game
>> yeah especially like abandoned hall like
abandon Hall Defiant Dance gives you
such a big difference in might just for
one rune and one recycle. But
>> yeah, the uh Scuttle Crab is doing the
scuttling god over there to the
abandoned hall. And uh honestly, anytime
I can give Scuttle Crab more than Zero
Might, it's just it's so funny.
>> I mean, I think if if a deck could do
it, it would be Ireelia.
>> Yeah.
All right, we got the boots on the
Aurelia passing with two runes open and
Terry's going to start with three. This
lonely Porro almost doing half the job
for him.
>> Channel two.
>> Yeah, it does seem like that. We're just
holding here on that uh Herana being
able to generate more and more points as
we get set up. And it Yeah, we're just
we're pretty happy sitting here.
>> Yeah, he's he's still lonely, right? But
you know, you're getting points for us.
>> Lonely, but not buffed right now.
>> Not buffed.
Uh looks like we are going to be having
eight runes this turn though. So we
probably can play a couple units here or
at least uh a nicesized one to try to
figure out like how to deal with the
threat of Aurelia because as you
mentioned she can get gigantic
especially with that defiant dance. Uh
and only pearl probably will not survive
against her very long.
>> No. And and also you know what happens
especially with like these calm matchups
are it's kind of like a staring match.
just like I know that I'm running
discipline, you're running discipline.
Like we can really affect our might
totals during a combat. So, we have to
be really confident uh when going in.
So, we're going a six into the zero on
the scuttle crab. Uh that is offering
one XP and then showing off the hand.
[laughter]
>> All right, double on guard, discipline,
back off, punch, uh fist, and we also do
have the charm and the za's hourglass.
So, it is a Aelia whole hand.
>> What is that? [laughter]
>> What?
>> Levia says, "I think your hand looks in
Aelia hand with a with a punch in it."
>> That's wild.
>> Yeah, you mentioned that these com decks
can have a lot of might in hand. And I
think I'm counting like upwards
>> 6 10.
>> Yeah, just a lot right now. So, uh,
looks like we're going to pay six for
the le.
>> Uh, we're going to recycle to put
anything. Yeah, I mean [laughter]
you you know I only have one hidden card
there. I don't have to show you, but
>> that is going to be it. And again, the
Elder is currently at six might here. Um
and yeah, we're we're halfway there for
Terry.
>> Yeah, and we do want to attach the uh
we do want to attach the gear to
Ireelia. So, she is going to grow even
larger here. That does give extra might.
And I'm interested to see which
battlefield she goes in first, whether
it's going to be that abandoned hall
where she really I mean could
potentially use it to grow and shrink
the opponent. Uh depending with that
define dance or if she's going to come
up take out the lonely porro which does
kind of have the offside that it could
draw a card for dairy.
>> Yeah. And so another thing to mention
too for le um so it has accelerate. We
decided to not use it but uh other buff
friendly units at my battlefield have
plus two might. So currently not at a
battlefield doesn't become relevant but
uh if you are able to buff another unit
uh and be at the same battlefield you do
get that bonus. So likely was a decision
if you put it at the uh wized elder uh
you would be able to get a lot of extra
but we have the unguard here
>> asking for some interaction and yeah
gets the plus two might
>> top two.
>> Yeah and then we are going to get that.
>> Uh so we're going to start adding all of
these uh might adding spells in. I think
this is like something where like you
were saying that they like kind of have
this stare off of like I know you have
extra might
>> you know I have extra might and then
when they actually come to fight it's
like
>> sometimes you can almost play your whole
hand growing these different units.
>> Yeah. I mean like discipline is just
like such a you know supify we see it
make something smaller and draw one but
like we've got discipline we're
targeting it. We're setting it active
using the uh Aurelia legend ability. We
also have the abandoned hall. like the
we just get so much extra might from
this two energy.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Thank you. Thank you also to
our uh might totalist. Yeah, we I would
be super lost without them. Yeah. 8 to
13 off of just a single discipline and
uh setting the Aurelia active at the
start. We are going to pop the Za's
hourglass which is then going to be able
to uh save the Elder there.
and thinking on
>> Yeah. Get rid of those onas. Yeah. And
then go from there.
>> Yeah. I mean, being able to save it is
so nice, but we'll have to see. I mean,
if we can somehow deceit this Ireelia. I
feel like this is one of the big things
that you struggle with when you go into
Ireelia is just once she holds a she can
kind of just dance back and forth
between battlefields. She can get so
gigantic and then
How do you deal with her if you can't
get her off the board quickly?
>> Yeah. And uh we also have ganking thanks
to the boots right now. Uh we are just
crashing the poras. I mean they they're
lonely together I suppose. Uh a draw for
each of them. Uh which means you know
Leius might be looking for a little bit
of more card draw right now. And uh
we'll see how they end out their turn.
>> Let's see. I mean we have so many runes
still to play as well. does look like
it's going to be that charm bringing
back in that le and it is going to end
up killing le with that gigantic
Ireelia.
>> Yeah, and when you know there's not a
defy in hand uh unless they just drew
one off of the lonely poor, right? You
felt pretty confident about that. And uh
>> yeah, the Aurelia does uh you know all
of its temporary might goes away, but
again with what is it five runes open
like you're still terrified what could
be on the other side.
>> Yeah, for sure. You have to like also
wonder like what type of information
they're like pulling from that there was
one rune up. Would you have defied the
charm if you had defies in hand? So then
we have starting to think like maybe
Leon doesn't have defy currently unless
he draws one in this upcoming turn and
give it can give Levius more more
confidence in with what they're going to
play with these five runes that are
still up.
>> Yeah. So we've currently have a uh the
Wizard Elder. Uh it's at six with the
buff due to its own effect as well. And
we're currently going six to six after
playing the Zna's hourglass which can
help us keep it around. And we are going
to play the Unguard. Uh and we're going
to uh give it the plus two and then the
additional plus one off the Aurelia
effect.
>> Yeah, it's going to be really nice
making it just too big for Terry
currently, but Discipline is going to
come down. Start making it a little bit
bigger. Oh, by the
>> I have to think that Terry has an
additional defi additional discipline
since he still wasn't big enough to kill
that plus three, but
>> does he have two more disciplines?
>> Yeah. And and this is the big thing too
with with the particularly wick in a
mild mirror match when it comes to all
of this calm uh you know might addition,
right? uh you're in the spot where yeah
the plus three makes a difference but
we've got the punch and uh that plus
five is going to be important. So
currently I believe we're 11 to their
>> nine.
>> Yeah. So we are just slightly bigger
here but that's all you have to be
>> hand up.
>> So four up for for Terry again there is
some knowledge and yeah the defiant
dance here
>> going to maybe get a you know plus five
deficit here. Uh, defy would be really
helpful here. And we do have the defy
from Terry and a third defy. Oh my
goodness. [laughter]
>> Yeah, you think you have it when you
defy the defiant dance, but a defy of
the defy.
>> Yeah, that is really tough. So, we get
the minus two might on the Elder there,
the plus two on the Aurelia, and I
believe we get one additional for
targeting it. So, yeah, it's going to be
a 9 to 12. And you know without the uh
you know we we kind of need another
punch to maybe get over it.
>> That's good.
>> Yeah. I wonder if Terry has it but it
kind of looks like he doesn't. It is
going to pop that zonas. So that wise
and elder will become safe back in base
but Ireelia I mean kind of down to five
runes as they get their two runes for
this turn. So not a lot of resources.
They had to spend a lot of power to keep
that Ireelia alive. But that's kind of
their whole game plan, keeping their
alive, moving between these bases,
gaining points, and kind of having a
queen that's too big for Terry to beat.
>> Yeah. But like you can see like even
without a signature spell from like Le
uh the punch effectively acts as like
the defiant dance too when it comes to
the number game. So uh that's pretty
important. We also have, you know, the
ganking. So Aelia can just move over. Uh
maybe thinking about moving it back to
base if they want to, but in a really
good spot for Aurelia here.
>> Yeah, I think Aurelia is sitting pretty
right now.
>> Uh
>> looks like we are trying to figure out
what to do with our five runes. Looks
like we do just pass back with the five
runes up. So we do have a lot of options
just like
>> even if it's just a threat, right? Like
there's so many options that Terry has
to account for that those five runes
threaten even if they're not in Levius's
hand. uh six into here.
>> Yeah. And we're at six a piece. But
looks like we are saying, you know what,
I'd rather get the uh the extra draw.
I'm missing something. So, uh that also
means that we can at least, you know,
use our legend ability to get another
buff. But, uh you know, because again,
we do have the rune advantage here, but
again, Aurelia having the boots of
swiftness has been really tough with how
easy it can get to each battlefield.
>> Yeah. And you have to like think here
was you have your I mean, to buff
>> big unit. It does look like we are going
to
>> buff up that Wisen Elder here. So, he is
a six, but
>> it's the only unit that's down right
now. So, I'm like a kind I feel like I
would be worried as Harry that I may
lose my only unit if I can't find
another unit to put down here.
>> Yeah, I mean, we've had to use Zas to
save it twice already. Uh, which has
been good. Uh, and you know, at least it
gives us something to play with, but uh,
Aelage is just so good at turning these
runes into might, and you know, the
additional movement that it gets
afforded, it's really tough for, uh, you
know, uh, I think a deck like Terries to
go toe-to-toe with it.
>> Yeah, 100%. I actually, something that I
love seeing here is seeing the different
players look at each other's discard
pile. Uh, the uh, the trash is, you
know, open knowledge for both players.
So, they're able to have this idea. I
see that they have these cards in their
trash. I don't have to account for them.
What else could this energy be? And just
really, you know, taking control of the
information here.
>> Yeah. And we're at six points for
Levvious here. Uh so likely will not be
able to win this turn, but we are going
to use Find Your Center here.
>> And uh we we kind of uh wanting to use
as many uh spells as we can during this
turn, especially Yeah. uh when we have
abandoned hall, we get this additional
uh increase. We have the guardian angel
here too for the plus four. So, you
know, this Aelia is becoming really
large here and uh it's going to be tough
to contest.
>> Yeah, we're going to draw cards, get
more runes, get more uh might and just
moving so easily back over to that monst
runes up, so there's some options
>> there. There are uh it's currently 6 to
11. So almost twice as mighty here uh
form, but we've got the back off. Does
not matter what your value is. Do we
have a not so fast? Okay, so being able
to use that. Do we have a defy
potentially?
>> Uh looks like we're going to react with
a
>> discipline.
>> Uh not so fast is good.
>> All right. Yeah. And just just in case
we had a way to interact with the not so
fast from like a defy off the draw from
discipline. So good sequencing there.
It's currently 8 to11.
If we have a punch, that could get us
over the number here.
>> Punching us over. I think we already
played one on guard and it looks like
we're only playing two ong guards in
this list. So, we don't have enough just
from that. And it does look like Wise
and Elder will finally find themselves
in the trash.
>> Yeah. And that's going to be really
tough to interact with. We're hiding a
card here. Could be a zona's as well. We
also have the guardian angel, too. So,
it's going to be tough for Terry to try
to, you know, answer this Aelia. You
know, an answer that or a problem a lot
of people find themselves like, how do I
interact with this card successfully?
>> Yeah. And then even when you do, not so
fast says not so fast, you can't touch
me.
>> Mhm. Mhm. Well, it is nice that they
don't have any calm runes currently. So,
defy not so fast. Both of these out of
contention here. But, uh, if you can't
get rid of this Aurelia, we're going to
game two.
>> Yeah. I mean, and that is what Levis is
hoping for. that this Ireelia can
basically be immortal and take every
point that they need. So,
>> one recycle.
>> Will Terry have anything? It does look
like we are going to be I think I saw
some like energy recycled. It looks like
we will be charming the Ireelia back to
base.
>> Um it is going to let that that hidden
card fizzle. Um and back off will go to
the trash.
>> Yep. So, uh you know that does get rid
of a backoff which is nice. It means
that also they don't immediately win uh
on turn pass which is helpful uh with
Aurelia having ways to have ganking and
to ready itself is still very scary next
turn.
>> Oh yeah.
>> But uh yeah, I think that charm was a
good first step.
>> Yeah, it is the first step. That is for
sure. And now because of this, as you
said, will have to gank across at some
point next turn if it wants to win. You
can't just win by conquering one point
in riftbound. either have to get your
eighth point by holding or have had
control of both battlefields during a
turn. Uh so it is going to potentially
save off at least one more turn for
Terry, but it's not looking good.
>> Yeah, but one thing is I'm not sure if
if you know Levius is holding they might
be out of cards in hand, right?
>> Uh which means that you can't really
target it unless you have something to
do. So
>> uh we got the I think that's Niti if I'm
uh correct on that one. Yeah, Niti there
playing in base. We have the first mate.
Okay. All right. So, it will be able to
uh buff and looks like ready it. And
we're just going to go five into the
monastery, which then we're going to be
able to draw another card. I mean, this
is good. And it's going to really ask
them to, hey, please don't have a card
that will let your Aurelia uh you know,
react active and take both battlefields.
>> Yeah, it's a great point. And we did go
and get that draw. Hopefully, we can
find something else. We only have one
rune up as well. That is not
doesn't feel good. Doesn't feel good.
And okay, so we do have cards in hand
too. Just uh we're keeping it in hand.
Must have like three or four at this
point. But uh going to abandon hall
again being able to use this to you know
further increase the might of our
Aurelia before sending it over. I think
that makes a lot of sense.
>> Yeah, it does. We'll have to see if they
have something or I guess because one
rune is up, we could potentially see a
defy.
>> Mhm.
>> Which could stop her from moving
potentially.
>> Yeah. And so we do have the scuttle crab
for two to get a draw one.
>> Find your center for one. So it it does
kind of look like we're looking for
something to uh you know let us
reactivate our Aurelia here and maybe
not seeing it quite yet.
>> Let's see. They still have four runes up
so we could
potentially see it here.
>> Mhm. Oh, it's up two. I'll play a
guardian.
>> Two runes being played by Guardian
Angel. All right.
>> Game two. [laughter]
>> Okay. And and Terry's like, "Okay, they
have something which uh can get us
there." Yeah. Yeah. But uh you know, you
have to put yourself on it, right? Once
you realize they have the out, go to
game two, but make sure that they do
have it.
>> Yeah. 100%. And that is so smart to make
sure they have every piece before uh we
go on to game two. Game two, I'm excited
to see what changes they make and
hopefully. I mean, the le was pretty
close. It felt like
>> Yeah, like it was it went pretty close
to toe for toe, right? I think Aelia
does have a bit of an advantage to
getting a little bit more respect for
its buck from cars from like discipline
and on guard, but uh really kept them
honest and you know could have gone
either way.
>> Yeah, 100%. I'm
>> cyber time.
>> I'm hopeful that we're going to see that
like Leon has something for because
Ireelia is definitely a legend that you
expect to see. It's not like you go to
the the RQ and you say, "Oh, I'm not
going to see Ireelia." Yeah,
>> you have to have something for Ireelia.
>> I mean, you know, Terry Terry's
definitely the underdog, I think,
playing Le today, right? Uh so, you
know, we want to see what the deck can
do. I think, uh they've already done a
really good job showcasing that. Yeah,
we do have a lot of our own tricks up
our sleeve. Uh you know, we will miss
Monastery of Herana. I think that
offered us a couple two or three draws.
Uh that could have made the big
difference there.
my heal. I'd love to see again, as you
said, the adjustment to game number two.
>> Yeah, it'll be interesting to see. And
then obviously I think the Ireelia did
great job. It did. We were able to clear
out all the units other than
um and I wonder if we had been able to
get her off the board, what that would
have meant. We didn't see Silicorn
Herder. Obviously, still corner herder
has been a pretty good uh
replacement for Ireelia sometimes when
you can't when you can't get her into
play um or if she dies. But
>> we'll have to see how Levias deals with
it if that happens.
>> Yeah. And also, you know, Terry's in a
really good spot for uh our our best
ofves, right? Uh which uh you know,
we're we're 50 right now. I don't have
the specific number in front of me, but
I'm going to guess we have probably less
than 20 less. Don't don't hard quote me
on that, but uh you know I'm I'm
guessing that you are from what we've
seen off the top 50 right now definitely
the only le in that position. So already
in a good spot but you know you still
have to grind it out. Uh getting to day
two I think would you know make your
odds exponentially higher for being our
our best of le and that is a feat in its
own.
>> Yeah it is. And the best ofs are so
cool. I absolutely love the best of
cards. Uh and I know a lot of players do
come to the RQ. They want to get them.
They're so like they love the love the
legends. They've been working really
hard on these decks and they sometimes
even come as a team trying to win the
best stuff together.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And my favorite thing too is
that we do have uh you know they have
them showcased uh behind behind some
plexiglass but uh to show you know what
people are fighting for, what the prizes
are and so it's really really cool to
see you know to be able to visibly see
what you're trying to play for. Uh and I
think that's really fun. So, uh, it
looks like we're finishing up our, uh,
siding. We're deciding what our
battlefields for game number two are
going to be, but, uh, yeah, it's going
to be tough. Again, like I think Leon
really hopes to win game one because
Monastery uh, can be such a one-sided
battlefield.
>> Yeah, 100%. And so, I am not sure what
she's going to pick next. We'll have to
see. I assume he is going to choose to
go first, as most people do when they
have the option. Um, so hopefully he has
a very good going first battlefield that
he'll be able to hopefully use to get
the win here. But
>> I will say like getting abandoned hall
behind us does feel good. Even if we
lost that is such a
>> benefit for Aurelia more than us when
they have so many more cheaper spells to
play most of the time.
>> I'm okay with not playing on abandoned
hall anymore.
>> Yeah, that is true. That is very true.
So H I wonder what both players will
pick. We'll have to see here in a
second. It does look like Rockfall Path
is going to be the Ireelia's second uh
battlefield of choice here.
>> Yeah. And then we've got Starring, one
of our newest battlefields as well. And
this could be really helpful for, you
know, helping us keep our bigger body
healthy. Right. You play just a smaller
unit to move it back uh on the Star
Spring. Obviously, this is something
that I think Aurelia can also take
advantage of, but uh you know, it's one
that we're we're happy to to take
advantage of the the advantage from.
>> Yeah, they're kind of almost like
opposite battlefields here. So, for
Rockfall Path, you're not able to play
units directly to that battlefield
>> versus Starring, it kind of
>> incentivizes you to play a unit directly
to the battlefield.
>> Yeah. And I think this is also really
good against like ambush decks as well.
Um, so, uh, you you know, Rengar, which
I don't, you know, I'm pretty sure if I
remember right, Terry's playing, uh, but
we didn't see it in that previous game.
Uh, it does give you like a layer of
protection for for that one. So,
>> yeah. And I think they're also playing
>> Ni. Yeah, you're right.
>> Uh, so two great ambush ambush cards uh
that I mean, Rockfall Path will stop
just like you're saying.
>> Yeah.
>> No, no. Two costs from Terry is a little
bit tough. uh you know obviously uh you
do get the benefit of uh I don't think
we see but this could also be a deck
that plays the sentry uh card that we
saw earlier from uh from I think Rengar
right because you could play it for one
and then you can buff it with your le
ability um so that could be helpful in
these situations but no
two cost there and [laughter]
>> double pass oh this is this is tough for
Terry here
>> yeah this never feels good when you
can't find a unit doesn't feel good
your turn one does it feel so good,
especially on turn two.
>> Yeah, but you know, shout outs to Terry
being in good spirits about it. Uh we
can hear them talk back and forth.
They're in good spirits here and uh and
definitely making the best of this game.
Uh meanwhile, Levius
>> kind of showing off the the two drops
they've got, right? Double scuttle crab,
so additional two draw here. Uh being
able to get the spring and you know,
already one point to zero.
>> Yeah, one point to zero. And we'll have
to see if Terry gets a unit this next
turn. Random notes.
>> I'll play.
>> Levvice's uh runes are my favorite art
for um they were I think Nexus Knight
packs last set, maybe the set as well,
but I I know they were last set.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I I'm kind of on like a
quest to get like at least one. Like if
I'm running, you know, six and six, I
want the runes to be all different arts,
right? So, you're one of those people. I
am kind of one. Are you one of the like
the all be
>> all the same?
>> All the same. No,
>> I don't know. Like it's it's okay to
agree to disagree, but uh yeah, it's you
know, when there's so many pretty arts,
right, it's hard to determine a
favorite. So, you're going to uh
>> have to uh you know, sometimes you can't
play favorites. So,
>> does he cut it?
>> Yeah, it looks like I think we might
have had a quick easy extra draw there.
So, uh, just following the judges, uh,
ruling there to just shuffle the deck
there off of the, uh, the find your
center there and we're going to continue
the match here. So, currently 1.20
after the find your center and back to
Terry. Let's see if we can play a unit
this time. What the hell?
>> Yeah, there are no runes up on Le's
side, but
>> go.
>> We I mean, I don't think it's too much
of a concern right now for Terry as we
are trying to find our way back in. We
finally
>> do actually find a unit. And lo and
behold, it is ironic.
>> Yeah. Which is, you know, ironic, right?
A little bit here. But, uh, you know,
we're also able to, you know, target it
a lot ourselves and get some readiness.
The fact that you can also, you know,
you choose it with your legend ability.
So, uh, being able to spend one to give
it plus two might is great. Uh, we're
going to ready it at the start of the
turn, too. So, we'll have a quick seven
as well. But, looks like we're going to
put the scuttle crab, uh, defending both
these battlefields. Uh, you know, a
menace over there. uh in you know
getting Levius into threepoint
territory.
>> Yeah. And it does look like we're going
to bring one of those scuttle crabs back
to base just giving us a unit that we
can potentially take a battlefield with
again next turn if Terry uh is able to
take one. And that lonely port honestly
such a great choice to be holding the
battlefield because if it dies it's
still a plus for us. We get to draw.
>> Yeah cuz it's it's going to be tough I
think for Terry to interact with both
battlefields. So it does kind of give
you that passive point too. Uh neither
of these are really like hold or conquer
based either. So uh you don't really
care about resetting that conquer
effect. I mean yeah moving back to Terry
but we now are the turn uh you know
Levia is now passing with six open.
>> Yeah and you have to think there's so
many different options as we saw uh for
six runes. Definitely the Ireelia player
will be able to potentially do something
here if we move up and I know Terry is
thinking about that.
>> Yeah. And so we will be doing the play
here. We're going to be at seven here.
Uh Lonely Porro
>> not really standing a chance
unfortunately, but we do get a card
draw. Uh big seven to two here. Uh we do
have the potential to uh play something
at the spring to move the Aurelia back.
And looks like for six uh maybe playing
out the champion
>> Le Star spring back.
>> Yeah. Okay. Moving it back. We love to
see that
>> recycle. Yeah, that is going to be nice.
At least it will be able to hold uh hold
the battlefield. Um while Ireelia is
just kind of safe back in base.
>> Yeah. So, this has been pretty solid. I
think we're at four points to one. Uh
but but the kind of thing is that
sometimes being at uh like five or uh
you know, five or four uh points are
pretty much the same in the spot. The
fact that you need to be able to be in
six uh or more range helps a lot. But
we're going to move the crab up.
>> This will die. Just to get the insight,
we're gonna play the
>> what of [laughter]
>> Oh, I'll see. I'll see.
>> Well, that is a lot of defian. I mean,
we saw a lot of it last game. You know
that there has to be a, you know, not a
lot of units in hand, but my goodness.
>> Yeah, that's an interesting hand to see.
Obviously, we kind of had an idea that
he had a handful of spells since he
couldn't play units for two turns. But
to be face to face with three defies,
obviously the zonas that was hidden that
we showed Uh I think I did also see the
disarming rake uh in hand.
>> Bring out the Aurelia.
>> It's it's surprising to say the least.
>> Yeah. So uh we do bring out the Aurelia
also. I I forget. Skull crab also shows
hidden cards, right? That's why it
wasn't activating it. So uh I mean not
that it there's obviously back offers,
right? But not too big of a surprise.
We're going to use the ability here on
the unguard.
>> Uh two.
>> Uh would you like to play one of your
three to five fives? No. Okay, I'll keep
going. resolve a little four.
>> I mean, he's got a lot of energy, uh, a
lot of runes that he could use. So, even
if we did defy the one on guard,
obviously, he could still play more.
Again, we do have three defies, though,
so why not?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I We got to use uh some of
our uh energy as is, but we're going to
use the zas and then we're just going to
use it to save the le. It was a an eight
to a six and then likely trying to maybe
uh what a charm in action, which yeah,
charm. We're going to try to defy it and
let's see if they have a defy as an
answer.
>> Defy.
>> Looks like we do have
>> Yeah, another defy. Yeah.
>> And obviously we do have an idea that
our player does have one defies, but we
don't have any runes that we can tap for
energy to pay for the defy.
>> So, uh that will successfully defy the
the the defy.
>> Yeah. And and Leavius like knew that and
that's like why Scuttle Crab has been so
strong. uh you would feel way less
confident with that play without perfect
knowledge, but with perfect knowledge,
you're like, "All right, well, I can
play this game of back and forth because
I know that I'm still going to come out
ahead."
>> Yeah, that knowledge is so important.
And it does feel like uh the board is
less daunting without that.
>> Yeah, and uh we don't have any equipment
on it. Also, Levius only has two runes
open, so it might be a little bit tough
to protect the Aurelia on this turn. Le
might just be able to get there. And
yeah, passing with only two open.
>> You know, Terry's actually kind of in a
good spot to get rid of this Aurelia.
>> Yeah,
>> I do think this could be definitely like
a good turn to do it. Two energy isn't
too much. There's no uh zonas in play.
There's no guardian angel protecting the
Ireelia.
>> Maybe
>> we'll have to see if Leon's able to do
it. It does look like we're going to go
and buff the Le using that uh legend
ability.
>> And now Le will be able to come up into
that star spring dance.
>> Yeah, we're going to do a defiant dance.
And I think it's going to be recalled as
a defied dance there uh to prevent the
uh you know only targeting it so you get
the plus one.
>> And uh we could try again. Yeah. On the
defy uh for your Defy. And you know,
you've we've come this far and yeah,
that's going to be a Aurelia moved.
>> Yeah. And to note, we now have all of
our runes uh back recycled into the rune
deck. So, we won't be able to use any
for the rest of this turn.
>> Correct. But I, you know, getting rid of
Aurelia, I think, is very strong here.
Uh we love to see that. Uh we've got
five runes left to play with.
>> Uh we're going to play a lonely por,
which is great on this star spring. It
keeps our leis safe here.
>> I'll pass. And we're gonna pass a three
open. So very good. Uh, one also thing I
want to mention, I think there was a
rake in the hand for Le. So there might
have been some way to give an equipment
to the Aurelia, but if you know that
it's just going to get removed, I think
it was a good call from Levvious to just
keep it in hand for the moment.
>> Yeah, for sure. I had to think that cuz
I also thought I saw the rake um that
like hope I think he maybe he could have
known if he does have those option in
hand. I mean, obviously he knew, but
like that that's maybe why he didn't use
those last two last two runes. Um, but
we'll have to find out. It does look
like we have six runes up here on
Levis's side now to play more units, but
obviously first we can do with this
scuttle crab.
>> Yeah. So moving it to the battlefield
there on Rockfall path going to six
points which is generally what these
like uh you know more aggressive decks
like you know being able to double
conquer is very good for us. We do have
a Vex come out uh which loves to see
[snorts] combat here and uh we're going
to start at three points for Terry, but
we've we do have a bit of a foothold,
right? We do have a little bit more uh
defense there. Uh and yeah, only one
come right now.
Yeah, this is I don't know like Terry
Terry's, you know, making this a game,
right?
>> Yeah, I definitely think this I mean
Terry has done something with this game
100%. Especially thinking that we
started this game
>> two turns without a single unit. Yeah.
>> Uh so really interesting and just to
note this Vex is the Vex cheerless,
which when it's in combat, the spell
prices
>> change. So your friendly um spells
decrease in price and your enemy spells
increase. So definitely in this match
where a lot of that might is in hand,
it's going to be really important.
>> Yeah, I I fully agree. Uh yeah, showing
off the hand. Yeah, double rake. We've
got a back off and a discipline. So
very helpful there. Uh it also I mean
again you did have to pop the scuttle
crab eventually and uh yeah the back off
is going to be strong especially since
we can't hide it somewhere. So again I
think we're we're doing okay uh
especially without knowingly a boots of
swiftness on the side of Levius. There
could be a chance for uh you know it to
be very tough for get to get us to eight
points here.
>> Yeah, we're so happy to be at six just
like you mentioned. It's a really
important number for more aggressive
decks like this. But
>> where do we go from here? Yeah,
>> I mean we lost our queen. We're probably
looking for I'm thinking obviously I
think the specs is very a very strong
unit. Um but traditionally I feel like
Aurelia we're definitely looking for
we're still looking for that Silicorn
Herder. If we have additional Ireelas in
deck then we're looking for those. Uh
we'll have to see what Levius does here.
>> Yeah. And again uh you know it's it's
pretty open knowledge. Two cards in hand
for Terry are the rake. We've got the
discipline in hand which can offer
another card and we do have the back off
that was hidden cuz nothing else in hand
could have been hidden here. Uh Levious
has what looks like I think seven runes
right now. Going to play out the
guardian angel here.
>> And uh we are going to use that and
equip it to the Vex. So currently we're
at six might
>> we've got five runes left open and uh
you know we could challenge either one
of these battlefields. I think the, you
know, lonely poor would be the easy one
for us to get. Uh, and then it really
asks for, uh, some interaction, uh, you
know, to remove it cuz otherwise, if we
can't interact with that Vex, they just
win off holding next turn.
>> Uh,
>> yeah, that's very true. And it does look
like we are going to move into that
rockfall path just like you mentioned.
[sighs and gasps] If we're able to hold
it, obviously, this could be a bit of a
problem for Terry. He would lose game
two uh, and that would be a 2 and 0.
Well, I'm trying to think if there's
like any options. I do think we saw him
use right uh
>> I think it's right hand.
>> Uh first mate. Yes. No. Yeah, you're
right. Yeah, first mate could be
possible uh for sure. But also since it
is rockfall path, he can't play units
there. So uh that is important. But uh
since we are on starfall or star spring,
we could play something there and move
it back. Uh so that could be helpful for
us there. Uh you know, scuttle crab
defending the the spring there. Um Oh
yeah, this Vex is very [snorts] scary.
>> Yeah, I mean that's a great point about
the Starring as you're unit there and it
would almost be like pseudo ganking
bringing that uh readied le back to base
and then you can move it up into that
Vex. I think Terry here does have to
decide if he's going to play any spells
because if he wants to make this le big,
he probably should do it now before he
enters combat with that Vex and the
price for those spells skyrockets. Yeah,
I I fully agree. And currently, uh we're
at five might to seven. I think
discipline makes sense, too. So,
currently we're nine to five. Um you
know, also the fact that Vex makes our
own uh spells cheaper is nice. And we do
get the removal. This is huge here. It's
going to be a six point there. If we
just hold, we're going to game three.
>> Yeah, we are. And also that disarming
rake, I kind of just went over was able
to take off that GA, I think it was,
that was on Vex. Uh, and so I mean we're
pretty we're really happy right now.
>> Yeah, I I was kind of expecting to have
a little bit more fight for that Vex,
but with it six points to seven on
Levius, we'll see if they have any
answer to this board. And looking
around,
>> I'm not sure.
>> Yeah, I mean, you have to think like
what could have been in hand that you
wouldn't [laughter] want to stop
from moving in. Obviously, you kind of
had an idea of how much energy
he'd already played it before the price
went up. And it does look like we are
going to game three. Um, and let's see
what they do. Obviously, I think Terry
was able to figure out what he needed to
win that game. And now it's Ley's turn.
>> Yeah. And like, you know, one, I think
Terry played that very well. Also to the
fact of saying, you know, sometimes like
the first game or two or first turn or
two can be really slow, but if you play
it out, if you grind it grind it
correctly, like
>> Terry was able to bring that back from a
really really tough position. So shout
outs to them. You get to claim that you
won with Le on stream a game already and
we're going to see if Terry's able
[laughter] to make it a match.
>> Yeah, we'll have to see. It's going to
be really exciting to try to see how
game three goes. And I have to kind of
commend his mental game there. I feel
like if I started a match It's I'm going
against one of the probably a very
strong card in the it's very strong deck
in the meta
>> and I go turn one pass.
>> I might just literally want to say turn
two scoop
>> cross but they they were able to hold it
off. Uh honestly those three to five
were really relevant to me right that
ended up being really helpful and and
Terry's been all smiles on stream so far
and you guys can probably hear a bit of
the banter. These guys have been pretty
happy too. uh they know what's on the
line, but they know, you know, this is,
you know, this is fun. There's a reason
they're here, and they wanted to make it
the best match that they can.
>> Yeah. You can tell they love the game.
Even when he missed his the turn two
unit, he was still smiling.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And I think I heard Leius
play, oh no. Like for him, right?
[laughter] Like that is that is tough,
but you know, able to grind it out. And
yeah, now we're going to see Levious go
in first here. We've got one more
Battlefield left a piece. And uh yeah, I
think Starring ended up being very
helpful for Leon. Uh Rockfall path, but
uh-oh, we've got abandoned hall.
>> That's going to be kind of tough to get
more value than Aurelia for that one.
>> Yeah. And sunken temple.
>> Yeah. So, we kind of switched roles,
right? We had monastery be the draw one
and abandoned hall game one. Game two.
Sunken Temple is essentially the same.
Uh we can get a five might unit to get a
draw, but again, the abandoned hall is
really scary with Aelia
yesterday. uh abandoned hall when a
player plays a spell that gives the unit
they control there plus one which is as
we know Ireelia loves playing spells so
as you
>> and being at battlefield
>> and being at battlefield so exactly
you're saying she's really going to love
it I will say at least because they both
are calm decks
>> le can use it obviously I mean he's
playing it so he can use a good bit but
he's not as disadvantaged as some of
those other players and luckily with
sunken temple both of these players are
also having mighty characters.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But definitely a bit uphill
for Terry, I think, for this one,
especially I mean, it's not like you
were going to play two cost game
anyways. Not that that mattered, but uh
we're going on into it. We've got Levia
starting us off. Double chaos. Let's see
if there's a turn one play. And no. All
right.
>> Levia saying exactly what I'm thinking.
It's his turn to take a turn off. Yeah,
it almost feels like we're back in a set
two where you didn't play as many of
those lower cost units uh on Ireelia. I
do think I saw a Stellorn her. I think
she's like the princess of the deck. So,
he's not feeling the worst from it.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I mean, and uh you know,
fashionably late, right? This is our
third game. First time we've seen a
Stellicorn, though. That tends to happen
when you're only playing two copies of a
card, right? But, uh this can offer a
lot of card draw that we might have been
missing for the first couple games.
>> Yeah, I feel like her ability is so
strong. When she moves, she draws a
card. Traveling Merchant was already so
strong and you had to discard to use
him.
>> Yeah. Yeah. No. So, it's it's been it's
been very clear. Obviously, Aurelia has
a lot of tricks. Uh, luckily, we're not
on the Star Spring. Starring with
Celicorn is just one more move trigger.
So, that is nice to dodge that one. But,
you know, Terry's got the big think on
five runes right now.
Yeah, at least he did find his unit as
you said uh this game. So, he could also
make a choice to move into one of these
spots first. It looks like instead he is
going to play this gear Doran's blade
though and attach it to that lonely
porro. It gives him plus two.
>> Yeah, and that does make us mighty. So,
we can get a draw off the sunken temple
here. So, uh we are able to convert into
some card draw. We've got two runes left
open. And again, I do think it's better
that we are on the temple because it
does, you know, Celicorn can take
advantage of the abandoned hall very
easily. So, we're gonna use the pit
rookie. Unfortunately, everything is too
buffed to interacted with and back to
Levius.
>> That is I think it's pretty funny
honestly playing the pit rookie after
the things are buffed, but uh it is nice
to see pit rookie as well. Just making
sure we do have units if something does
decide to happen to the lonely borrow.
Just just pretend that Sunken Temple was
the Monastery of Herana. You used the
buff, you rebuffed it. It's the same
math. You just lost a rune. So
>> yeah,
>> don't worry about it's fine. Pit Rookie,
you you definitely buffed my my lonely
poro. Don't think about it too hard.
>> Yeah, Pit Rookie, you did such a great
job.
>> Well, we've got the Stellicorn here.
Moving to the abandoned hall, getting
that first draw one off of it. A lot of
cards in hand and a good amount of
runes. I think we're at six runes right
now for uh Actually, it might be seven.
I I don't think we've recycled one quite
yet. Uh, no. Six turns. Yeah, because we
did go first. Yeah. Yep. Yep.
>> We did get that draw. Stellorn Herder.
Does look like there's cards in hand
that you could use to draw more, but
we're just going to go and start that
lead. It does look like we are going to
use a find your sentry, though.
>> Yep. So, getting a draw one and able to
channel one rune. We've got three left
open. Uh, you know, if there's a way for
us to uh, you know, target the Celicorn,
we can ready it with our legend ability
and move it safely back and draw another
card for our troubles. But we'll see
what Levius decides to do.
>> I wonder what we could do with the extra
three runes. I don't think we saw any
other units in hand. Obviously, we kind
of want to leave some up cuz for to some
extent.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, obviously, Ireelia is still an
option to play in the future. So, it's
not like if Silicon Herder dies, we
don't have any options. But, I think
sometimes Silicorn Herder is such is a
great, you know, protect the president
itself.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I mean, like,
>> you don't have deflect and you have one
less base might, but like it's still
like the card draw. I mean, it turns
every Unguard into discipline, right?
Like, it's it's just so good at uh at
facilitating card draw and might, but
we're going to leave it at the abandoned
hall. We feel like we're going to have
enough to really contest it here. It's
currently at three might. We do have the
buff on the pit rookie from the Leon
Legend, and we're going to contest a
three to three on the abandoned hall.
>> Oo, let's see what they do. Obviously, I
mean, three runes up on Levius's side,
five runes up on Terry's side. It does
look like defiant dance is going to come
down. That is plus two and minus two.
And with abandoned hall does make it, I
believe, a plus three for the silicorn
herder. Minus two on that pit rookie.
>> Yeah, but uh you know, you have to play
the spell for the abandoned hall too.
So, uh if there is a defy, that means
that you not only stop the defiant
dance, but then you get the plus one
from the hall on your pit rookie. So
again, this is so numbers based. The
might totals are so close and you really
want to force some interactions. So
seeing if the define dance ends up
resolving. Terry's taking a look at it.
>> Yeah, this is a big moment here. Will
resolve
>> float one recycle.
>> All right, looks like float one recycle.
We are going to do the punch first here.
So, it's currently 6 to3, but now it's
going to be 9 to six. Plus five from the
punch first and then a plus one from the
hall there.
>> And uh we're going to be like, okay, am
I a little scared? We can [laughter]
>> And the defy on that. That is huge. Uh
you get so much benefit from your
patience. Terry really really cleanly uh
you know, clean that up. We're at three
points here. We're going to move our
porro back. That's going to be mighty
for another potential turn. And Levius,
I think, is kind of on the back foot.
Oh, and another first mate to move this
back. This is such a good turn from
Terry.
>> Yeah, this seems fantastic. I mean, we
were able to get that win as well as the
fact that Silicorn Herder didn't get the
draw off the flash, which is I mean,
just going to keep Levis's resources
low. That pit rookie is safe back in
base just like you mentioned. And next
turn, we could get that sunken temple
because you don't get it off the hold.
>> Yeah. Well, we beat the mini [laughter]
boss. of settle. Here comes Aelia, the
main boss of the deck here. And you
know, it's obviously it was a good
sequence of the plays, but we're not out
of the uh we're not, you know, 2-1 quite
yet.
>> Mhm. Very true. But we do have a lot of
options here, I believe, as Terry
obviously those three units. We could go
in and take these two points going up to
five points this turn. Uh it does look
like our somehow mighty but lonely Horo
is going to be moving up to Sunken
Temple. He's lonely. He's mighty. He's
buffed. He's everything. He's got Yeah,
he's collecting these keywords here. So,
uh yeah, this will offer us a draw one.
Um if if Terry wants to. We only have
five runes cuz it was a pretty runeheavy
turn last turn. Uh but yeah, we are able
to make a decision on if we want to use
it or not.
>> It feels like the the poor is playing
like a miniame. We're a you know, you we
collect the cards, he collects the
keywords.
>> Yes. Yes.
See?
>> All right. Yeah, considering on this.
Yeah, only three cards in hand. So,
yeah, drawing one for one energy is so
tempting, right? But when these totals
of runes are so tiny when every move
matters. You have to decide, okay,
what's what's the best draw I can get of
the situation? Is it worth maybe like
having to use all my runes this turn to
set up and maybe be open to interaction?
You know, I understand the think from
Terry. Yeah, I mean we're currently at I
think five runes here. Uh so I mean
every rune counts.
Do you want the draw? Is there some card
you would play instead? Do I need to
protect against Ireelia? Even if I don't
have the card that protects against
Ireelia, I could be bluffing that I have
the card that protects against Ireelia.
>> And it looks like instead we don't take
that sunken temple trigger, but we are
going to be moving pit rookie up into
abandoned hall.
>> Oh yeah. And then the Aurelia for five.
We're going to hide something at the
lonely porro. And uh yeah, I can see
like yeah, getting Aurelia on on the
board is a big priority. I can
understand why we did so. Uh cuz it can
offer us, you know, enough as it is. But
Levius, you know, we are a bit behind on
points and on tempo, but we've got a lot
of cards in hand, a lot of runes, and
only two in hand for Terry. So, let's
see what they start off with.
last game it did seem like Lebius really
did prioritize killing that Ireelia
quickly. Uh so I wonder if that is
something that he's going to prioritize
again this game. Obviously probably step
one is getting into one of these battle
builds though.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And uh you know we we
haven't had any hand knowledge this
game. We've been seeing a lot of scuttle
crabs in the previous ones but uh a copy
of back off could be you know
devastating. uh and you know there are
some interaction points for it to uh so
we'll see what Levius decides to and
yeah decides to go straight to the
sunken temple and starting off with an
unguard uh on the Aurelia here.
>> Yeah, I mean Ireelia I mean it's
gigantic. It's very mighty. So it will
be able to use that sunken temple
trigger if we do win that combat. There
are no runes up on Terry's side, but
there is the hidden card, which is going
to be a ZAS. Uh, and it looks like we
are going to flip the ZAS
>> as it dies. So, it does not save the
Loro.
>> Yep. Correct. Yeah. So, we're we want
the card draw obviously. Uh, we want to
be able to keep the Aurelia around two.
So, uh, good knowledge on the sequencing
for that one. And, uh, yeah, we're in a
pretty good spot for for Levious here.
So,
>> I'll play
>> or, you know, against Levius here. So,
double crab gets the double draw.
And
yeah, we kind of I mean, if if this
Aelli just kind of stays on there, it's
a little scary, but
>> it is what it is
>> cuz we might just go to six uh points
for for Terry. Move everything back and
say we can be the ones to get the double
conquer next turn.
>> Yeah, that would be really nice for
sure. It looks like we do have Ride the
Wind though, bringing us over to that
abandoned hall. And I mean, Terry just
says, "Look,
>> guys did." Yeah, I understand. Yeah, and
unfortunately we do have to proc the ZAS
on that one. Uh definitely would have
rather the Aurelia. Not all like keeping
a a unit around is not always, you know,
is always okay, right? But uh you know,
there definitely are some bigger targets
for it. So we go to three points for
Levius, I believe, uh off that double
conquer turn and then uh yeah, we're
going to start off with Ter. We can
pretty easily conquer one of these and
maybe try to force a double conquer next
turn.
>> Yeah,
>> whether
I feel like whether you're at like six
or seven here, it's not
>> the biggest difference. No.
>> Uh because
>> I mean obviously you still have to hold
at some point or get that extra point.
Um this Ireelia is going to be really
difficult to deal with.
>> Mhm.
>> And so I wonder like what Terry's going
to do here. Obviously has a couple turns
to kind of try to figure it out though.
Levious is far enough behind. But now
that the scuttle crabs are down, we are
going to It seems like we're kind of
moving back into set three. And what can
Libyas do versus us now that this
Ireelia is on online?
>> Defied.
>> All right, we've got a sabotage, but the
sabotage has been defied. So, uh,
understood there. It means that we can't
play Lisa in this turn, but wouldn't be
too difficult to play it next turn as
well.
>> It does look like it may have been
>> two.
>> Was it the only card I was saying? Maybe
not, cuz he does look he has cards.
>> Yeah, he's been keeping them close to
the close to himself, right? So, it's a
little bit harder to to tell. Uh, but we
are going to play the scuttle crab. Uh,
and we are going to move a buffed and a
uh
>> is it just buffed? Yeah,
>> I
>> it looks like there's another card
underneath it on the other side.
>> I think they meant to equip the Dorne's
blade if I if I'm being honest.
>> I just equipped the scuttle.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Yeah, they equipped
the scuttle crab. All right. [laughter]
>> Yeah, Ignore that. Ignore that.
>> No, no worries there. Yeah, obviously
the intent with the, you know, recycling
and the equip there, but yeah, we get
the uh the pit rookie there. a mighty
pit rookie for once. But
>> yes. Yeah.
>> Uh they were both giggling about that. I
thought it was very cute.
>> You just want to come along. He just
wanted to be, hey, we're going to the
sunken temple. I'm down. We can go
together. But
>> yeah, scuttle crab just wanted to be a
part of the party.
>> All right, but we're going to use the
buff there on the first mate. Going to
be at four. Not quite Mighty itself, but
again, since Aelia has been on the back
foot for so much of this game, they're
really, you know, still like two turns
away from winning, right? They're at
three points to six. And so you can
still kind of set up. You're not kind of
scared about them winning in the next
turn.
>> Yeah, that is for sure. And like I'm
interested to see like what Ielia does
decide to do because I think obviously
they are going to need a little like
especially aggressive
>> to maybe put themselves in a better
foot. obviously that Ireel is in
Tererry's base, but we've seen cards
like Charm uh on Levvis's on Levies's
side that have helped them really, you
know,
>> take care of cards like that. Looks like
we do go on and send our scuttle crab
into that pit rookie just knowing it's
going to die so we can get that
information.
>> So, we're about to find out exactly what
Terry
>> could do.
>> Yeah. So, we have the wizard elder,
we've got the rake, and we also have the
discipline. So, uh, we are going to,
looks like play our own discipline for
two.
>> Mhm.
>> Just for the card draw there and, uh,
and making sure that we get over it. We
get the Dorners Blades to fall off and,
uh, we could potentially draw one more
if Levius wants to. Yeah, that's it
seems to be the case.
>> Yeah. Yeah, now we're going to feel way
more confident deciding what to do with
these leftover runes on the Ireelia side
because I mean all the information just
tells us, you know, what are our
options, what's going to play the best,
and uh we can play as efficiently as
possible now.
>> Yeah. Uh so we can see that we we could
this I don't know if it's going to be a
good play. We could buff our own scuttle
crab and send it to their scuttle crab,
which would be really funny. Uh one
might to zero Scuttle crab battle. But
looks like Terry's turn once again.
We've got uh six runes open for sorry,
seven runes up for Levius and all of six
runes open for Terry. Uh so we'll see if
they feel confident enough to try to win
this turn.
>> Yeah, the number of resources these two
players have just feels so different. Uh
Ireelia, I mean, is kind of drowning in
runes. It's got so many up. Uh and Terry
feels like he has to choose every single
choice he's doing. How does it affect my
runes? What What is it going to do? Are
there is it going to stop cards being
played? But it looks like we're going to
do that same thing that Levies did last
turn trying to learn more information by
just sending a scuttle crab into die.
>> All right, so some good knowledge here.
We've got the Vex, the Starcross, uh the
back off, the hard bargain, defiant
dance, and defy. So
>> honestly, a lot of scary cards to have
in hand. Uh we can mostly play most of
them here. Uh hard bargain is going to
kind of checkmate a little bit, too. And
yeah, I don't I don't even know where to
begin to decipher what my next play is
now. This is a lot of good information
and very scary for Terry to see all of
the interaction that's available.
>> Yeah, it's definitely scary. And there's
like a question of like what are you
supposed to do directly into it because
we do I guess have like some hand
disruption when it comes like sabotage
that we saw that can remove like
nonunits, but
>> we don't have six of them or five of
them that or we better not, you know.
Uh, so the the problem is like sometimes
maybe we just send one of these units in
and he's going to play the cards to stop
you from winning it, but it means he
won't be able to play them in the future
turn. So we do have to burn them at some
point is at least a thought of how to
get around them because they're
definitely hard cards to get around the
end.
>> Yeah, cuz like we they have two counters
and defy and hard bargain. Uh they have
starcross which I think you're going to
starcross on a scuttle crab makes a lot
of sense in the spot because you kind of
already have the tempo lead back at you
and and then just like the rest like
back off in case they do get the really
big number. Uh if they try to charm the
Aurelia away you can defy it hard
bargain it. There's just so much
interaction that Levius can play around.
It is is going to be tough for Terry to
find those that you know seventh and
eighth point I think.
>> Yeah, I I completely agree. It just
feels like so many of the cards in
somebody's hand are just going to either
stop the combat, stop the extra might
from coming down or potentially
completely remove them from the
battlefield. Uh so definitely as Terry,
I have a lot of, you know, I have a lot
to think about.
>> Yeah. And it's it's understood like why
why the think is here. Uh you know, we
could get the abandoned hall. Uh but
then, you know, they get the renowledge
of I think the one or two cards we've
drawn since the last scuttle crab. uh
you know being at seven points compared
to eight points is not or sorry seven
points and six points are not that much
closer to eight most of the time and
yeah I I understand for Terry here. So
six runes here we could play our
champion if we want to uh we could buff
our Aurelia. It would make it a seven uh
or sorry a six because it was already
active at the end of last turn so it did
not switch to active already. And uh
yeah this is you know a lot on the line
for this decision.
>> [snorts]
>> Yeah. And I just especially with just
the six runes, there's not a lot of ways
to make this. Well, I'm trying to think
way perfect way to put it, but like
there's
>> there's only so many runes to work with.
>> Yes. Yeah, agreed.
>> So, it looks like we're going to play
two for a Za's hourglass
>> and we're going to equip the Doron's
blade here.
>> And we're going to actually go five into
the Aurelia.
>> Six
>> or sorry, six into the Aurelia. Yeah,
because we we do have the buff and the
plus two from the Doran's blade.
>> Yeah, so we're definitely threatening
the here kind of making them burn some
of their cards. It does look like
discipline's going to come down. It is
card draw, which a card that we don't uh
know about potentially, but it does mean
it's one hopefully one less that we have
to worry about as well.
>> It's seven to six.
>> Yeah. And so currently 7 to six here. Uh
we could have something like a punch
first which would be you know couldn't
be defied could be hard bargained but
then they'd have to spend you know you
you could there there are some numbers
that can get there but I think I think
punch f uh first would have to be one of
the cards in our catalog here.
>> Good.
>> I have to wonder if he doesn't want to
burn too much such as since he put that
zonas down before going in. Kind of
accepting that maybe this card could
die. It does look like he goes and lets
it uh die to be revived by the zonas. Um
but does we still have that ready
Ireelia we could use this turn as well.
There is still going to be that plus
smite on our opponent's Ireelia though
that we do have to account for.
>> Yeah. And so we do you know we could use
the le for the uh plus one uh there. Oh,
abandoned hall also get the you know we
got the scuttle crabs getting some
action here. Um, but buffing the Aurelia
would make it a uh six cost. So it would
be six to the uh other Aurelia who's
currently at seven. But
>> yeah, maybe Yeah, just moving it over to
the scuttle crab. Yeah, there's just so
much to to try to weave through here and
I understand why Terry's having a tough
time. Yeah, moving it to the scuttle
crab. Currently four to one.
>> Fingers crossed. Maybe four to one we
can overcome the scuttle crab. is going
to give information though to Levius if
we are able to kill the scuttle crab but
>> it's just a choice we have accepted.
>> Yeah. So it looks like we're thinking
about playing three for the back off. We
do have to play the uh deflect cost but
since we also played back off from hand
we do get the extra draw one. We're
going to play the Elder there for the
remaining four and we're going to pass
it back. Levvious at seven, Terry at
six, it's getting right down to it.
Yeah, I mean this is where the pressure
comes on. Next turn, Terry will have to
kill both of these units or at least
free up both battlefields or it will be
a loss. So Levius here is just probably
going to build up his board and make it
as hard as possible for Terry to deal
with it.
>> Yeah, and we're ticking into time. So
this should be turn zero. Honestly, I
think both players just have one turn a
piece based on the board state already.
So uh you know this is essentially a
natural conclusion already. and Levius.
Yeah. Starting off as turn zero.
>> Yep.
>> He's got a lot of runes to make sure his
board is very strong. Obviously, a lot
of the cards could just be used during
Terry's turn as well. Talked about a lot
about the might in hand that we could be
seeing. Uh but it is going to be looks
like three runes are being turned. Looks
like we are going to be attaching a gear
here.
>> Yeah, there's the boots of swiftness
getting us the additional knight and we
did target. So even if we got rid of the
scuttle crab, uh the ganking could be uh
useful for us there. But the
>> the biggest thing is that Aelia is not
really good at uh holding, right? So but
the charm here, which must have been the
card that we drew for turn at this
point, right? I think that's the one
card we didn't know about. So
>> we had the back off draw as well as well
as discipline. Oh, sure. There's a
couple cards, but yeah, it's it's all
since the the scuttle crab. It looks
like we are going to use that ganking to
try to hold just the one side. We don't
really need to hold both per se. Uh so
that is nice for Levius. It was kind of
it's kind of a either you I'm winning or
you're winning. Yeah.
>> You know.
>> Yeah. And I think it makes sense too
because uh yeah, we we don't really care
about the other battlefield as much. And
we really want to be on the abandoned
hall because uh I would expect to play a
good amount of spells on this next turn,
too. Yeah, I completely completely
agree. Um,
>> honestly, some part of me is like, what
if they were able to go into the sunken
temple and draw a card and that mattered
in some way, but I do think that there's
only two units down. There's not a lot
of ways that Terry can just move into
the battlefield uh with a unit he just
played. So, I don't think it's the
biggest deal. It does look like
starcross is going to come down picking
up that scuttle crab and sending the
wisened elder back to Terry's hand
decreasing again the ch the different
units that he can play to take this
battlefield.
>> Yeah. So scuttle back to hand. We got
four open. Uh you know there have been a
couple cards.
>> We could just play our lease in
champion. It wouldn't win us the game
but we could really pressure this
Aurelia due to it. And uh it just you
know the additional plus two might off
the le ability will be pretty huge.
>> That would be for sure.
Let's see. And there are four runes up
on Levis's side that Terry does have to
account for here. Honestly, that's a lot
of might that it could be.
>> Yeah. So, I we know that one's Scuttle
Crab, one's Defy, one is Hard Bargain.
True. There might have been one more
card revealed, but again, we've had a
good amount of cycle since then, too.
One was definitely Starcross, which we
used. So,
>> um you it really depends on what Lilius
has drawn since. And
>> you know, this should be our second turn
here or sorry, turn one here for for
Terry uh based off time rules.
>> Yeah, I do kind of like the idea that
you were saying about playing the chosen
champion. Uh you can't defy a chosen
champion. Yeah, that's for sure. Um
>> and obviously there are a lot of I mean
things like that that could that we may
not be able to account for if we just
move our units in.
>> Yeah. And thinking about how we're doing
it. Yeah, cuz the, you know, Leon has
accelerate also the ability that buff
count plus two. So, uh, an additional
plus two. So, right now the, uh, first
mate is at six might and you go to eight
uh, with an additional six. So, 14
might. Not unheard of to beat Levius. I
think there was a Defiant Dance in hand
that I was thinking from Levius uh, when
we when we peaked it earlier. So, that
could be, you know, a good swing,
especially on Abandoned Hall.
>> Yeah, that is very true. We are
currently I think at six might on the
Aelia here. Uh so
>> yeah, definant dance would offer quite a
an increase there because not only the
the deficit from you know plus five but
the hall will be a plus six deficit.
>> Yeah, decreases there. My as well is
able to increase hours in that divine
dance. Ah I mean seven runes is a good
amount.
>> So I have to hope that we have something
here.
Yeah, it's just tough when you know that
there's a hard bargain and defy in hand
as well, right?
>> Yeah,
>> that's the big issue.
>> It makes you worry about playing spells.
>> Yeah, which you at every hard bargain
and defy just increases their Aurelia
because of the hall, too. And you know,
I understand like why Terry puts hall in
their deck as one of their battlefields,
but it's definitely something that, you
know, you have to be worried about
Aurelia using a little bit better than
you.
>> Yeah, completely. And we don't really
have the runes for a hard bargain in the
way that Levius seems to have. Like
Levius has so many more runes than we
do.
>> It does look like distoring rake is
what's going to come down. That will
take the uh boots of swiftness off of
the Ireelia doesn't decrease it by two
might.
>> Uh
>> I mean, so now we're now we're six to uh
six to four.
>> Mhm.
>> But we're moving it up. Again, we want
to play our own spells during uh this.
And we're going to start off with the
discipline. We're going to hit them with
the defy
>> off the rip there. And yeah, that's all
we've got. And Levius takes it. But what
a great match.
>> Yeah, fantastic match by [music] both
players. It was so cool to see how this
le dealt with the monster that is
Ireelia.
>> Yeah, a lot of back and forth forcing
the game three and I'm really really
happy that we were able to showcase that
game.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, Levius. Yeah, definitely thinking
a lot. you know, the the scattered hair
like, man, this is this is tough. These
numbers are so close to each other. And
again, when there's two calm decks
fighting with ong guards, discipline
define dances. Yeah. It is, you know,
some really close numbers.
>> Yeah. And especially when you're against
a calm deck as well, right? Because I
feel like a lot of times when you're
working with your own math, at least
you're kind of used to it. You have an
idea what you do. You've been doing that
exact math, those pluses pretty often
because you've been practicing your
deck. But then going against someone
else that you also have to account for
it with
>> and then now you also have to deal with
the fies and things like that where it
can like change how your math is working
out. So many numbers to work with.
>> Yeah, it was it was honestly a great
game and again uh really showing you
know le still can do it right. Can can
make your opponent at least nervous
right for the game three. Uh but I don't
think we've really shown Aurelia that
much off. So obviously a reason for
Aurelia being very strong right now. Uh
the abandoned hall is a really good new
battlefield that you can take advantage
of. Uh so I think it's still yeah one of
the best decks in the game right now.
>> Yeah, I mean I I really like seeing all
the new battlefields for the record.
There's a lot of cool uses of different
battlefields here. Uh but yeah, I think
Ireelia definitely is just so strong.
Obviously it won RQ Sydney as well. Um
and I mean it'll be interesting to see
how it plays out today and into
tomorrow.
>> Yeah, but uh Levius is currently 6. So
qualified for day two. So obviously a
relief already. Terry still in
contention not only for day two but uh
you know and both players obviously in
contention for best of right but I would
say the ratio is a little bit better on
Terry's side than maybe Levius is but uh
yeah really happy we were able to watch
that match. Yeah, it's so cool to some
see some of these more uh
kind of like dark horse legends because
I kind of did not expect to see Le um
like at all, especially at the 5 and0. I
think it may have been the only one we
saw on the 5-0 list. So maybe I am wrong
with that. And so so cool to see a
player who really knows that deck, seems
to be piloting it so well and then up
against who could be very well, you
know, a boogeyman in this meta. And
honestly taking it to game three, taking
it to the last turn.
>> Really really. Yeah. And and you I think
body has gone a lot of new cards from
unleash. We obviously have been focusing
on like Elder Dragon and his interaction
with Aurora. I think that's been a
really understood bun, but uh Rengar can
just give you so much value to a lot of
other decks that exist right now. Uh the
way that you can interact and and be
healthy. Uh and so yeah, it's really
cool to see people, you know, really
believe in Leon, say, you know what, I
think it's better than Master, right?
and uh and prove it like so far. Like
we've gotten really far with it so far
today.
>> Yeah. And it was so cool to see also
like some new cards with the rake being
able to destroy some of those gears. Uh
I mean so many interesting cards in
Leon. I had so much fun watching it.
>> Definitely. So, uh with how it is when
we go to timings, we don't have as much
in between, which is good for you guys
cuz round seven is coming right up. You
guys don't want to miss it. We'll be
right back. Round seven of eight today.
And let's go to it.
Hey guys, I'm here with Colin Kaiser
from Challenger TCG. Would you like to
introduce yourself?
>> Yeah, as you already mentioned, my name
is Colin. I am a part of Challenger TCG
and one of the owners and I've been
playing competitive Riftbound since it
started.
>> That's so awesome. Do you have a
favorite uh legend that you play?
>> Yeah, I am most well known for set uh
twotime set best of winner as well as
I've been playing it since set one. So,
uh set forever has kind of been my motto
so far.
>> Yeah, I would say that you're pretty
well known for playing set, especially
since set one. And since then, you've
been playing really like the kingpin
versus brawler. Can you explain it to us
a little bit?
>> Yeah, Brawler tends to be a little bit
more on the aggressive side, much more
about breaking into battlefields. I like
to be a much more defensive player, and
Kingpin is kind of the king, no pun
intended, for holding. And that's my
favorite strategy to do is it just
involves kind of predicting what my
opponent's going to do on the next turn
and having to build boards according to
uh to what their might numbers are,
right? And I just love the math behind
it and watching my opponents struggle to
do the math themselves, it uh makes me
all giddy inside.
>> That makes sense. And obviously you did
really well at the regional qualifier in
Sydney. Is there any innovation you're
doing coming into this tournament?
>> Uh yeah, I've changed, I believe, about
five cards since then. Pretty much every
time I go to a new event, there's going
to be some card that I love, some card
that I hate. Most recently, I added uh
Rengar into the list as my most recent
tech. That card's been very good for me
and it has some really cool lines where
I go like turn one arena bar into turn
two Rengar going second immediately get
it on the battlefield. It's a seven
miter that's protected by set. It's been
uh very good so far.
>> That makes a lot of sense. So going to
this tournament today uh well soon. Are
there any players or teams that you're
hesitant to be going up against?
>> Yeah, there's a few that have been
competing. We know that TSS just came
out and uh while we aren't too afraid of
them, we still think that we're the
best. They are definitely on our radar
as well as Allan and Prismat. While I
don't think they have a team proper
themselves, uh they're still some of our
best competition, of course.
>> Well, thank you so much. Is there
anybody you like to shout out?
>> Uh yeah, just shout out to everybody on
my team, Challenger TCG. Check us out
pretty much everywhere. Uh we love
making content for the game and helping
out anyone where we can to learn how to
play competitively like us.
>> Well, thank you so much.
>> Thank you.
Hey guys, I'm back with CTCG Koko Lopez.
Would you like to introduce yourself?
>> Yeah, how you doing for everybody out
there? I'm uh Koko Lopez, part of the
team child of TCG and uh we're here
running it up.
>> Let's go. Well, are there any legends
you're really excited about or a
favorite legend you like to play?
>> Uh a favorite legend I like to play
would probably Kaisa. Unfortunately, I'm
not playing it today, but we're running
Aurelia. I think she's good. She's good
into the field right now, so we try to
take it all the way. Well, you did
fantastic in the Atlanta uh regional
qualifier.
After doing so well, is there any
changes you're making to how you're
preparing for this tournament or
anything like that?
>> Yeah. Uh after that run, I took it a
little bit more serious. I put a lot
more hours into testing and stuff like
that. Uh I've been uh grinding basically
multiple decks trying to fit trying to
find something that fits more of a play
style that I like cuz uh Draven has kind
of fell off, you know, his tail a little
bit. So, that's how I ended up uh
landing on Aurelia.
>> That's awesome. Do you have any
recommendations for players who are
trying to find their deck to play?
>> Uh, I would say just put in the effort.
You got to try everything. There's a
bunch of legends out there obviously.
You know what I'm saying? Uh, the more
you play, the more you find a style that
you like, that you enjoy.
>> Well, thank you so much. Are there any
players, you know, even though you put
in all these hours or teams that you're
a little bit worried about going against
tomorrow?
>> Obviously, not really, but I will say,
you know, anybody from the team,
obviously, we don't want to play each
other. Uh, other than that,
I'm not really afraid to go against
anybody, but you know, obviously I
respect Pierce, Matt, Allen, you know,
the heavy hitters in the game. So, yeah,
>> I respect that a lot. Well, thank you so
much. Is there anybody you like to shout
out? Is there anywhere people can find
you?
>> Yeah. Uh, shout out to my boy M. Shout
out to the homies. Shout out to Child
TCG. Uh, shout out to the Twitch to the,
uh, Twitch chat. You know what I'm
saying? Everybody in chat. I've been
streaming lately. Everybody been in
there showing love. I appreciate you
guys the best.
>> And that's really about it. Well, thank
you so much and we can't wait to see you
play later this weekend.
>> Awesome. Thank you. Sweet.
>> I'm back with D Ziden from Challenger
TCG. Would you like to introduce
yourself a bit?
>> Hey. Yeah. I'm Daniel Zidenberg from
Challenger TCG. I'm the first guy to
ever get uh best of with all six
domains. I'm the Avatar. I got got all
of them in my pocket.
>> I love it. Do you have a favorite
legend?
>> Well, yeah. I mean, I've been doing so
well with Leblanc. She's got to be my
favorite for now. I mean, I I went
undefeated last week. I got top eight in
Sydney. I mean, I until I do poorly,
she's my favorite.
>> I support that. Will you tell me a
little bit about how you guys created
[music] Challenger TCG?
>> Yes. So, uh, I met a few of the guys in
a previous card game. Alex brought us
together. He said, "We got to test this
game. It's going to be huge." He was
right on the money and then we proceeded
to do really well in the early game and
uh in the early season and that's how
the the team started. You guys
definitely have been doing really well,
especially as you said in Sydney with
that top eight. You did end up losing to
Diana though. Are there any changes you
made to your list to kind of work with
that?
>> Yeah, so we uh we added the vibes back
to the maiden board. Uh it's like the
best tool you can have for beating uh
Diana's like early tempo plays and then
there's some watchers in the side where
we think it'll really help in sort of
clearing up the board.
>> That makes a lot of sense. I think a lot
of people would like to know though,
what made you put Hook into the list?
So, we started with a very aggressive
Leblanc list. It was fine. It had some
issues. Felt like it was too vulnerable
to interaction. Tried a mid-range list.
Still fine. Still vulnerable to
interaction. And then Colin sees some
random list with two hooks in it and he
goes, "Okay, let's give that a try." And
it starts out rough and then the engine
really gets going and we go, "Oh, this
thing's just crazy. We got to do what
this, you know, we have to play this."
>> Well, it definitely seems to be doing
well and we hope to see it continue to
do well this weekend. Uh, are there any
teams or players that [music] you're
hesitant to go against this weekend?
>> You know, there are a lot of other teams
out there. There's like TSS is popping
up and then you've got Allen's team.
But, uh, at Challenger TCG, we don't
fear anybody.
>> I love that. Well, would you like to
shout anyone out or where people can
find you?
>> Yeah, absolutely. So, shout out to the
team. Everybody at Challenger TCG. I
love everybody. It's the best team in
the world. Uh, shout out to everybody
back home who's supporting me. And then
you can find me on Twitter, uh, CTCG
Ziden.
>> Awesome. Um, well, thank you so much and
good luck this weekend, Global Blanc.
>> Thank you.
>> We have the champion deck of RQ Sydney,
which is Ireelia, the Blade Dancer. So,
what she does is that when you are able
to play uh target her first and then you
play a a power and you're able to move a
champion or a unit of your wish. And
then we also have Aurelia Fervent. And
Aurelia Fervent is whenever you target
her or she ready, she gains plus one.
She also has deflect which makes her
very resistant against removal. So the
biggest thing about this deck that I
love the inclusion of is scuttle. So
with the scuttle, this really wasn't
that common in the uh RQ Sydney at
first. It was actually pretty low play
rate, but we saw it perform
exceptionally well and I expected to
become a mainstay of the deck for sure
and definitely one of my favorite cards
of the new set for too. Uh we have tide
turner as well which we love tide turner
because it acts as a two drop and then
on top of that we're able to use it to
move Ireelia to safety or or more
importantly stellic corn herder and what
that card does is it draws you a card
every single time that it moves and we
have seen this card perform well over
and over again. It's been a mainstay of
the deck and Aurelia just uses the
utility of it so well. The other cards
that we have in this deck that help
Areia survive is the guardian angel,
which is really important because
whenever Aurelia dies, this keeps her a
little bit more protected. And because
she is such an important piece of the
deck, we have to protect her pretty much
at all cost. And sometimes it will even
go on that Celicorn herder that we
talked about earlier. We have other
spells to protect her such as the
Defiant Dance, which is the card that
gives you plus two might and then also
takes away two might from your opponent.
And let's go ahead and take a look at
the battlefields here. The biggest
addition to Ireelia has been that
abandoned hall. Abandoned hall has been
really critical as what it does is it
gives your units plus one for each spell
that you play. And with Ireelia, it's
even better because it acts as a chosen
because you choose Ireelia with the
abandoned hall. You actually get plus
two with Ireelia which is incredibly
strong and it makes playing abandoned
hall with Ireelia or into Ireelia just
so much might so quickly. And then we
have the Targon's Peak which is often
our go first, but it doesn't have to be
our go first battlefield running those
two runes. So you do have those really
efficient spells where you are able to
uh make sure that she is uh getting all
that might and being nice and protected.
You have your defies in there as well.
And then finally, we have our sunken
temple. And with sunken temple, we are
able to draw more cards with that five
might conquers. And this is really good
against a lot of lists who aren't
running a lot of high might units. So
this sometimes becomes your neutral or
your go first battlefield depending on
what matchup you're up against. And now
that we have the champion Aurelia,
there's lots of ways of building
Ireelia. So, let's go ahead and take a
look at the next deck, which is a top
eight Ireelia finisher as well. And what
we have here is we'll notice is a lot of
one-offs. There's a lot of one-ups
because Stellorn Herder allows you to
draw through cards over and over again.
So, you're going to see most of your
deck anyway. So, that's one of the big
things about this list is that it also
has a lot of hidden cards in it where
you're always going to keep your
opponent on their toes because usually
people are used to seeing tide turner as
the hidden card, but instead we have
things like the uh Edge of Night for
instance, which is a very uncommon card
that is run, but I'm sure that it threw
a lot of people off guard. There's also
the hourglass which we have as well
which is a very common hidden card but
then we aren't just stuck with just tide
turner and hourglass over and over again
which makes this deck very unique. And
then on top of that we also have the
regular standard things such as the uh
boots of swiftness or the swifties as we
like to call them. And then we have
charm, which is another very common card
where you're able to get this large
Aurelia with a lot of might. And then
you're able to charm in your opponent's
card and take it down with ease. And
then finally, we do have once again the
Vex Apathetic, which has become a
mainstay in most decks, including this
Curelia deck. So with the Vex Apathetic,
you're able to play it for four might
and four cost and no power included or
required for it. And with that, it has
deflect. And it also stops your
opponent, Ireelia, from being able to
essentially accelerate their units by
using the chosen legend cost and then
being able to play that power with Vex
on the board. That's no longer an issue.
So, it helps in the mirror a lot as
well. And I really is a really common
deck. So, we do expect Vex to do a lot
of work. And that's all I have for you
today.
I'm out here on the floor here at the
regional qualifier here at Vancouver.
And of course, the players around me are
all playing in their own events. I
believe a sealed events going on right
at this current moment. But I just want
to talk about all the different formats
that you can play for Riftbound. One of
my favorites being 2v2. Now, it's one of
these formats that we're starting to
bring up a little bit more at all these
events and playing more of these sort of
scheduled sanctioned things because 2v2
changes the way the game is played
completely. You have to play to 12
points instead. And anytime a car refers
to friendly units, you're allowed to
target your friendly teammate ones as
well. Completely changes the dynamic and
the way that deck building exists as
well. So many things just like 2v2 and
sealed. Plenty of events here at
Vancouver. So, make sure you check them
out.
Welcome back. We are back with some
riftbound action as we get ready for the
next round. Uh we have a number of
legends that have gone undefeated and I
mean they're chasing those bests. We're
going to see some standing soon. But uh
soon in the but in the meantime we got
to talk about some of our favorite decks
that we've not yet had a chance to cast
on camera. And uh if I could go out and
say I would like to see some Victor
soon.
>> Some Victor. So, something that's been
really common in Victor has been those
hardcore removal decks because they do
target Aurora so well as well as
Aurelia. We saw earlier in the day what
Cool the Week can do against Aurelia.
So, seeing Victor do well wouldn't be
too surprising.
>> And for Victor, you get to just so
naturally put those salvages in your
main deck. Obviously, you can have some
additional on the sideboard. You often
get things like access to the Thousand
Tale Watcher, which is such a great
catch-up mechanic, not to mention an
absolute army of recruits. And I have to
tell you, after watching Arcane, I got
to be a uh I'm a Victor stand. What can
I say?
>> Victor is a really cool just champion
overall. Uh also, he's fun in League of
Legends, too. So, might as well check
that out.
>> Are there any heroes that you or
legends, I should say, that you're
interested in seeing that we haven't
seen yet today on stream?
>> Oh, well, we did see her on stream
earlier, but I do love Kai'Sa a lot. Um,
a big one for me is Annie. I have been
playing a lot of Annie recently and I
understand why Prismat loves that deck
so much and the ambush mechanic just she
takes such great advantage of it of
writing those runes consistently. You're
just always a threat on the board and I
know that there are several Annies who
are doing really well right now. I
personally am hoping that somewhere out
there there's an undefeated Ivvern
getting into that top cut that we can
talk about tomorrow because Ivvern is
one of the decks that I've been loving.
And I got to tell you, there's something
beautiful about like those Menagerie
style decks where you're trying to
answer all the the the tags of all the
different units trying to make some
magic happen. And I actually am a
believer in Daisy. I think that people
are sleeping on Daisy ever so slightly.
Don't get me wrong, I don't think
Daisy's like the craziest card in the
world, but I actually think it's pretty
good. And um for you though, why don't
you tell us a little bit about your
experience in Vegas because I know you
played an underrepresented legend.
>> Oh, I played Rumble in Vegas because
first off, well, I love Kai'Sa and
really the natural progression was to go
to Rumble since I wanted to play a new
champion, Spirit Forge. So, uh I was on
the first broadcast and I was able to
take a win. Not able to get my hands on
that medal, but I was one game away from
doing it. So, that's a lot of fun. And I
know there's a Rumble out there who is
doing very well right now.
>> Let's hope we get a chance to see them.
But before that, there has been some
news in the world of Riftbound, and it
comes in the form of banned cards. So,
why don't we just take a quick look at
uh in the last little while here, what
has been banned? And I know, Silver,
that uh you know, you're going to be
interested in some of these cards from a
standpoint. They were meta definers and
now they are no longer with us.
>> Oh, yeah. Of course. You know, Cold Shot
just allowed for a couple very
oppressive decks in the meta. Uh, it
allowed you to draw cards so quickly,
was so good with Ezreal because you
didn't have to pay that additional cost.
We saw Allen's EQ take multiple Ezreal
medals because of called Shot and the
decision-making that it allowed.
However, because you got so many cards
for such a little amount, it just became
a little bit too strong and allowed for
some, you know, interesting miracle
decks that we got to see. I think it's
one of those situations where you have a
card like cold shot and uh you're going
to put it three of in almost every
single deck you play as long as you have
chaos of course. And for me like I was a
little disappointed cuz I'm like I love
cold shot because I love Noturn and Cold
Shot is a beautiful Noctturn card and
unfortunately Coldshot had to go. Now we
got a lot of chaos cards here but we got
to talk about Draven the Vanquisher
because Draven absolutely dominated the
meta for Spirit Forge for essentially
the longest time. And I mean, I got to
tell you, one of the benefits of the
regionals is that you do have the best
of, which really does diversify the meta
a lot. If we didn't have those best of,
I think we would have seen a lot more of
Draven. So, I'm glad that we have that
there. What are your thoughts on the ban
of Draven?
>> Of course, I think it was a great ban
who was just super consistent to be able
to put that much on the board so early
just for one red power. So, being able
to have that in your champion zone, make
it really big, it just took over pretty
much every battlefield. and it could be
paired with Chaos who also runs Ride the
Wind. So, that was really tough. On top
of that, we do look at the battlefields
here. Obeliska Power when you played
that going second with Draven, you're
able to just go ahead and get a Draven
out right away, which was just
incredibly strong and made it a little
bit too consistent.
>> And yeah, Reaver's Row again, it it
provided the uh the defending player so
much optionality. And at the end of the
day, I have to tell you that uh
something like Scrap Heap, that was one
of my favorite cards. I remember one of
the first decks I built for Riftbound
was a Dr. Mundo deck. And Scrap Heap was
an absolute carry card for me,
generating a lot of value, not only just
making my discard pile nice and thick,
but of course allowing me to find my
Mundos, which ultimately allowed me to
close out the game.
>> Yeah, I mean, we did see some Aurora
decks that missed on Aurora that would
have loved to have had the Scrappy, for
example, with Lunar Boon would have been
a really great combo. a lot more
consistent that way. And also, I want to
say Reverse Royal wasn't only good on
just Raven, it was really good on any
decks that had a lot of good removal. It
probably would have been pretty good on
Diana, too. Uh, but it was really good
with Kai'Sa because opponents were
forced to go into the reverse row and we
were able to remove things with Kai'Sa.
Or you could also bluff with cleaves was
a really big thing that we saw where you
throw in a unit, ask your opponent, hey,
are you taking or decline this trigger?
And then after that, they decline it and
you throw a cleave or two on there and
boom, you just win the you just win that
battlefield nice and easily from there.
>> Now my friends, we are going to be going
into round seven soon, but in the
meantime, we're going to go to a quick
break. We'll be back with round seven.
>> Hey guys, I'm here with Sold Out and
Togg from Team TSS. Would you guys like
to introduce yourselves?
>> Yeah. Uh I'm Sold Out. Some people know
me, some people don't. Uh our team, the
secret sauce. Uh, I recently placed uh
second at RQ Sydney on Civer Aurora. Me
and my boy Togg, we built that deck
together. Uh,
>> what do you think about that deck, dog?
>> Best deck ever made because it was made
by me and he stole it. But yeah,
>> pretty much. Yeah.
>> Would you guys like to tell us how y'all
made y'all's team?
>> Uh, yeah.
>> Yeah, pretty much. It just started up in
set one before the full set revealed.
Uh, we were already jamming. Every time
I lost to someone, I just invited them
to a server because I just want to
practice against good players.
Obviously, that worked out. A lot of our
players have done really well in all the
tournaments. And so, we decided at
Sydney just to make the team and yeah,
that's how we
>> Yeah, Sydney was actually the first
tournament we did as TSS like proper and
they just happened to, you know, make
second. I was like, "All right, well,
worked out."
>> Yeah, it seemed like it worked out
really well. I mean, I've heard from
Little Birdie, you kind of mentioned it
earlier, but I heard you guys built the
Civer Deck together. Could you tell me a
little bit about it?
>> Uh, well, so the originally the deck
started as Togg's creation. Uh, well,
Togg's uh adaptation of the existing uh
Civer Aurora deck. Uh, and then like two
weeks before the event, I'm like, I have
no idea what to play because every deck
I'm playing is terrible and I don't want
to bring this to the original qualifier.
And then T was like,
>> yeah, pretty much just sent sold the
list. And then I think every single day
for 2 weeks, we jammed like 12 hours
straight of just like S into everything.
Yeah. And then obvious
stuff that Civer Aurora wins when
Aurora's on the field and a lot of
people like to play cards that are good
only when Aurora's on the field and
you're already winning and it's like why
are we playing like if we're already
running like these cards just win more,
you know? So we make the deck more
consistent. Find it, play it, win the
game. Like that's all you need to do.
>> That makes a lot of sense. Are there any
teams or players that you're like
hesitant going into this weekend?
>> Everybody can get it. Yeah,
>> everybody can get it.
>> I'm pretty sure that like between me and
Todd, we're the best players like in the
game
>> on planet Earth.
>> Well, I'm the best player in the game.
>> He's getting there. He's He's close, you
know.
>> How do y'all feel about Challenger TCG?
They're another team that's playing this
weekend.
>> Who?
[laughter]
>> Well, would you like to shout anyone out
or uh anything like that?
Shout outs.
>> Uh, shout out the rest of the TSS
brothers, Gail, Veggie, Don.
>> Absolutely. Yeah. Yeah. It's a team
effort. Like none of us would be here if
it wasn't for anybody, everybody else on
the team, you know.
>> Sharpens iron.
>> Well, yeah.
>> Awesome. Well, thank you guys so much
and good luck this weekend.
>> Good. Thank you. Thank you.
>> Hey guys, I'm back with No Veggies from
Team TSS. Would you like to introduce
yourself a bit?
>> Uh, yeah. You already said my name. I'm
I'm No veggies. I'm known for uh civer
and stuff like that. Uh and I like
ripbound.
>> That's a good answer. Do you I like
ripbound as well. Are there any legends
that you really like in particular?
>> Um obviously my near near and dear my
heart is Civer uh prior to this format.
Um also I'm very uh very fond of playing
uh the Annie deck.
>> Um apart from that I'm just a combo
player in general. I like the combo
decks. I like the intricate stuff.
Leblanc is pretty fun too. Even though
my main my favorite legend does not
combine with any of that. They made
Poppy completely different about
anything. So, it's been rough trying to
adjust to that.
>> Oh, no. Well, you're definitely known
for playing your Civer list in set two.
You bested with it. How do you feel
about the old Civer versus the new one?
>> Uh, completely different beast. Um, the
old server uh obviously was a lot less
linear compared to now it's you can
basically call it an Aurora deck, but I
they I actually think they share some
similarities in the sense that like they
do have a lot of options to how to
navigate their turns. Obviously, you can
like summarize it to like get to Aurora
when game, but people don't really talk
about it after you have you're actually
in the game with your opponent that
didn't scoop because they saw Aurora.
Um, watching the game play out is
actually very interesting and um,
watching the other player trying to
combat the constant flood of monsters
and watching server trying to beat the
hate they bring in from the sideburn and
stuff like that. It's actually
interesting gameplay when both players
open optimal obviously.
>> Well, how do you feel about Annie in
this new set?
>> Uh, completely different how she worked
in set one. um she used to be like uh
like a hit and run deck sort of and she
sort of works in the same way but now
she is has some aspects of that but also
uh more like mid-rangy aspects to where
she's trying to crack battlefield uh and
then get out quickly with flash and
stuff like that or set up Vex to where
your opponent can't really answer to the
board and then you can hit back and do
it's really interesting trying to adjust
playing Annie again um in my testing uh
I think it's pretty different to how she
played inside to where she's like just
ran around everywhere. Doesn't care what
the opponent does. I get the six points
vibrate the win. Smile.
>> That makes a lot of sense. So, going
into the tournament this weekend, are
you hesitant about going with any
players or teams?
>> Um, not particularly. I'm honestly like
I don't really care who uh goes in front
of me. Um, I'll play them the same way.
Um, obviously if I choose to play Annie
for the main event, I have Prisma to
compete for and that's not the easiest
thing to to realize. But I I play the
dicks cuz I like them. I enjoy them. So
if I'm if it's good competition, you
know, to have someone at that caliber,
uh being the running in for the same
leader as you are. Or maybe I just play
Poppy tomorrow. Who knows?
>> Or you could play Poppy.
>> Or I could play Poppy. I could always
play Poppy.
>> Is there anybody you like to shout out?
>> Uh man, there's like so many. Uh we'll
keep it brief to the to the ones that
come off the top of my head. Um
obviously Spicy Hot, my sponsor. Uh best
merch. Um
uh to the boys back in Florida, John
Garcia, Tristan, um Terry, all the guys
from obviously all the guys from TSS
that helped me test. Um Ver who keeps my
crazy ideas in check. Um
who else? Uh my mom. Love my mom.
>> That you always have to shout mom. That
is for sure. Well, thank you so much for
talking with us today and good luck this
weekend as you fight for maybe the best
of Annie or maybe the best of Poppy.
>> Let's see how I wake up.
>> We'll see.
>> So, it's been a really eventful day here
in Vancouver. And I mean, we got to talk
about standings eventually, right?
There's got to be some undefeated
legends out there and we're going to
find out who they are
>> soon. Maybe
>> soon.
Screen. Boom. We got it. All right. What
do we got here?
>> Well, first off, I have to point out we
have Dewali undefeated on Diana, our
Houston champion,
>> on Annie before.
>> Absolutely. We'd love to see that. Yeah.
And Randy, we did cast Randy Prior
continuing to go 6 and0 on Aurelia, the
Blade Dancer. And I mean, we're going to
expect to see Aurelia be doing very,
very well. And we do have a number
undefeated on this list here.
>> On top of that, we have Rexi, the void
burrower, also undefeated that we casted
earlier. and Rexi making it to day two
after not making it to day two for a bit
now in our tournament. So really cool to
see that Rexi deck do so well.
>> We also have Exale running the Draven
Glorious Executioner. We were just
talking about the the ban on Draven, how
it impacted that archetype so so much.
And then now what we have here is a 6
and0 and I mean as you go on in Swiss
it's only going to get harder. So I hope
that they're able to still continue cuz
you know I wouldn't have mind seeing a
Draven. Also, we have what you've been
rooting for, Azir with a 6 and0 as well.
Plenty of Master Y is there. Of course,
Civer the Aurora is there as we do have
um multiple Civer players making it into
that 6o, making that day two as
expected.
>> Now, I do want to call out we do have
Master Ye's on this list. And what's
crazy about this is we were kind of
previewing here and there. Okay, what
are people bringing for Master Y? We're
seeing some mid-range Master. We're
seeing some different variations. And
so, that's really exciting. But we might
get a chance to see some mid-range
Master Yi back.
>> So, we have to point out here we have an
undefeated Victor here, 6 and0. Very
interesting to see that deck. Hopefully,
we're able to take a look at that in the
future as it is the only well might be
the only Victor in the top uh in the 6
pool. More Diana. We do have Allen's EQ
making it 6 with Diana. We saw him do
some really clean play earlier and we
expect him to continue to do well as he
does make it to day two for sure.
>> Shout out to some of these extreme
noodles. I wish I thought of that first.
Can only be possibly second to Pog
Chungus. Absolutely unbelievable here.
These have been great results, right?
And a lot of these of of course are
chasing these best of. And is this the
first Rengar we're seeing on Well, look
at that. It's the champion of Las Vegas,
Sam D. Sherman. Of course, I mean, we're
seeing a lot of names come here over and
over again. We see some secret sauce.
Dizzy on Civer is also coming up here at
501. Still in the running as well. So, a
lot of great players here. And we do see
our first Vex, too. One that we were
probably expecting to see a little bit
more in this uh pool, but still making
it into that 50 and one. Needs to win
another game here.
>> I actually really like Vex. I'm
surprised we haven't seen any Vexes yet
because for me, I'm all about like those
hold decks. I mean, we've been talking
about Ivvern so much. I I mean, Azir is
definitely not a whole deck, but Vex, I
think, has a lot of interesting tools,
and it would be very interesting to see
if it can end up in the top. Well, I'm
sure it's going to end up in a top cut,
but I don't know how much further it'll
get.
>> Well, I expect Vex to still get there
some way, one way or the other, although
I am surprised by it. We do see a set
the boss there as a 501 record, still in
the running to make that day two and
even make the top eight potentially.
really important there. Anything else
that you're seeing here that you're
interested in?
>> Well, I have to tell you, it's about
time we see some Ezreals. Ezreal was
such a dominant factor in the meta just
even a few regionals ago and then now
things have rapidly changed. Seeing
these Ezreals doing as well as they are
is good to see. We have Ranatada from
you know who. That is a familiar name. I
think I know who casted that uh that
pairing there. And then of course as uh
as we mentioned prior, we do have set
the boss at the top. Now, Set is one of
those legends that like I think has the
potential to really perform early on in
Origins. It had a ton of really really
strong results and then he kind of just
disappeared.
>> Yeah, set's kind of a bit niche. Uh been
really popular popularized overall by
challenger TCG. So, seeing Set there is
not it's expected, but it's not the name
I was expecting to be paired with it.
Okay, so let's take a second to talk
about some upcoming events in Riftbound.
It's a busy schedule and I mean it's
going to be a ton of fun here. And first
of all, we do have the organized play.
You do have the summoner skirmishes
which is a competitive event that you
can compete in. You have the QR codes on
the screen here as well as the Nexus
Knights. [music] How are your
experiences in both Nexus Knights and
the Scum Summoner Skirmishes?
>> Well, I play in them all the time. U
Nexus Knights can be very dependent on
what your local stores do. Some are a
bit more [music] competitive, some are a
bit more casual. There's a little bit of
everything for everyone. You just have
to find the right spot for you.
Skirmishes [music] tend to be more on
the competitive side depending on the
store. Once again, uh some of the ones
that I have in my locals will have 60
plus people there. It's a huge event. So
many players come out, test against each
other, a lot of camaraderie. It's just a
great experience [music] overall.
>> I have to tell you, it's one of my
absolute favorite parts about Riftbound.
Being able to go to Nexus Knights, you
make friends, you tra It's a trading
card game, and trading is one of my
favorite things to do. Now on the screen
we do have the official road map for
2026. We have Houston the first North
American major won by Dewali on the
Annie and we have Bolognia of course.
Now these are in the past but I'll tell
you both of us we were both at Vegas.
>> Oh yes we were. And Vegas was so much
fun. Absolutely loved my experience
there. Kept me coming back for more.
>> Now the schedule only gets more fun. And
you know highlighting there is May 8th
which was the release of Unleashed. That
was monumental and it actually closed
the gap between the release in China and
of course in [music] North America and
uh Europe and for Vendetta. It should be
along the same lines which is
particularly exciting. And hey, look at
that. Vancouver. I I know that there and
Vendetta coming on July 31st. [music]
>> Yes. And right away we'll be going to
Barcelona in August 21st through 23rd.
So make sure [music] to check that out.
>> Los Angeles. For me, I've circled Los
Angeles. I want to be in Los Angeles. I
think that's going to be a ton of fun
because it's also right when Radiance is
coming out. I love the idea that we have
a regional uh you know relatively after
the uh the Radiance little bit of time.
So, it's going to allow people to really
cook there and try to establish kind of
like uh what their game plan is.
Actually, I think the uh the graphic
kind of deceived me there because yeah,
Radiance is [music] October 23rd in Los
Angeles, September 25th.
[laughter] Oh, I got I got too caught up
in the graphics and the order. So, uh,
anyhow, but, uh, yeah, I I want to take
a second to talk about Las Vegas because
that was one that we got a chance to
participate in. And I know that you
actually had a chance to play Rumble on
the main stage.
>> Yep. Uh, I brought Rumble because I was
hunting for a middle card and didn't
quite work out for me. I was very close,
but I did play the first round on stage
and was able to get a win against
Miracle Jinx, which was another fun deck
to see as well.
>> Yeah, that's fantastic. And guys, I got
great news. Round seven is about to
start and it's up to you to decide who
is going to be on stream first. Oh my,
what are the chances? It's Extreme
Noodles on Victor. Just finished
shutting out Extreme Noodles. I love it.
Match A. So you can spam in the chat
whether you want A or B. Match A is
Extreme Noodles on Victor versus Annie.
And then match B is going to be Kaisa
versus Master Yi. Spam the chat now.
>> And we don't know if that Master Yi is
the mid-range version or Aurora. So, if
you take that choice, that's the gamble
on you, chat.
>> That's right. I'm I'm spamming A. I got
to be honest. I want to see I want to
see some victory. And you know, I love
Annie, too. But because I said that, now
everyone's going to spam B. So, I
shouldn't have said anything. But yeah,
either one of these matches. I know you
love Kai'Sa. And I to be honest, I just
want to kind of see what build of
[music]
uh the Wu Bladesman this might be cuz
like there are various different builds
of um Masi. You're seeing the Aurora
variation, you're seeing the mid-range
variation, and like players are bringing
both right now.
>> Oh, yeah. That was one of the big things
we're expecting was more Aurora E
potentially because it really had fallen
out of favor for a bit, but with
Aurora's rise, we expected to see a
little bit more of it. However, we've
also seen a ton of gear in main board.
So, it really becomes this cat- mouse
game of deciding which one's going to be
which at this point.
>> Well, my friends, I've got great news.
The votes are in and I might have
influenced the tally slightly because
it's going to be match A. Extreme
Noodles is going on and we're going to
see Annie versus Victor. I got to tell
you, I'm actually excited. This is our
Is this our first Victor on stream
today?
>> It's our first Annie as well.
>> It is our first Annie. I was so fixated
on Victor. And it's Annie's first time
on stream as well. And we've got the
deck on the screen. What stands out to
you? Well, first off, this one's running
more units than what we had seen in
previous Victor where I was very
concerned about playing Kohl's and
Hidden, but I really like the units
here. Of course, we've talked about Vi
all day. Such a strong card, a big
[music] piece of the deck overall. And
of course, we are bringing back Riptide
Rex, something we had not seen for a
while.
>> That's right, Riptide Rex. It's
basically Singularity on an alligator.
I'm not he's an alligator. I'm not sure.
Crocodile. I'm not sure. I'm just really
not sure. But Riptide Rex is amazing.
That's what I'll tell you right now. But
yeah, you're right. This deck is built
to be aggressive. Even in the
Battlefield slot there, you do see the
arena's greatest. They know what they
have to do to win. They don't want to be
in these long Drono matches versus the
Auroras and the slower Leblancs and
stuff like they want to get the they
want to get the win nice and fast. Now,
there are a couple combos here worth
mentioning. You do have the Thousand
Tail Watcher, which is a fantastic
combo. You can bring things [music] down
potentially to one might and then you're
able to hit them with the Bellow's
Breath. But it doesn't just stop there
cuz Bella's breath combos with another
card,
>> Imperial [music] Decree, which is a
fantastic card overall. Um, being able
to just kill anything. Essentially,
[music] it way to think of it is it sets
everything down kind of one might uh as
a way to think of it. If you take dam if
it takes damage, you kill it, [music]
which is a really cool card overall.
Absolutely love this card. And of
course, uh, we also have the sprite
fountain as well, which is something
interesting that we hadn't seen really
teched into Victor quite yet because it
does it's a way for Victor to gain
points pretty efficiently, which is
really strong because you're you really
aren't playing the unit game. You're
playing more of the spell game overall.
But I really like these unit choices
from Victor.
>> Yeah, sprite fountain is being found in
Victor. It's being found in Or it's
pretty much everywhere. And as much as I
love noodles, I would love to see the
next deck that we're talking about here
today. And we got here it's Annie. Now
Annie has seen this constant evolution.
Obviously it started off as a deck that
like I think people were kind of
sleeping on a little bit in the openings
of Origins. We didn't see much Annie
success and then that completely changed
with Dewali uh winning in Houston. So
what are your thoughts on this
particular deck? There's a lot of new
cards splashed in.
>> A big thing is just how much this deck
has evolved overall. Uh the origins deck
has a good number of differences
specifically because of the ambush
mechanic which we see from Rengar is a
big player in this deck. uh I've found
to have huge swings because the assault
plus two and a reaction and overall for
one power this is worth a lot
>> of course and of uh another thing worth
mentioning you do have the Vex apathetic
[music]
uh two of in the main deck here that's
going to it's kind of interesting right
because with Annie not only you trying
to be as aggressive as possible but you
also shut down the aggressive decks as
well with Vex [music] apathetic
>> yes Annie does this fun little dance
overall and of course we have starcross
it's been an MVP of this tournament in
multiple situations. And the thing that
you can do that's really interesting
about this is you can put your Annie
Stubborn back into your hand and bounce
even more decks from your recycle uh
from your trash, which is really nice
because it just allows for more value
because you have good onplay effects as
well.
>> I've got great news, Silver. We're ready
to see the match. Let's go to round
number seven.
>> I can't wait for it.
Okay.
>> All right. We have seed of power and
treasure These Okay, we've seen a
couple of these now. And okay, hold on
here.
>> Is that a porro on their head?
>> That looks like a porro to me.
>> Sweating.
>> That is okay. I got to hunt that that uh
>> that down. I need that hat.
>> Okay, will they let me wear that hat on
stream? Like, am I going to wear that
hat? Cuz I think I need to find it.
>> Yeah, but it's just the pressure of like
>> It's either that or the Teemo hat. The
Teemo hat's another amazing one.
>> Absolute amazing merch from from our
friends at Ry. I have a couple of those
Teemo hats back from when I played a
bunch of League of Legends in college
and we had a League of Legends club.
>> All right, and now we are getting
started.
We're in the mulligan phase here.
I see Bella's breath.
>> Um,
>> we have Deadly Flourish there as well.
>> Good luck.
>> Like their hand quite a bit here. So,
uh, of course we have to talk about Seed
of Power again because first off, I love
this battlefield over and over again.
We've seen it get so much value from all
these aggressive decks. It's a really
great neutral battlefield as well. So, I
just absolutely love seeing the seed of
power come out to play again.
>> Going to top one
>> starting off with the Inferna here.
>> And again, that Annie ability, it's
going to be one of those ones that just
it just ages so well. There's always a
benefit to having two
>> open runes at the end of your turn.
>> That would be so aggressive.
>> Yes, it has so much ability to just
react to, especially with the ambush
mechanic being added. Uh being able to
throw a unit that can't be countered
onto the battlefield is huge. A lot of
math involved in this deck because of
the ambush mechanic. Lots of assault as
well. So has to think about this quite a
bit because the inferna does really well
attacking into battlefields. Doesn't do
so well waiting for them.
>> Kai'Sa survivor coming onto the field of
play. One of Fury's top cards if not uh
one of their absolute best.
>> So I really like this hold on the
Inferna, not being too aggressive with
it because we're looking to do a double
conquer next turn potentially,
especially if we do have something like
a cleave in hand or other accelerates.
We're able to refill our hand with the
seed of power if we are able to do a
double conquer. And because Victor did
miss that early drop, uh it's less of an
issue here. So, we should be able to
take a double conquer depending on what
it is. And we are seeing that carry on
dredger. Not a card that we see very
often, but we did see it earlier today.
So, had to go ahead and take a look at
that card to read it.
>> Yeah, it generates so much value. That
death now bringing out that bird token,
which is exactly what Victor wants to
do. who wants to have as many tokens as
possible cuz even with that Imperial
decree, you could have an elder dragon
out there and all you need is a little
recruit to just jump on in and give him
a little pop and that'll be enough. And
what we're going to see here is Inferno
going into the treasure board and then
as you called out, seed of power I'm
sure will be next.
>> Yes. And potentially a double draw there
with the Kai'Sa conquer on top of the
seat of power. Lots of cards, lots of
availability for this Annie and with the
extra runes available too. hasn't had to
d ramp at all because we didn't
accelerate that Kai'Sa. Great play from
the San.
>> Now, we saw a flash drawn there.
>> We'll have to see uh what their next
play is. Still all the runes are
available here. So, they have lots of
options. We're going four.
>> I really like being able to have this
flash of course as Andy will always have
access to it. So, looking at potentially
playing Looks like we have a
>> another Kai'Sa.
>> Kai'Sa. Let's go. and Inferna coming
out. Okay, awesome.
>> Two runes up and ready ready to defend
that battlefield. Now, the Inferno
obviously is going to be a little
susceptible just to a little recruit
jumping in here, but Kais is going to
need a little more a little more of a
reaction or action to kind of get over
the hump.
>> So, something interesting here is that
Annie might just be able to play a value
game here because we have the Kai'Sa, we
have the flash, we have seed of power.
Usually Annie doesn't have access to a
lot of card draw outside of really
Kai'Sa and we might just be able to out,
you know, just outv value this Victor
deck, which is weird to say because this
is a pretty hard control deck overall.
It shouldn't be something that you
should be easily outvaluing. But we
might be able to see that because of
this particular setup.
>> Focus being passed. The point is scored
there and the bird token will be
generated. One of the uh well it is the
value by the Kurran dredger there.
Yep. And I like taking that trade there.
A lot of players may have thought like,
"Let's just play this flash. We'll save
everything right away." But, uh, the
anti player understands that the flash
is more valuable than that. It at the
end of the day, this uh, Inferna is
going to die at some point. And allowing
to be now is perfectly fine, especially
when we aren't looking to reconquer the
seat of power. So, holding that
battlefield isn't really going to do
anything. And then just saving an
Inferna is also not going to do that
much. and it could potentially save the
Kai'Sa in the future as well, but really
it's not going to be targeted. So, I
really like just holding on to it.
>> And Riptide Rex comes on down. Kai'Sa is
going to pay the price and it's honestly
it's it's a fantastic play. It's it's
and again with that recruit, you go and
you conquer and again, seed of power
getting a proc
>> and because it was only at a battlefield
that Reptide Rex hits, the flash
actually does save this Kai'Sa. So, by
saving this flash, we were able to get
the Riptide Rex out. um to counter it
and also it is two blue power. So this
is actually a very expensive Rex to not
do what we were wanting to do with it
>> of course but one of the benefits as
well is that now you got the body so if
that Kaiso wants to come back in which
you know it wants to
>> maybe you'll be able to punish there but
yeah excellent use of the flash.
>> Yeah, excellent play from Annie once
again. Really liking what I'm seeing
here.
>> That's good. Yeah. All right, point
scored
>> and we will get the draw from the Kai'Sa
conquer
>> from KSA.
>> Another one too. Like I said, the value
game is going to be so strong here with
the power. Double draw from Kai'Sa once
again. I mean, this Annie's hand is
going to become bigger [laughter] than
the draw pile here pretty soon.
>> That's right. It's looking like a
Leblanc deck all of a sudden. Tons of
cards in hand, tons of options. And when
you give Andy a ton of opt and
[laughter]
well would you I mean it's the alt art
at least. So we have a little bit of
variation but do you like Kai'Sa?
Because we have Kai'Sa survivor. That's
right. Bring it on the screen. There we
have another Kai'Sa
>> and we have all the tools we need to
protect them and they are going to
continue to draw cards. But it doesn't
mean that our Victor player does not
have answers because you know they do.
>> On top of that, four runes up here for
Annie as well. Lots of options for if
there is uh you know uh the rough tide
rex coming in potentially. We'll see. Is
that another flash in hand ready to go?
We have abandoned there. Hard bargain.
Lots of answers available
>> and lots of runes up. Not just the two.
>> So let's see what Victor can really do
here. It's it's a tough spot to be in
for sure. Might be looking just to see
if we can clear out this Kai'Sa. I
really like how we're not going for the
one on seed of power because obviously a
reconquer there is even more draw. So
going for this battlefield makes a lot
more sense.
>> Yeah. Long sword onto the
>> Kai'Sa
>> going to increase its power here.
>> Focus being passed.
>> Has to decide if there's anything else
that can be done here. Looks like we're
going to a trade.
>> Wow. Good defense set up by uh by Annie.
>> Still has a flash in hand for the future
as well. We have a stacked deck there is
what we can also see which will give us
access to even more options in the
future.
>> And hard bargain is always relevant.
There's going to come a time when you
need that hard bargain.
>> Four play deadly first on your
>> daily flourish
>> and has a couple of options here. Uh
this is a full full four energy here. So
four energy. We might look at playing
the abandoned. Yesand
>> because it's just such a high amount of
energy. It's a very quality abandoned
for that reason. And we'll see. We'll
take the predict as well from that
assuming it resolves.
>> It's so interesting. These are both like
almost aggro style decks but they're
playing them in like you're having these
like very control ccentric showdowns
here where they're they're trying to
outwit each other with their reactions.
You know what it is? It's the porro
licking his forehead. It's giving him
some sort of like insight into the best
possible place.
>> I mean, porro brain on top of your
brain. Just put them together.
>> Wonder how smart porros are.
>> You know what? I got to be honest with
you. I don't something of both of I I
don't know if they're very bright. I
just [laughter] I got to be honest with
you. I don't know the porro lore.
There's got to be a smart porro
somewhere. They look like they could be.
All right. that's going to come out
accelerated cuz you do have the two
tokens available here and so we're going
to be able to apply some pressure which
is what extreme noodles is going to want
to do here.
>> Yes. And at four might as well can
potentially do something against this
Kai'Sa. However, notice that we are
tapped out here. So if Kai'Sa does have
an answer, it will be a freebie here.
>> This is nerve-wracking. Two up and there
is an answer there and it's going to be
the flash. Bring Kaisa back.
>> Yep.
>> Yep. It's just too much value to leave,
especially with the sword, long sword
ready to go. Going to be able to likely
double conquer here once again and get
up to six points and also draw more and
also draw even more and then draw even
more. I can always I can already see the
vision. I see it. [laughter]
>> This is actually kind of exciting. Like
it's it's kind of rare that you have an
Annie with this much optionality going
into every single turn. There's a ton
here. And on top of that often have the
Annie just having so many options
afterwards. We see that Nox is hopeful
as being a new draw as well. A very
efficient drop that we will likely see.
So many runes available. It's almost ner
it's like almost too much to decide what
to play here. Of course developing you
can't really go wrong. We know that uh
Imperial decree though with the Bellow's
breath. So we do have to take a look at
that and watch out for that as well.
been holding these units back to
potentially make trades with Imperial
Decree as well. So, this board could
actually be cleared in some
circumstances.
>> Yes. So, we see a stack deck. We see the
Noxis Hopeful there. Lots of options.
And again, the amount of draw being
generated is absolutely crazy. Using
seed of power to perfect effectiveness
throughout the entire course of this
game. Nox's hopeful does come down.
>> Doesn't get much better than a two for
four
>> or a four for two. and did get a little
bit of peak in the hand as it's being
shuffled here from extreme noodles.
There is a coal, there's a bellow's
breath, and there's a deadly flourish in
the hand for sure here.
>> So, judge intervene there.
>> I will play this one.
>> And we're going to see the overzealous
fan come out to defend the treasure
horde.
>> So, there is a thousand tailed watcher
in hand as well. I just saw that come
through. And we have the bellow's breath
combo. So, we're going to probably see a
lot of removal coming up here for
Extreme Noodles.
>> Okay.
>> And Extreme Noodles needs to get back in
this game.
>> You're playing an aggressive style deck.
You're down six to three. And again, in
Riftbound, one of the most dangerous
numbers. I mean, eight's the most
dangerous. Sometimes it's nine, but
eight is a very dangerous number. The
second most dangerous number is six.
>> Exactly. Because of that double hold
potential. However, I think we are going
to see a play here from Extreme Noodles
to try to clear this board. Thousand
tilled Watcher. All these units are with
the exception of Kaisa the long sword
are at six or four or less. Kai'Sa being
at six might. So, there should be ways
to clear this out. I mean, even the
Thousand Tailed Watcher plus Bellows in
the uh base will do a lot. And we do
have those units, the tokens ready to go
as well. Imperial decree will do it as
well. So, lots of activity is about to
go on here.
>> And those recruits, you just send them
in one at a time.
>> But also, as you mentioned, you got
Bellow's breath, right?
>> And hard bargain comes down as well.
>> Yep. You got this one.
>> Yeah.
>> Yep.
>> That's a GG on game one there.
>> Yeah, that hard bargain we we mentioned
it prior. We knew it was going to be a
valuable component to the victory there.
And I mean, when you have a hand, like
you're looking at your opponent, they're
an anti player. They have runes up. They
got like they're they're holding their
deck in their hand basically.
>> There's going to come a point in time
where they're going to be able to close
it out.
>> It felt like I was an old Draven player
from Spirit Forge where it's just like,
"All right, I have access to everything
now. Um, you better push your luck and
hope that you can do something." But
that's all that Victor can really do
there is say, you know, if you have it,
you have it. If you don't, maybe I can
come back into this game. Even if they
did were able to clear that board, there
are so many resources for Annie that it
was going to be hard to come back,
especially when we were at six points
already.
>> It does look like Extreme Noodles is
heavily sideboarding here. Kind of wish
the camera angles are like the other
side over the shoulder, but we're going
to see what they're teching in here to
see if they can kind of make a comeback.
They're going to have to win the next
two
>> against Annie
>> Annaporro.
And Annie is running that Zan Warren,
which is very strong for her as well.
It's a card that has been around since
Origins has really been a mainstay
because you are able to filter through
your deck even more. However, a lot of
opponents do not want to discard their
own cards. You're mulligating to get
specific cards and you want specific
cards and Annie has learned to be okay
with it. A lot of opponents will
sometimes avoid going to Zon Warren just
because they don't want to discard a
card that they need.
>> Oh, well, you're still cutting, right?
>> And with Arena's Greatest,
unfortunately, you're against an Annie
deck.
>> They don't mind Arena's greatest.
Actually, they might even love Arena's
greatest, especially since the way that
last game went.
>> But I do think that without the seed of
power, we won't quite see that
absolutely epic uh flow of cards into uh
hand.
>> Yeah, I'm actually really interested to
hear the idea of the arena's greatest.
Um maybe it's to be faster than things
such as like Leblanc, for instance,
where you don't want to play an aspirin
climb to some of these slower decks that
have more value than you. You're kind of
in the middle between the two. You're
not the fastest deck. You're not the
slowest deck. So saying often times I do
want to speed the game up against these
slower decks. So it's worth it. Of
course, Annie just isn't the best
matchup for it for as the reason you
said Annie is quick. She wants to get on
the board. She wants to score points.
She is totally fine with taking the
arena's greatest the extra point at the
start of the turn.
>> I think I see two Noxis Hopefuls, a
Falling Star, and possibly a traveling
merchant.
>> Yeah, that's exactly what I was saying.
trying to get better at reading cards on
an angle or just like the corner of the
card. It's a practice skill, I guess.
And looks like they might be keeping
their hand. I mean, it's a pretty solid
hand overall. I'm assuming that Extreme
Noodles is going to be taking first. We
don't actually have confirmation of that
yet. We do have uh Singularity in hand
for Extreme Noodles.
>> Yeah, Singularity sometimes can be an
absolute blowout card, especially when
we did see as many Kaises as we did.
That is pretty expensive, but noted that
we didn't have to see them accelerated.
So, a lot of it kind of comes down to
that. Uh, we will see if we get that
turn one drop or not. If not, Victor is
there for us so we always have an
option.
>> Silver, I have great news. They remember
the greatest the arena's greatest we did
it.
>> We did it.
>> We got it.
>> That's a great way to start the game for
sure. And we get
>> Yep. Traveling Merchant. Just such a
great card overall. Able to filter
through. A lot of decisions to be made
with this card because Zon Warren if you
take merchant into it you have to
discard two cards and draw two cards
which is a lot of decisions to be made
but the high agency of these type of
decks is what makes these players so
good and that's why they are consistent
and getting these 6.
>> Carryan dredger is going into the
arena's greatest to score its first
point. We go to two
>> and no didn't want to go into that Z
warns and we talked about earlier how
sometimes players don't want to discard
cards in their hand. They're like
actually I like all my cards. I don't
want to think about which one I got got
to get rid of. I just spent my time
deciding which ones I wanted to keep. So
that is something important to notice
here. Also on top of that by going to
the arena's greatest it forces the Annie
player not to go z when they might have
wanted to. Uh we did see them only
mulligan one card. So, usually if you
see your opponent mulligan two cards,
you're thinking, "Oh, they really don't
like their hand. They might need to
filter and look for something. But in
this case, uh that's not the case with
the only one mulligan." Instead,
>> we're going to see a wages of pain come
from hand. Is there a reaction? It's a
Rengar. Rengar coming into play to close
out that battlefield.
>> Yes, doing his job exactly as we
expected. A full amount of might just
being able to take down this dreger nice
and easily. I can confirm that Rengar
certainly pounced in that given uh
situation there.
>> Hell the battlefield the bird token is
generated. We do get a gold token as
well.
>> Unfortunately, we don't get to quite see
the cat versus bird yet, [laughter] but
it is close enough.
>> Noxis hopeful does come down. We did see
that in the opening hand and that's
going to generate a ton of value for
Annie. That 24 is just it's
unbelievable.
And we'll see what Victor can do here.
If we can establish a little bit more on
board, of course, the wages coming down
for the Rengar once again.
>> And flash. Flash being used to save the
Rengar.
>> Yep. A good way to counter that for
sure. Still gets the gold here though
for the Victor, which will be really
important when we are looking to play
things like Imperial Decree and Thousand
Tailed Watcher in the future as well.
We'll
>> have to see what this next play is.
You're going to want to develop your
board a little bit.
>> Yeah, I mean this counter play with the
flash, we've seen flash come in clutch
several times now. A lot of this has
been at a battlefield at a battlefield
and so seeing that being countered so
efficiently and effectively and just
being able to reconquer again, it just
it's such a great card overall.
>> I remember early in Origins people were
like, "Ah, flash is mid." I'm like, I
don't think so. And then you go to
Houston, you see Annie take it all and
then the rest of the meta was I need to
get more flashes. And so things rapidly
change there. Uh it's just unbelievable,
especially at reaction speed as well.
And it's not just a single, it's two
friendly units that can move back to
base. So it is a truly remarkable
ability.
>> And we do discard the Eclipse. Makes a
lot of sense here. And the draw, we
don't know, but a hidden card. We did
see a peak at Hidden Blade earlier, so
likely is Hidden Blade.
>> Could be Wages of Pain as well. Another
hidden card. That's a that's an option
there. But yeah, Hidden Blade for sure
because especially if you have that
recruit there, you target the uh recruit
with the Hidden Blade. Hidden Blade,
unless of course they're sending in
something you'd like to target yourself,
but you can draw, build up your hand,
and try to get some value that way as
well. Lots of options with hidden blade.
And we're going to find out.
>> Yes. And the question becomes, do you
hidden blade your own unit? And the
answer is yes because we saw what Annie
did when it had a lot of cards and just
confirming that I do want a hidden blade
myself being able to draw because this
is still at the end of the day. It wants
to be slightly slower to defeat this
Annie. Yes, Annie wants to go quick and
go under the Victor. However, the Victor
deck isn't going to ever beat Annie at
the go fast game, especially with the
arena's greatest. So, has to still be
very careful navigating this as a whole.
One thing I'll say as well, this is a
great lesson, a great little moment, and
how in games like this in Riftbound,
right? The score is a resource. And so
you look at the hidden blade, you're
like, do I really want to use hidden
blade on a rank, right? No, no, that's
okay. I'm going to give up the score.
>> I'm going to draw more cards. I'm going
to play the long game, right? Utilize
that resource. Now, obviously, Annie is
going to want to swipe that resource
away from you as fast as possible.
>> But in that case, I absolutely agree
that taking out that token with the
hidden blade was the correct call.
establish yourself for a better turn.
You still have the gold tokens. You
mentioned the Thousand Tales Watcher.
Thousand Tail Watcher. That will
definitely provide you some value.
There's so many ways that you can board
clear here. But the thing is is that
Annie still has so many tricks up their
sleeve.
>> Yeah, it looks like we have Singularity
in hand. We have Imperial Decree. We
also have Sprite Fountain. A couple
options there to contest these
battlefields at least.
>> I love Sprite Fountain. I think Sprite
Fountain might be one of the most
impactful cards released in this set. It
has rejuvenated
so many just aggressive archetypes.
Obviously, it's a a staple in Lilia and
I talked about or before. I don't know.
I love the card. I absolutely love
Sprite Fountain.
>> It's a great card and it's one that
feels like right in the middle of being
fair, too. Like, I'm never like, "Oh,
it's not fair. You played Sprite
Fountain." I'm like, "Oh, okay." Like,
"You played Sprite Fountain. It got you
some points. Good for you." But I've
never been like,
>> "No, how could they do Sprite fountain?
My game's not fun anymore." It's always
been like, "Oh, yeah. This is Yeah,
that's fair. Annie stubborn coming out
does bring back flash
and uh I mean if listen flash is so
good. We just talked about how good
flash is. You know what's even better is
playing flash again because you pulled
it from the trash. That's just uh that's
free value.
>> So this is a lot of information that can
be gained from this too for the reason
that we've had so much added battlefield
thing and we know that we won't be
playing things that say hey added
battlefield because we know we'll be
getting flash. So that's why we see this
singularity come down instead.
>> This is a heavy price to pay.
>> If there's a hard bargain, this game is
really tough.
>> Abandoned. Uh that's also
>> Yeah,
>> that is a rough one for sure. Abandoned
getting its full value here, more or
less.
>> Yeah, that's heartbreaking. That's
heartbreaking for Noodles.
>> And it must have been the only choice
here that really made sense because
Imperial decree gets abandoned as well.
We will see the sprite fountain come in.
So, we will be able to contest the
Rengar at least. It's better than
nothing, but it's still a really tough
time.
>> Yeah, that that was a soul crushing uh
soul crushing abandon there.
>> I do agree. I think you expect this
sprite to try to trade with this Rengar.
Still two up though on Annie.
>> Yeah, still two up. Um does have the
recruit here for the future. Really
going to be dependent on the draws and
also if Andy makes any missteps here.
Annie is a very unforgiving deck
overall. If you make missteps, you will
lose the game pretty quickly. Um, of
course, the runes can help at times, but
because she doesn't have a bunch of draw
power and really does rely on some of
these ambush units. She can misstep and
make the game tough again. But, uh,
overall, we've seen really excellent
piloting from the Sandy players. So, I'd
be surprised if they were to make a
misstep here that were to lose them the
game. However, still quite a bit of game
to go, but still that six point mark as
we talked about is ready.
>> I think I saw a 4erunner there as well,
which is going to be a uh a forwardable
card because Victor can't really like
cleanly deal with it in some way. I
mean, you could you can definitely take
it out, but there's you can't just like
bounce it to hand.
>> Well, a big thing is we already saw that
singularity come down and we know it is
in the hand. How because the abandon,
but we might have another abandon here.
We could have a hard bargain. There's a
couple options in general here. Looking
to potentially
>> hold this, but uh we're getting going to
bring back the Nox's hopeful. I really
like that play because the tokens if
they die, you know, the mechs become
tokens and we're able to reconquer this.
Annie is likely going to be dying to a
sprite. So, that's just how it is. But,
it did its job. It did exactly what it
needed to do. Although, we do have flash
available as well. So, there's lots of
options here for Annie. Yeah, I love
this setup from uh from Gonkra here
because what you've done is you have the
Noxis hopeful for that four. You see
their board, they have a recruit. They
got a sprite. Well, the sprite's not
really that relevant in the in the case,
but what I'll tell you is that Ferious
4Runner is going to have those bots
generating and in the event that you can
even remove it and you're going to be
able to just sweep right back in for
those uh two points to close out the
game. I love the board state here and uh
I think that extreme noodles is perhaps
in extreme danger of being 2 here.
Something interesting is a lot of
players have been cutting the 4erunner
for the reason that starc cross has been
in the meta. But if you're not playing
against chaos, it's not as much of an
issue. It just has so much value. First,
we do see that sprite move in and we'll
take a quick trade there.
>> The question is
>> at this point, right, like okay, so you
have the Noxisful there.
>> The 4Runner generates so much value. You
don't want to just take it out
necessarily. You have to be very careful
with how you make these next plays here.
Let's see what they do.
>> Yeah. Is there a way to come back here?
Of course, you know, even you can't even
singularity here because unless you have
a way to remove stuff afterwards because
the mechs can just double conquer. So,
there must be something in the hand to
be able to take care of these mechs as
well.
>> I have some. Thank you.
>> Okay, it looks like the turn was passed.
Clear the board. Pass turn. Two mechs
generated.
>> Still looking dangerous.
Yes. Does not take a um a point here
either. So,
>> we'll have to see what the plan is.
>> We have Cole.
>> How many cards?
>> The turn wasn't passed. My apologies.
>> I saw the hand gesture and I I'm like,
"Oh, pass turn. Okay." And then that's
not quite what happened there. I was
like, I didn't move the the recruit yet.
I think you might want that point
>> because there's a potential here of
discarding and finding a card that you
need. So, having to decide if we want to
go into Zon Warren or not. uh especially
when we know that there has been counter
spells such as hard bargain and abandon
in the deck. We have now seen both of
them. So that's a lot of knowledge about
the deck itself here.
>> Can you defend with just this recruit
though?
Two runes up,
a solo recruit.
>> It's looking dangerous
>> and it might just come down to do we
have an accelerate unit or not because
of this. Cole is going to be played
taking out the recruit taking out a mech
and the question becomes do we have a
counter spell? No is the answer to that.
So now the next question is do we have a
unit that can be ready or accelerate
into the winning
>> point for
accelerate.
>> Well the good news is is that we saw
three kaises last game
>> deck
>> stack deck. I wonder what
>> we find it.
>> That was a I didn't quite see but that
was pretty fast.
found something at least
>> looks foiled and it's Kai and that's a
good game absolutely phenomenally well
played
>> that Porro is blessed 7 and0 Annie
getting it done and I got to tell you
that was an amazing game
>> a little heartbroken for Victor but
>> when you play an [music] aggressive
match you meet your match and Annie
>> is is the end of the day it's all about
the value being generally the board and
those Kaises in the first game
absolutely just drew a storm And I did
and unfortunately for the Victor [music]
player was never able to really recover.
>> Yeah, Victor wish she had access to Vex
there for sure,
>> but really we didn't accelerate anyway.
So,
>> uh yeah, the just seeing the value of
Kai'Sa and her being such a staple since
set one. People have kind of forgotten
about her because of the quite the
downfall of Fury, but she's still so
good and can carry that domain. For me,
Victor, I think, was probably
anticipating more of these slower
matchups, right? You saw the way the
deck was built and then meeting a match
in in something like an Annie. It was
like just going against your own
strategy to some degree. And
unfortunately, when the Kaisers were
generating as much value as they were
and at the end of the day, the flashes
were really mitigating a lot of the
effects of like the singularities and
the Riptide Rexes. So, it was just such
a hard game to come back from because
you were just so far behind at every
single point.
>> Oh, yeah. And just Annie has access to
so many runes, so much energy all the
time. So that's a huge part too is
you're never safe against Annie. No
matter what, she has access to something
and with that number of cards, there was
always going to be an answer.
>> And the other thing was was like the use
of hard bargain for instance, right?
That's something that some people have
been cutting from the deck and you saw
it in its full force here. You know,
hard bargaining the uh you know, the the
singularity stuff like that. Like that
completely set the tone for the match
because Annie continuously had answers
for the questions that Victor was
asking.
>> Exactly. Just a rough match up for
Victor overall and on top of that
doesn't have access to that many units.
We didn't get to see some of the key
players like Vi come out for instance.
Uh we weren't able to make those good
trades because we didn't see those
bigger units for instance.
>> It's definitely a tough match up for
Victor cuz Victor we actually saw it
even things like the uh like Call of the
Week against an Ann deck. It's just not
going to take as much value as you're
hoping for. Right. Usually you want to
trade something like you know you
recruit for a larger unit and in this
case like we need to do like take out a
4runner then the mechs come out like
it's just it's just a matchup that is
incredibly difficult for Victor but that
doesn't mean I don't think that uh
Victor can make it into top cut or
perhaps even better. We've had some
amazing results and Victor I think is
very close to making a splash.
>> Oh yeah, Victor can definitely still do
it. I have no doubt about it and I do
expect Annie to continue do wells do
well as well.
We're going to be going to the next
match here, which is Kai'Sa versus
Master Yi. So, we do got some more
gameplay for you in round seven. Here's
the Kai'Sa deck. What do you see?
>> Well, first off, Time Warp is there. A
lot of KISS have kind of gone lower on
time warp. Some cutting it completely
and some going to zero of the time warp,
but instead we see two, which I really
like in this format because it is just
really sneaky. Overall, players forget
about Time Warp's existence pretty
often. And the fact that you can just
win from a double time warp at times
four points that definitely steals games
away. The other thing I have to
highlight is of course void seeker has
been falling out of favor until recently
because of Vex is so prevalent in the
meta. It's a very clean and efficient
way to deal with Vex. And with Kai'Sa
you can pay for the uh Damp or the
deflect cost very easily. It doesn't
feel as bad and you're drawing one on
top of that.
>> I believe we're into Master Y. Let's
take a look at this list cuz we were
talking about it prior. We're not sure
and we don't know if it is the mid-range
or the Aurora variation and we have been
answered.
>> We do have Aurora up there for us. Of
course, Elder Dragon ready to go. And
something interesting is we got the Vile
is one of the key cards in this deck as
well. Vile Mall is one of those cards
that when it when it came out obviously
in Unleash, people were really excited
about and yet I haven't seen all that
much of it and I'm kind of curious about
your thoughts on that because it seemed
like an absolutely fantastic card that
just hadn't quite like gotten into the
meta yet.
>> Yeah. Uh really a lot of players have
kind of been a love it or hate it on it
saying like Vile Mall is super overrated
or super underrated. Personally, I think
I'm on the overrated side of it, funny
enough. Uh, even in Vex, I felt like it
didn't do as much as I wanted it to do.
Of course, when it works, it really
works, though.
>> And I love the inclusion, as many Aurora
players are are including. We do have
sabotage as a two of here. Now, one can
make the argument that sabotage is being
used to, I don't know, maybe discard the
Aurora in the mirror match, but it also
has other utility as well.
>> Oh, yeah. Sabotage just gives so many so
many options. discarding gear [music] in
general spells, taking or even sometimes
just forcing your opponent to use their
own defy to stop a sabotage is
essentially discarding it. Information
[music] is power. Um, I will mention
though that this isn't your typical
Aurora deck cuz they have a bit of
another plan here cuz we do have
Desert's Call, which I think is
particularly fascinating. Desert's Call
might shore up a little bit of that
early mid game in [music] the event that
perhaps they don't get the draws they're
looking for because you can repeat it on
uh turn uh well when you have four runes
of course or you can just play it as a
two and it might generate a lot of
value.
>> Yeah, and because of uh Bladesman being
able to when you defend you get two
might. The Desert's Call actually is
deceptively stronger than what you would
expect.
>> All right, we're going to go to game two
here. Let's check it out.
It looks like we're starting off. Oh,
look at that. It's Aspirin's Climb. Who
would have thought?
>> Yep. Very strong and a signature card in
a lot of the Aurora decks. Any slower
deck looking to play Aspirin's Climb,
anything that can get you a lot of
value. And of course, Kai'Sa. Looks like
we have the Voidgate, which is very
strong for Kai'Sa and oftent times isn't
really good for the opponent outside of
a few things such as Diana.
>> Shuffle my run deck as well.
>> Looks like we're just getting ready to
get started here.
We're in the mulligan phase. Both six
and O.
>> Incredible results.
>> Let me
>> It looks like Kaiso took game one.
>> So, we do have going second or going
first aspirants climb for the master Y
here.
>> I see a not so fast in hand. We got
discipline.
>> I want to throw two on the bottom.
>> Two.
>> All right. Two being mulligan.
We have the Eclipse, the long sword, the
falling star, and the time warp in hand
for the Kai'Sa.
>> Very interesting to see if they hold
that time warp.
>> It is a two of the list, so I'd be a
little bit surprised to see it. Unless
you feel like, oh, actually, because
you're playing against Aurora, you might
have to just try to steal the game with
Time Warp at times.
>> And here we go.
>> Sure. It's Desert's Call as we mentioned
prior which does help start that early
game for the Master Yi.
>> Uh pass to you.
>> Not a good start.
>> Two or three drop here for
>> Kai'Sa with a deck that wants to get on
the board so early. He getting on the
board before Kai'Sa.
>> That's really rough.
>> It's going to go into the void gate here
and it's the hex tech ray which is going
to come down to prevent that sand
soldier from taking the point.
Catalyst of Aons dropping expected
>> and Kaisa having no way to interact with
that will always be channeling those
runes.
>> We'll have to see what this next play
looks like here.
>> That is a double time warp in hand right
now.
>> Oh, they never actually they because
they they want to be able to play time
warp to be able to essentially get that
sneak like we're going to nine points
because we're going to nine points. It's
really hard for Kai'Sa to actually find
the value to out uh to outv value Ye.
They pretty much have to do a sneaky
time warp here multiple times to be able
to win this game. And so that's why they
likely kept it even though it doesn't
feel that great. Uh I think the Eclipse
discard made a lot of sense because
Eclipse isn't going to be doing too much
in the early game. Uh however, now
against this Tasty Fay Folk, it might
not have felt that bad.
>> Yeah, Tasty Fay Folk is absolutely
fantastic here. You pay a price,
especially against an Aurora deck. You
take it out. Two runes get channeled
exhausted.
>> And we do see Aurora and might even be
two Auroras in the hand for this Master
Yi. So, it's going to be coming down
here nice and early.
>> Now, of course, we don't have access to
the sideboard information, but Kai'Sa, I
mean, are you assuming they would have
put some thermal beams into their deck
to try to deal with this?
>> Oh, yes, for sure. Uh well, you might
see a very different game on the second
game if with the gear hate that Kaiso
will probably add in if they don't main
deck it because we have seen a good
number of players main deck it, but I
don't believe this one is.
>> Yeah, falling falling star not going to
be the call here. Knox is hold full in
hand as well. Lots of options, but not
all of them are great.
>> I'll pay four.
>> And because we are tapped out on the Y
side, uh anything was going to be safe
instead. We had a tap four to play our
hopeful. That's I can't remember the
last time I saw this for four and not
for two. We're so used to seeing it for
two with the Legion.
>> Yeah, definitely not very common here.
>> It's kind of interesting. It's Is the
Master Y Aurora deck playing a little
faster than the Kai'Sa deck right now?
>> Yeah, that's I mean Kai'Sa did take the
first game pre-side, which we couldn't
we wouldn't quite expect. Um well, it it
is a tough matchup.
>> Oh no.
>> Yep.
>> As we expected, it's a very early
dowsing Aurora. Let's take a look at it.
Right off the top.
>> That is
>> That's heartbreaking.
>> That
>> right off the top here. It's the Elder
Dragon.
>> Already looking.
>> This is going to be a hill to climb.
>> This is what was supposed to happen in
game one. [laughter]
>> And now we see the
>> I don't see thermal.
>> There's another Aurora, too. Uh we just
heard that's what happened in game or
that's what should have happened in game
one. I'm guessing that the Aurora was
missed in game one, especially with the
game one usually be a bit favoring the
Aurora before the gear hate comes in.
>> So, we see no thermo. If we see the
second Aurora come down and no thermo,
it's going to be a really tough game for
Kai'Sa.
>> Recycle one for a watcher.
>> And there is the Watcher coming in.
>> I'll channel two and draw card.
>> I think we saw a smite as well very
quickly.
>> You do not. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Okay. And
because it is banished, we don't do the
channel in the draw. Really smart with
the smite. It is when a unit dies, it
doesn't have to be necessarily the
killing blow. It just needs to die
during that turn.
>> Very, very well played by Kaisen to try
to mitigate some of the damage here,
>> but still when you're staring down an
Aurora, this is sabotage. And it's
sabotage. That is a great card. Let's
take a look. Not as hopeful. It's time
warp. It's time warp.
>> And I can't quite make out. So now that
surprise factor of time warp isn't there
anymore. That was the biggest thing is
maybe we're able to steal the game with
a double time warp. That surprise is
gone. Now this hand information from
sabotage is so important for this
reason.
>> Yeah, falling star. You do have hex hex
ray which is not particularly useful
here.
>> Yes, it's just going to be an uphill
battle for this Kai'Sa player. And as
much as I love Kai'Sa, h Ye is looking
so good.
>> I think that was the vile at the top of
the hand there for Master Yi.
>> This is going to be a difficult hill to
climb.
I mean it it is the aspirin's climb, but
I think uh
>> I mean it looks like there's stairs too.
Not even just a regular climb. Just
going upstairs.
>> As I get older, the the stairs I tell
you they take the wind out of you
sometimes. But what does not take the
win out of me is this dowsing aurora
because at the end of the day it's going
to generate a ton of consistent value at
the end of every turn. This is going to
be crazy.
>> So what I'm really interested to see
here is if the Yi player decides to play
another Dazzling Aurora next turn or
not. Oh, nope. We will not just be
holding here.
>> I mean in in your opinion, right, you
play that second Dow Aurora and then you
get thermal beam. That just feels awful,
right? Like you're probably going to
want to not do that. You probably want
to just hold in hand be like, you know
what, I got I got a backup plan. All
right. Uh, can I see that?
>> And also, we're only at eight runes as
well, so we can't quite play it.
>> All right. This is a good note
takingaking here because you do have to
reveal your cards when you do the instep
of Dazzling Aurora and just being say,
hey, this not so fast is not an option
now. The unyielding spirit is a huge
one. It's a blowout card against Kai'Sa.
The Blade Fury as well. Like, there's a
lot of options uh that are just getting
taken off the table now. So Kai'Sa
taking some diligent notes. Really smart
play.
>> Yep.
>> And also what I like about this is
despite this game not going in Kai'Sa's
favor, this player hasn't given up. They
haven't said like, "Oh, you hit Aurora.
Okay, I guess you know, scoops next
game. Next game." They're still looking
at ways for them to figure out pieces of
the deck for the whether it be for the
next game or for this game. Gathering
knowledge is so important in these
games, especially with the closed deck
list. So I really like the mindset of
this Kaisa player.
>> No, I absolutely agree. in my listen
I've I've thrown games with better
advantages I got to tell you. So never
ever give up. Go to the end.
>> We're getting a point here. We go to
two.
>> Oh, and is there a way for us to get rid
of this elder dragon? Potentially
>> time warp.
>> And it's going to be a time warp.
>> Take another turn. It is.
>> Yep.
>> And I like the idea of this because we
are getting another point. Uh we're
playing around sabotage in the future
because we know that our opponent has uh
you know knows about our time warp. It's
not a secret anymore. So we might as
well play it, get the point, and then
try to do something else here.
>> And it does negate the dazzling Aurora.
Like you don't get an opportunity to
play that additional card. So
>> yep, straight to the next turn.
>> Got to find every small advantage you
can. It's not the ideal time to play
something like a time war, but clearly
there wasn't too many other options.
It's a it's a heavy price to pay.
>> Looking at potentially playing the
4Runner here, maybe we do have to get a
lot of might on the board and we want it
all at the same location because if
another Elder Dragon is flipped, then
we're in a lot of trouble. However,
there are several units in this deck.
So, the Elder Dragon is not a guarantee,
>> of course, and that's one of the
disadvantages to having this like
>> this kind of little bit of like extra
cheaper cards mixed in there cuz you're
not going to guarantee you're going to
hit something absolutely massive. You
might get another FA folk for instance.
Right there's a 4Runner as you
anticipated. We are readying up the
Elder Dragon. We're going to capture
that fourth point.
>> We'll see what this next turn looks
like.
>> Channel two.
>> Yeah. And I think this is the best move
that this Kaisa player could do is just
develop the board. Say, I hope you don't
hit it off of Aurora. And even then,
it's just a one of and they're not at
the battlefields either. We don't have
to worry about blades. So, there's a lot
of options here for the future if we're
able to potentially retake
>> one man out. So, I'll go here.
>> Yep.
>> Going for that additional point. Go to
five.
>> Now, the it's kind of under spoken, but
like the the draw from the Tasty Fay
folk is actually pretty valuable as
well. Generally speaking, you go after
the uh the accelerate the the runes
being added, but the draw is notable.
And there, it's exactly what you
mentioned. You're not necessarily going
to hit the elder dragon here. You are
going to get another tasty fave folk.
>> Some more notes here. I wish we could
see all the cards that we hit,
>> but it will give Kaisa just a little bit
more information here. That was
critical. Looks like Aurora, Mobilize,
Discipline, Blade, a couple of options
there for sure.
And that's the second uh uh blades of
flurry that we've seen. Flurry of
blades.
>> What you mentioned prior is is ringing
true here. You've established a bit of a
board. These this is like a decent
amount of might like you could perhaps
start staging a bit of a comeback here.
>> So that is a double falling star in
hand. It's very expensive to cast them.
But it looks like we are going to be
doing that to remove this elder dragon
or we can remove both fay folk.
>> So this is a really tough decision as
well because the fa folk is just very
efficient. But elder dragon has so much
value.
>> It looks like he targeted the elder
dragon and there it is
>> response. It's vile.
>> Sure.
>> Yep. File Mall is a fine response there
and it will make that battlefield a lot
more locked down now and with hold being
able to draw one potentially just having
access to more options here.
>> They're going to score additional points
here on the hold. The battlefield never
changed possession. And there's the
falling star again.
>> We are damping.
>> We really don't like fa apparently.
We've we've killed a number of them now.
One's been banished, one's been killed,
one's on the board. I wonder if he'll
die, too.
>> At one point, you called a few eggplant,
if I remember correctly.
>> Yes, it's eggplant.
>> Is that like and draw?
>> It's just It's like a pet name from the
community.
>> Oh, I see. Okay. You know what? It It
really does look like an eggplant. I
wasn't 100% sure if it was like some
eggplant that like
>> Maybe it is canon. I mean, look at his
arm. It It looks kind of eggplanty,
>> but yeah, I am unsure if it's canon or
not, but it is uh Oh,
why
>> watch? Sure, I'll make two mech tokens.
>> Oh,
>> it's just heartbreaking.
>> A hard cast, too. So, one time I've
heard someone say if you had a hard cast
Elder Dragon, you've lost the game.
Obviously, we've seen Elder Dragon hard
cast multiple games and has won multiple
games when hard cast. Well, yeah. You're
ramping like absolutely crazy. And you
have all this uh these runes. You got to
use them. Let's see what we pull here.
Give me something big.
>> And there it is.
>> Just in case you needed more dragons,
they have arrived.
>> They have arrived. And we really see the
power of this deck when it operates. And
uh we do see No, we're actually not
going to look at the discard this time.
We did see the third mobilize for
instance. Uh, but this one Kaiso kind of
knows the writing on the wall and has
seen a good amount of the deck already.
There wasn't anything too interesting in
those flips. So, I understand why Kaiso
is like, "Yeah, I don't really need to
take the notes now." Um, if there's a
way to win this game, it would it'd have
to be a bit of a miracle.
>> These two mechs, I hope they're brave.
They're staring down
>> a wall of
conquered seven.
>> And I'm not talking about the Tasty Fay
folk. I kind of hope Kaiser just kills
the tasty folk just to stay on brand.
Oh,
>> we got so excited for a second.
>> We're ready. We're ready.
>> Hates eggplant.
>> It just hates for about mastery ability.
>> I want to see it.
>> Uh, no. Yeah, you got it. Looks like
we're Yeah,
>> we could have killed it, I bet, though.
>> It's okay. But I mean, I think it's the
correct call because perhaps you want to
save time for for game three, right? You
don't want to go to I mean, they do have
30 minutes. This actually, let's be
honest, these are fast Aurora games
right now. At my locals, we're we're not
doing two uh dowsing Aurora games in 30
minutes.
>> Well, from those card flips, I could
tell they've done this a few times
before they know what they're doing.
Yeah, maybe all day. Maybe [snorts] they
are well practiced.
>> As we go to game three here,
>> interesting. And we see Sigil of the
Storm there, which is one that a lot of
Aurora players have decided that they
want to lead off with that battlefield
because it is a good neutral battlefield
because your opponent doesn't want to go
to it. They don't want to spend that
power, recycle those runes. But Kai'Sa
is probably saved the best for last. Is
going first with the arena's greatest.
Is going to speed up this game. Has
already passed the aspirin climb game,
which was one of the harder games. We
always knew that was going to be hard
unless he just completely whiffs. So
this game, I like it. If Kai'Sa is able
to find their two drop, I think that
they will be able to get on board and
they're able to navigate this to stay
away from the Elder Dragon flips, I
think they have a good shot at this.
>> Yeah, for sure. They got to start off
quick
>> cuz the last game as we talked about
like you keep Oh, there it is. Raven
Bloom student
>> trigger.
>> Perfect. That's a good start because
last time they started with, well, let's
just, you know, let's keep a time warp.
Oh, let's top deck a time warp as well.
>> And then obviously it was a a start that
was slow enough to really cost them. And
both players did remember the arena's
greatest as well. So another kudos to
them for sure.
>> Yes.
>> Go ahead.
>> Sand soldier coming into play. Desert's
Call. Second time we've seen Desert's
Call we played right off the top.
>> And we see it do some great things as
well.
>> Two two early point.
>> A good start for sure. And another Raven
Bloom. OKAY. OH.
>> OH, HERE WE GO. THAT'S THE START YOU'RE
looking for if you're Kai'Sa.
>> This is the dream start for Kai'Sa. If
there's a way to win this game, it is
double Raven Bloom into a Noxis hopeful
because you're able to just do so much.
Also, you're getting on the board early
here. Uh unlike last time we saw ye get
into the board earlier taking a trade
because we're tapped out, we aren't able
to buff up that Raven Bloom.
>> Go ahead.
>> Yeah, this is the ideal opening here.
Not only do you have the board, but you
have Arena's greatest and you're
threatening even more points. They did
get the catalyst of Aon. So, they're
starting to ramp, but do they have the
dowsing aurora?
>> That is the big question and it's long
been the big question. One thing that I
really dislike for Kaisa here is that
the sigil of the storm does not feel
good. Like, you want to score these
points, but you really don't want to
recycle these runes if possible.
>> I mean, if anybody can recycle runes,
maybe it's Kai'Sa. That legend ability
does mitigate some of the downside a
little bit, but at the same time, like
it it is a balance you have to take. But
I think you you go into these
battlefields, I think you want to take
them.
>> One.
>> Yeah. Has to be careful though here
because of
>> well, let's see. We have
>> potential dazzling aura next turn. And
if you hit Elder Dragon, it could be
game over. However, you have to decide
>> if I don't take these, I'm not going to
score enough points to be able to win
the game either. So, it feels like it's
almost a risk that you have to take.
Will we stack a battlefield here instead
just to kind of keep something uh extra
safe? We'll see. Yes, stacking the
battlefield makes so much sense here.
>> It does. And I I guess when you're
playing against Aurori, you almost you
just got to play to your outs. Like you
got to say, "Okay, listen. I got to
score points."
>> Like I'm not going to be able to trade
into this late game. And you could see
what happened last game.
>> Oh, look at that. Dazzling Aurora
>> comes down. Let's see. But again, you
mentioned it before. It might not be the
Elder Dragon. We might see a Tasty
Faithful come down. And that is not all
that threatening.
>> There's an amazing Cari had an amazing
start. Don't do it to me.
>> Already at four. What's it going to be?
>> It's the Tasty Faithful. It's the
[laughter] eggplant.
>> But here, look, he loves eggplants all
of a sudden. Now he's excited.
>> He doesn't even want to kill this one.
>> Yes, sure.
>> He still might kill it.
>> But he was way happier about this
eggplant than last time.
>> I also love how much fun these players
are having. You can tell they're just
happy to be here. They're happy to be,
you know, 6 for one. And they're
smiling, enjoying themselves, talking
with each other. This is what it's all
about. This is, and we've said it so
many times,
>> the game of Earthbound, it really,
really is one of the absolute best for
just
>> purely having an the absolute time of
your life. These regionals, the vibe in
here is absolutely electric. I'm not
just saying it. It is a sight to behold
what this regional does. And, you know,
at the end of the day is Oh, wait. Hold
on.
>> That was it. Turn to dust.
>> Turn to dust. Exactly. Turn of Dust is
such a key card in in mind right now
because you give a gear temporary and it
technically is still on the board. So,
we're going to go ahead and fix that.
But, it does have temporary on it. It
will uh disappear essentially at the
beginning phase.
>> All right. So, we do have some answers
here. So, yeah, turn to dust. I'm sure
thermal beams in there somewhere. So, we
do have some answers. Now, the question
is they had multiple dowsing aurora in
hand prior. I haven't quite had a chance
to peek yet.
>> I don't think they do this time.
I don't know, but I I don't I don't get
the read that they have the second
Aurora.
>> This one back.
>> Okay, Raven Bloom Student back.
>> Will we also go ahead and retreat both
of these back as well
>> because we're worried about a second
Dazzling Aurora. Uh a hard cast Elder
Dragon isn't on the table. So, that's
very important to note as well. I like
this retreat here.
>> Yep, this is a great retreat. You're at
six points.
>> Okay, four. They basically have to
>> Kaisa in base.
>> Bring and there's Kai'Sa in base as well
>> and pass you.
>> This is you get Aurora or you don't.
>> Yep.
>> Aurora does get destroyed. Turn to dust.
>> See what you can do.
>> And does find those orange runes as
well. If we didn't have those, if you
even if we had the Aurora, we wouldn't
have had enough for the power of it.
>> So interesting play from me here. We'll
have to see. Five cards in hand is what
we just heard.
>> Faith fo comes in.
>> Yep, that's good.
>> It's going to have to It's going to have
to just hold. It's going to have to try
to prevent
>> this game from going into further turns
or else it's just over.
>> I mean, Kai'Sa at six points is very
scary. We do know that they are running
multiple time warps, although we know
it's not in the hand currently. We do
see a Briner thunder song. We do see
smite. So, we do have some removal
options. And just being able to play
Brineer is actually huge here because
you're saying you cannot respond to me
anymore. You get, you know, that small
reaction window and once that window
passes, then they can't do anything else
including playing those ambush units if
you know they don't play it before that
reaction window. But I'm expecting that
Bernier. Yes, the Biner is a looking
really good right now.
>> 16.
>> You have to see.
>> Looks like uh
>> something there. We're in a very
difficult spot here for Master U.
>> So, we were just calculating the might
that's currently represented on board
and it is at 16. So, 16 there without
anything else going on. That's including
not playing a spell for Raven Bloom to
get it stronger. U just trying to decide
what we need to do to make sure that the
Kai'Sa doesn't double conquer which is a
tall order.
>> We've said it so many times. sitting at
six points going to
>> is such a threatening position
>> in riftbound especially when you have
that much and it's going to be a
sabotage. Take a look.
>> Well, you might be glad.
>> You might be glad thousand tailed
watcher
>> but seeing that
so we'll take that.
>> He's doing the commentary for us.
>> Yeah, watcher. Uh I will pass to you.
>> All right. This is it.
>> All right. So probably having a vile
mall is the expectation here. It has to
be vile. Uh that is absolutely the read
in every single scenario here is that
there's a vile mall ambush incoming
[laughter]
which I'm sure this Kaisa player knows
that as well. We'll be navigating around
that.
>> The crazy thing about that is you vom
ambush your top deck.
>> I will respond.
>> Oh, there's the there's a reaction just
to Yeah, that's what you have to do.
That's your moment.
>> You have to take that opportunity.
Um,
>> so now it becomes, do we have to look to
hold here? Instead, we're going to take
the conqueror Kaisa because we get the
additional draw. We do have to recycle a
rune unfortunately, but we're still fine
with that overall. There is no time warp
in hand. So, that isn't threatening
whatsoever and is saying we are going to
just hold here.
>> We'll hold a three and draw an extra
card from Val.
>> Yep.
>> So, we are holding to three. Ball gets
to draw. uh the Kaisa playing saying,
"Hey, this this mall is way too
threatening. I can't do anything against
it." So, we are going to try to see if
we can just hold the sigil of the storm
for the win.
>> It's a tense moment here.
>> Once again, 16 might is represented
there without any of the buffs. We do
have two runes open for the Kai'Sa
player, so we could potentially add
either do damage or add additional
>> might to this Raven Bloom student as
well. It's a lot of might to get through
for this Yi player.
>> 10.
>> You can't necessarily count out a Dow
Aurora player, though.
>> But I'm starting to count him out.
[laughter]
This looks like an impossible hill to
climb.
>> I mean, the biggest thing was we were
able to take care of that Aurora right
away and there wasn't a second one. And
we didn't, you know, get the flips that
we did get the Elder Dragon flip. We got
the eggplant flip instead. So, we'll
have to see what if there is any other
opportunity to do anything. We looks
like we do have
yards. Yeah,
>> it's just not going to be there.
>> I think there's another eggplant in
there. Yeah.
>> And there is looks like a dazzling
aurora that we cannot play because we
are only at eight runes.
>> Tasty back last turn. That just does it
as well. All right. Um, this might be uh
this might be GG's, I think.
>> Just making sure.
>> Yeah, we do have a charm in hand, but it
just doesn't do quite enough. Uh, one of
the weaknesses of these Z decks is that
they, you know, don't have a lot of
movement to them. So, it looks like just
making sure like when you have this much
time, you should just make sure that
you're not missing anything because this
game does have the complexity. It is.
>> There it is.
>> GG. Cari does take it in three games.
That third game was extremely cleanly
played. The perfect opener, rushed the
points, and ultimately came above
me.
>> So, I'm really excited to see a Kai'Sa
doing well again. That's something that
we hadn't seen for a bit, especially
since after [music] set one. And I I
like I said, I love Kai'Sa. So, I'm so
happy to see her doing well as a
champion. Once again,
>> Kai'SaO was such a mainstay in Origins
and then it kind of like did pretty good
in Spir uh Spirit Forge had had some
representation and then now lately it
seems like it's really been struggling
and I would suggest that part of that
has been Fury as a whole that's been
struggling but in this case what we saw
was the ability for them to establish
that early board, take those very
aggressive early points and then well
you draw the Aurora but then it gets
taken out. Yes, especially in that third
game, uh the navigation of the Kaiso
player of saying like, I'm not going to
put my units at different locations
until except for the time that they
absolutely had to and they were lucky
enough on the flip that it was an elder
dragon, but they noticed their line of I
need to get these points early. I need
to do it often and then I need to find a
way to just get those last two. And
that's what we saw very well played.
>> Yeah, I love the aggressiveness. And if
you're going to play against Aurora, you
want to be as aggressive as possible.
And I mean there was one point in time
during the second game we saw like what
there was like multiple uh Elder Dragons
on the field of play. Like how do you
even get above that you just you just
can't. And we saw them trying to use the
time warp to kind of make up the ground.
But at the end of the day it's like the
only plan is like you got to be fast.
You got to get to those points and you
just got to just keep keep chipping away
at the game plan of the Aurora player.
Just don't let them don't let them get
their Aurora out. If they do get rid of
it and just keep scoring points.
>> Yeah. Turn to dust being is I mean the
MVP of that last game. Without turn to
dust, the game is doesn't look the same.
Maybe if the elder dragon is just missed
over and over again, maybe Kai'Sa can
still find a way. But the instant
reaction of the turn to dust made all
the difference in that game.
>> And in your opinion, Master Yi, we have
different variations of Master Yi. Do
you think that the best way if you're
going for the best of Master, are you
playing Aurora or are you playing
mid-range?
>> Oh, that's a tricky one. If I'm doing it
personally, I'm playing Aurora because I
just I'm not really big into the whole
strategy of the mid-range G. However,
mid-range G has so many great matchups
as a whole. I think it's really good
into the field right now.
>> It definitely is. We are seeing lots of
Aurora and as a result, if you have the
option of playing mid-ranged, you might
dodge all that main deck gear heat that
we're seeing, right? And so, it might
actually give you an advantage in uh in
a lot of your especially your first game
matchups.
>> Yeah, that's definitely possible, I
would say. Yeah, I think that we're just
prepping for the interview going on to
the winner. But before we get to that, I
do want to mention something. I want to
mention that this has been a remarkable
experience. And if you have not yet had
a chance to come to regional, it's not
just about the competitive scene,
there's also sideboards as well. Uh, and
by sideboards, I meant the side events.
My experience at Vegas and the side
events was absolutely remarkable.
There's so much fun to be had. But
before we talk more about that, let's go
to the winners interview here from the
desk.
An excellent cast for an excellent
match. And I'm joined here with the
winner of that match, piloting Kai'Sa
Cesari. That was incredible. Mainly
because you guys went to game three and
also on top of the fact I feel like I
was dragged all the way back to an
Origins format. You know, I remember,
you know, Aurora Y being played back
then. This one not very highly
represented in the tournament compared
to mid-range Ye. But not only that, but
piloting Kai'Sa expertly, should I mind
that? You know, really navigating and
showing the people that Kai'Sa is still
here to compete. So, I got to ask you,
why Kai'Sa? Because Fury is kind of
pretty underrepresented and Kai'Sa had a
pretty poor performance in Sydney. Yeah.
So, that was actually part of why uh I
found that uh when I looked at
tournament results from previous
regionals, um like the last few uh both
Sydney and China, uh I found that Kai'Sa
was doing worse than I expected. I mean,
I don't think it's the best deck right
now. Uh the top meta decks are maybe
slightly unfavorable, but uh it felt
like it should be a top 64 deck at
least. And the fact that none of the
Kais made it into top 64 uh told me that
uh I could probably do that. Like I
thought I could do that as a a Kai'Sa
player since day one. Um so yeah, I
brought Kai'Sa to try and win the best
of. um super hyped to be going into uh
the eighth round at 70. But yeah,
>> it's got to feel amazing, right? And I
have no idea how close your competition
might be right now with the SkySa, but
based off of what I've seen from Sydney,
I could only imagine you are in the
front running right now, you know? Uh so
that's got to feel amazing. So obviously
you still got a lot of tournament to
play as you have already qualified for
day two and like you said you've got one
more round but the fact that you're 7
and0 I I can't imagine even if you end
today. Not that I'm going to say you're
going to end on a loss. I don't think
you will based off if you keep playing
like that but you know even if you do
even X and one's got to feel pretty good
even for a top 64 but you know in the
best of of course but do you think this
is maybe even something you could see in
top eight?
>> Uh yeah I think it depends on the
matchups. Like I've been seeing a lot of
Exo Diana right now and that's one of
the few meta decks that uh Kai'Sa does
really well into. Uh so if I face a
Diana in the last round, we'll see.
Maybe I can enter day two Ado. Uh if I
keep going Diana's all the way or I've
seen a lot of Pikes as well. Um those
are great matchups for Kaisa. Um there
the few ones that are bad are maybe
Master Yi uh and Aurelia and I think
Aurora is a little bit coin flippy
sometimes um but not too bad. Uh but
yeah, I think like if I get good
matchups, we'll see. Maybe it can make
eight uh top eight.
>> Well, you heard it here first. Heard it
here first, folks, because Kai'Sa might
just be the Diana killer and maybe we'll
see you take down some more Diana to
make a further run into day two
tomorrow. So, thank you so much.
Congratulations once again. Enjoy your
eighth round as you can obviously
celebrate even in some some capacity
right now. But we're going to go ahead
and send it back.
The competitive spirit is in full force
here in Vancouver. But as we were
discussing, if you're someone who's
relatively new to Riftbound, you're
watching the stream, you're getting
super hyped up, you can actually learn
how to play Riftbound at regionals and
participate in side events.
>> Oh, exactly. I've had so many friends
that just come here for the side events.
They are looking to get those tickets
and also just hanging out with their
friends. 2v2 is all the rage right now.
Players love the fun combinations that
they can do together and play with their
friends as well. One of my favorite
things is actually 3v3, which is
actually just one v one v one and then
you take the best of three. You get your
prize tickets and you go to the prize
wall. A lot of people may not realize
this if you're new. Basically, you get
these prize tickets. You go to a prize
wall and you get to redeem a lot of
rewards.
>> Exactly. And there's so many different
things. There's unique things that you
can't find anywhere else, such as
alternate runes that we have. And
there's also, of course, you can get
more packs if you want to go for that as
well. And of course, the plated legends
as well.
>> There is so much to do here at the
regionals. We hope to see you here. But
in the meantime, let's go to break as we
prepare for our next round.
Next, we're going to go over some
awesome gameplay moments from between
the Victor and the Annie. And I think
these are some of the moments that
really kind of decided that game,
especially in game number two. A lot of
these are going to be denials of where
they stopped the cards from being played
or from what their game plan was really
just shutting it down. You're going to
see here where this Wages of Pain is
going to be able to potentially kill
this traveling merchant, taking it off
the battlefield and winning the
showdown. But as we play the clip here,
you are going to actually be able to see
a Renguard get played with Ambush, which
is going to be able to continue the
match. And then Annie really has a
chance to take control or clear the
battlefield and continue the game. Next,
we're going to go to our next clip where
we can see a spell that we all remember
from set one, good old singularity. And
this is a really strong card. It is able
to deal six damage to two different
units. But the big drawback is just that
energy payment that you really have to
pay to be able to get this spell going.
So, as the clip plays, you're going to
see while we tried to do the singularity
to kill these two units on the
battlefield that Annie had, abandon is
going to come down here, which sends
singularity back to hand. And because of
how much that energy cost is, it kind of
just tells the Victor that he doesn't
have much of a turn this time and
because he will not be able to play
singularity. And those are two moments
of this game where those denials stopped
Victor from moving forward and Annie was
able to take the match. what are some
fantastic moments in the games we just
watched.
>> That was an excellent game that we got
to watch and match of course. Victor
versus Annie. One of my favorite things
to see even all the way back in Origins.
And I'm joined by the winner piloting
that Annie deck. Gonkra. How does it
feel going now 7 and0 more match to play
for the day? And you got paired into a
Victor who I hear you're kind of happy
to see that. Yeah, I'm really happy that
I faced a Victorian. Like when you're 6,
you're like I'm going to face a strong
players. So I want like good matchups
like this. That's part of the victory.
And when I see Victor, I'm just super
happy and I will like do great and on
stream. So like I was very stressed to
go on stream. But at the end I was like
I'm against Victor. It'll probably be
okay matchup. So it's reduced my stress
and it was fine. But yeah, amazing 70.
Like I haven't think about being 7 at
all to be honest. I was just like I
wanted to go like day two, see how it's
going. Um and try to get my my qualifi
for the regional. But yeah, it's going
well. Um I'm playing well. I think uh
the the the games like it's just two all
matches except one I think. So I'm
really happy about the plays. Like
that's something that matter to me like
being happy about myself how I played
even if I lose. Um but yeah, it's going
well.
>> You you better be happy because you're
not the only one out there playing
Annie. you are also having to fight
against of course we all know who he is
right prismaticism is piling Annie and
>> I think he's X and one right now so
you're currently in the race right now
as the winning Annie player at this
moment so that's that's got to feel
amazing and like you said you're very
happy with your play a lot of two so
I've heard so again you have one more to
play today and even if you don't win
that one you're going to day two no
matter what and you've been playing
Riftbound for quite a while I mean I've
seen your name in a lot of other outside
tournaments and everything you've come
all the way here from France your team
Paris based, right? So, I saw you in
Leo, of course, got to meet you there,
but you you're coming over here in
Vancouver and making an incredible
showing. And so, my last question I
really kind of want to ask you is what
decks are you trying to avoid? We talked
about Victor and that was a great
performance, but there's got to be
something you're maybe afraid of that
you feel like you have to 100% be on top
of your game to win. What is that?
>> I think LeBlanc is not so easy to beat.
Like, sometimes I like I just can't put
my ferus on the ball. I'm afraid of the
mirror image. And if he start like um
pushing the boards fast and he has the V
option like it's it's a hard match up
sometimes but I think it's still fine.
Like Annie has no bad matchup in my
opinion. The deck is just strong. The
worst match up I will say is Kazix
mid-range in my opinion but it's not
popular. I dodge them. So I'm happy with
that. But I don't think you have bad
matchup. You can win every matchup that
what matter are your plays most of all.
And yeah the other one maybe Aurora if
like they have everything. I dislike
that, but that's still a fine match up.
Like just a good match up for me still.
>> I will say that line that you said, I
don't think there's any bad matchups is
not the first time I've heard that
today. And it just kind of speaks, I
think, to the format right now and how
confident players like yourself feel
like they're coming into this tournament
and then doing well with it as you are
now 7 and0. Congratulations on your
victory on stream and a great interview
as well. I wish you luck. One more round
and then we'll see you in day two, of
course, but we're going to send it back.
>> We're here. I'm [music] Bar Bryant
joined with Ursy Day and we want to take
a moment here. We're at the conclusion
of round six now and we want to take a
moment and kind of analyze the decks
that we are basically guaranteed to see
tomorrow. And of course, some of these
are players that we got to even watch
earlier this, you know, during the
tournament. So, of course, they still
have two more rounds to play, [music]
but we are going to look at some of
these players. And some of these players
you already know. So, we're going to go
ahead and start off with Allen's EQ's
Diana list. And we've already kind of
like dove deep deep into this deck, but
there are other people on Diana
obviously and they're doing well in this
tournament. So, I kind of wanted to get
your opinions here Usi Day on why you
think this deck is succeeding so well
right now. Aside from the fact that
Allen's EQ just piloting it.
>> I will say obviously I do think a really
strong pilot is going to help any deck
succeed. And I mean going 6 and0 day one
is just a such a strong start. But I
really do love the deck that he decided
to build with Diana. And I know you
interviewed him earlier and there was a
mention that he's really like changed up
the list to more match the meta of the
second tournament versus it being new.
But I love seeing all the spells.
Obviously, they really work well with
Diana and her leader ability. Um, and I
just think they also work great with
some of these new battlefields like that
abandoned hall that we're seeing.
>> We know the success too of like things
like Starcrust, right? Okay, you'll pay
the hall of course being this great
card. It gets you that extra might over
when you need to get a little bit more
might. But Starcross being a big MVP.
We've already I mean we're going to talk
about it. We're spoiler. We're going to
talk about Dazzling Aurora later, right?
So, uh this card just being able to help
against that elder dragon, keep some of
your units alive is just really
important. As well as like you said,
we're seeing more success from things
like the stacked deck. Seeing more
consistency in these decks that have a
reason to use their energy in these
showdowns. And this card's just so
synergistic with Diana in general. But
we are going to have to talk about it
with our next deck. We've got [music] an
Ireelia deck here with Randy who we've
seen earlier today as well. And we've
are in this kind of discussion. This
deck is still opting for the two stack
decks, but it most Ireelia decks are
starting to shy away from them. And so
because those decks draw so many cards
from things like the Stellar
Cornhurters, we're going to see more
Ireelia and we're going to see it in
full force tomorrow as well.
>> Yeah, I mean obviously draw is always
going to be so strong. I feel like we've
been making that joke a lot that the
more you draw, the more you get to see,
the more information you have. And
that's just going to be so nice here
with that Ireelia. I mean, St. Court is
back. We're seeing her move. We're
seeing her draw. And I do think that
you're pointing out of that star cross
is just so nice. We've seen now I think
even last set we started seeing those
bounce cards. Uh, and I know even Randy
in set two was playing I think the card
is called the down is down under
>> down well. down is down well where it
could when it moved in the battlefield
bounced one of your units and the other
unit that he had.
>> Oh, that's beast below.
>> Yeah, you're right.
>> This is what I messed that every time by
the way. Even when I talk to Randy, I
say uh but yeah, the beast below kind of
very similar ability to that star cross.
[music] He really was able to use it
well last set and I think that's one of
the reasons starcross is so strong this
set. It's funny you bring it up actually
because Beast Below is still being
played in people's sideboards in Sydney
and so I think there's even a world
where some of these players are also
still sideboarding it. Of course, we're
not here to talk about sideboards, but
we are [music] still here to talk about
some more stuff we're going to see.
We've got even more 6 and0 decks of ones
that we've maybe highlighted, but also a
few that we haven't really seen just
quite yet. But I got to say another big
fan of a card here before we move on is
Scuttle Crab. I think Scuttle Crab is
coming in clutch and not just in this
deck specifically, but being able to
play this card, [music] replace itself,
draw a new one, and the death the death
nail is coming in so clutch. There was
literally a match earlier today where
the hand information was the most
important part of that game because of
the interactions that Riftbound has and
knowing when to use a defy or not. Can I
use this discipline safely or a defiant
dance such as this deck, knowing if your
opponent has the out is so important.
Yeah, I definitely agree. I mean, I
think we even saw that in the round six
uh match between Leon and Ireelia. That
scuttle crab getting to see hand,
getting to see the hidden cards as well
is just going to be so nice because
information is king in card games.
>> Absolutely. But we're going to move on
to our next deck cuz we got some more
people that we're going to highlight
that are currently 6 and0. That's right.
You know him, you love him. Sam D.
Sherman, another regional qualifier
champion right now. And we got to
witness this this Wrangler deck earlier
today. And no, it is not your infinite
dragons deck. This is a real honest
aggro tempmpo Rengar deck. And we talked
about it a little bit in one of our
other segments where math is so
important in the game. And a deck like
Rengar is so good at getting that one
more might over and when the response
speed is now being used because of
reactions with units. Ambush is here and
it sure is here to stay cuz it's so
powerful here. What do you think about
this deck?
>> It's absolutely insane. I got to watch
it a little bit earlier today. And I
think one thing to note is you cannot
really defy ambush, right? In the same
way that you can defy some of these
other cards. Obviously, sometimes you
want to I mean discipline is not in this
deck, but you sometimes you decide
discipline adding might in. But when
Rengar comes down, when Niti comes down,
you have to have a different option for
it. And maybe people aren't used to it
as much either. And honestly, this deck
was just so awesome to watch. It ran so
smoothly and it really felt like
he had found a really nice synergy with
Rengar here.
>> And I'm just glad to see the success of
the Fury domain. We we we've been
talking about it pretty much all weekend
that we think Fury is really kind of
taking a back seat, but Sandy Sherman
has locked in his day two now with this
Rengar deck. And you talked about not
being able to defide. Punch first is in
this deck still, right? Can't can't defy
that one. You can't knock yourself past
that one. That's picking my guy. I would
like to give five might to that unit.
So, I'm so excited cuz I love this deck.
I personally even have it built, but it
even still offers like removal, right?
Of course, you know, you have the
sabotages which you sometimes want to
defy those. So, it just seems to have a
really good match up because if you have
to hit those, you're not hitting things
like challenge. And of course, like you
said, the ambush units are really good.
But, we've got some more decks. Of
course, we want to move on to our next
one. And I think we're Yeah, that's
right. We're here to finally talk about
it. We have to talk about it. Dazzling
Aurora. Now, this is Swaggy YOLO 428 at
which is Ali Andrazi, who you may know
him cuz he won the best of Civer um at a
previous regional qualifier as well. And
lo and behold, here he is again playing
Dazzling Aurora Civer. And we have
already seen the success of this set on
stream quite a few times.
>> Yeah, for sure. He did such a great job
in Atlanta with this list. And I think
he's done a really great job in kind of
figuring out what to do in this third
set. And I think the list is just so
well built out and obviously he knows
how to play Civer so it's doing well.
[music]
But I think with how the uh how Civer's
list works, you really get to decrease
the number of units. We saw this in set
two as well. With those three outer
dragons, only one of the mind
spplitters, you're hitting that outer
dragon every single time.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And like you said, you
you don't really need all those units
because we're still playing things like
last rights that really help us bring
those units back into our deck. So even
if we have more turns to play, usually
by then maybe the game's kind of over,
but you know, the removal with the
flurry of blades of course, but last
rides being able to not only recycle on
use, but then if you get the hold
effect, you then get another unit back
already that you was probably going to
be there because there's only so much
removal that a lot of these decks have.
But, you know, we haven't been able to
put uh Ali on stream just quite yet, but
I got a feeling that if he keeps doing
this well, we're going to see him soon.
And I think we've got another one here
for more decks. Uh maybe I'm wrong. I
have no idea to be honest. Ah, yes, we
do. Oh, we've already seen Flex Duel.
Leblanc, you're a big Leblanc fan. So,
here we have the baited hook variant
once again showing that it's going to
make a Day2 appearance no matter [music]
what.
>> Yeah, I am the only caster who believes
LeBlanc will win the tournament. That's
my bet for the weekend. I'm going to say
it over and over. Hopefully, I'll win
the bet, but it is going to be that
baited hook version that we saw in
Sydney a couple weekends ago. Baited
hook just feels like it synergizes so
well with this list with LeBlanc in
general and really capitalizing off some
of these death nails. Obviously, early
game, you're not playing that baited
hook just yet, but later when you're not
fully sure if you're going to get to
kill something or not, baited hook gets
to choose when and how it kills. And I
want to highlight another one because of
the beta hook synergy, but it's not just
being seen in baited hook. We're seeing
it even in the dazzling Aurora decks
that are surprising me that are being
shared with the order domain harnessed
dragon. This just a really good card to
pull off the top with a baited hook of
course. And because of that six might
threshold, it's really good when you get
rid of this glass misologist, bring more
units onto the board, and then maybe
find one of these harness dragons off
the top. more removal, a body to go with
it, and of course, if we're already
winning the game, we can use things like
Leblanc's legend ability to create extra
copies, which means we just have more
units to play with, of course.
>> Yeah. And then your board just becomes
so wide by the time you get to late
game, it kind of feels like if you've
been able to develop, if you've been
able to get there and then take over the
battlefield before your opponent wins,
they can't really break the board that
you've set up.
>> Absolutely. Yeah. Leblanc is one of
those scary decks where I always think
about like the sort of analysis
paralysis. This deck is hard to play,
but people like Flex Doul, who we saw on
stream earlier today, 6 and0
>> means we're going to see it in day two
no matter what. And of course, there are
plenty other one of these as this is a
pretty high represented legend here in
this tournament. So, I'm excited to see
it. You might win your bet. Of course,
we already talked about Diana. There's a
plenty of those out there as well. And I
think we've got another one. Oh, that's
our last one. Perfect. Well, this has
been a sort of deep dive on all the
decks that we're going to be seeing in
day two here at the regional qualifier
in Vancouver. So, I'm really excited to
see what happens. I hope you are, too.
All right, we are back for our eighth
and final round today for the Riftbound
Regional Qualifier here in Vancouver,
but it's just half of the tournament in
general. We're trying to see who's going
to qualify for day two, and it's going
to be really exciting. I've been joined
by Ursa Day all day and we're on this
final one. How are you feeling?
>> Uh I am feeling great. I've had such a
fun day getting to cast with you and I
mean we just did look at some of those 6
and0's at the end of round six. I wonder
how they've been doing the last couple
of rounds. Really hope they're doing
well.
>> Yeah, and we also do have standings for
some 7 and0. So let's look at those
right now for Swiss standings. All these
players have guaranteed into day two.
Uh, and we do see LeBlanc at rank one.
Very happy for you.
>> I'm very happy to see it. We also see
Dewali at rank two here on Diana.
>> So, yeah, we're pretty close behind,
right?
>> Yeah, not too bad. Not too bad, but you
know what they say about second place.
>> Yeah, it's not as good as first, but
there's still a lot of rounds left to
go. We also see uh Civer at third. We've
got Aelia at four. So, four unique
legends across the top four. Obviously
all with the same rankings with some
minor uh you know pairing difference
there but uh you know still a lot of
different uh you know legends uh still
available for us.
>> Yeah, we even got to see some Kai'Sa
even Rengar heal here here 7 and0 Draven
Azir. It's crazy.
>> Yeah, and honestly we've got like a
pretty good selection. A lot of our
feature matches have continued to stay
undefeated which is cool to see. We see
Allen's EQ currently 70 with Diana. Uh
we also do see uh Draven that's 70, you
know, one of the bullies I think from
set two still viable right now and uh
really cool to see that. And to kind of
round out the top 30, so we do see some
601's and some 61s. Uh again, we see
Mastery Azir Aelia. We've got a Pike 61
Roosecow here. Uh really exciting to see
that.
>> Yeah, we were talking we thought that it
potentially could do really well today
and six and one does mean we are going
to see it tomorrow in day two.
>> Yeah. So some great standings. Uh,
obviously really excited to see so many
legends make it to day two already. And
uh, yeah, we got a Poppy too. No veggies
6-1. Great to see that. We've got Rexai.
I think we saw Satame earlier as well.
We've got uh, Prismaticism on Annie 61.
So obviously one of the favorites for
today, too.
>> And Le also still six and one. It's just
kind of crazy how many of these legends
are really able to do well.
>> Yeah. So we saw Terry earlier today,
too. Really happy that they're making to
the day two. Uh I would not expect
necessarily Leon getting the day two for
an event like this.
>> Yeah, it would not have been on my bingo
card uh for this weekend. That's for
sure.
>> Yeah. So uh we are going to go to our
eighth round. But before we do, we got
our feature match voting. We've got two
choices. We've got Pog Chungus with
Draven versus uh T1 win on Diana. So we
get that match. And for uh match B,
we've got Swag YOLO 420 Yah on Civer
against Zazetto on Leblanc.
>> Yeah. And this could be I mean both of
the matches look really fun. Obviously
Draven was a bit of a boogeyman last
set. We haven't seen him too much today.
Uh but versus Diana as well could be a
really fun game. Civer obviously has
done really well. Uh we looked at this
list just before we came here and it's
up against Leblanc as well which I do
want to see Leblanc today.
>> Yeah. So real quick, we didn't mention
it. Press A in chat if you want match A.
Press B in chat and match B. We'll look
at what the chat is saying and that will
be our first match. Obviously, if we
have time, we can kind of feature both,
but uh honestly, mostly uh kind of more
unique uh legends. We've seen some Diana
and some Leblanc, but not too much. And
obviously Civer I don't think we've uh
featured today. And definitely not the
Draven.
>> Yeah, that is for sure. I don't think I
definitely agree. Both of those could be
really new to stream today, which would
be a lot of fun. Uh I mean, is there one
that you would prefer to see today?
Well, I I know the answer now. So, it
looks like we are going to go to match
B. It's going to be Swag Yolo 420. Yeah.
On Civer versus Zazetto on Leblanc. So,
your champion, your legend for this
weekend. Let's see if it's able to go 80
going into day two.
>> This is going to be so exciting to see
how honestly I could be cheering for
either here. Uh Swag YOLO 420. Yeah,
running this really fun civerless.
Obviously is built around that dazzling
Aurora, but as we mentioned, only three
outer dragon and one mind spplitter to
really assure that you hit that outer
dragon with the Aurora.
>> Yeah, obviously one of the best cards
unleashed. Definitely worth building
your whole deck around and it can be
very tough to interact with. We got a
single mind spplitter as a backup copy
off the dazzling aurora. There's also
the unique interaction with treasure
trove with civer which is really cool
being able to use that uh to be able to
get the ramp and the cycle without
having to actually lose the rune which
is really nice. Uh we've got some unique
choices too. We've got the fading
memories and also the harrowing there
too. Uh not necessarily main deck
choices I see all the time. Uh maybe a
little bit more in the side deck but we
are deciding you know we are needing
this in the main now.
>> Yeah for sure. It's going to be really
interesting to see how some of this
plays into Leblanc. I think uh both of
these decks kind of can play as well
like towards the late game. So I'm
interested to see what they decide to
do. And those battlefields are also
built. As we mentioned earlier, it's a
late game deck. Aspirin's Climb, Sigil
of the Storm, Forgotten Monument. All of
these are built to bring us towards the
later game
>> for sure. So here's our Civer list here,
and we're going to go over to our
Leblanc list as well. One of our new
legends. And uh yeah, we are going to
see, you know, a good amount of variety.
And looks like it will be the baited
hook version of this deck,
>> which is my favorite if I'm being
completely honest here. You know, no
bias, but I do think it's my favorite.
Baited hook is just going to be so nice
in this list. There are so many death
nails that LeBlanc really likes to rely
on. And baited hook is going to let us
kind of use those death nails at free
will. But the main thing is is it also
helps us play units that don't really
cost us the energy and then we can use
our runes for other things from hand.
>> Yeah, another card to kind of note uh
we've got three copies of Vi in the main
here. I've been seeing, you know, three
cost the main and the side usually, but
three in the main is quite aggressive.
I've been seeing more and more people
kind of recognize this as a good card as
the weeks have gone by. So, uh
interesting to see again this. And since
it does have the five might, it's really
easy to go from five to six either into
the ruined directs are the harness
dragon which we've been seeing uh some
of the order uh uh Aurora decks be using
as well as a backup copy for removal.
>> Yeah, it's a great point. It also does
have that stun which honestly has been
played so much today. We were talking
about the Vex that stuns and now Vi kind
of does it too.
>> Yeah, for sure. So, this is the build
from Leblanc. We're going to go into our
eighth and final round once again. Civer
versus Leblanc and we'll have to see who
ends the day with that 80 record.
>> I cannot wait. This is going to be so
much fun to see. It is, as we said, Swag
YOLO420. Yav versus Ato here. And it
does look like we're going to be
starting with that Sigil of the Storm
versus Starring. Uh, Sigulous Storm, you
do have to pay one power to or no, you
have to recycle one rune to be able to
uh, you know, move a unit there or not
move, conquer when you
>> conquer. Yeah,
>> conquer uh, which
>> is important that key word of recycling
because you can make a lot of gold with
civer.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, Civer being able to kind
of play around it while also slowing
down your opponent is really good. And
we do have the star spring from Zazetto,
uh, which we've been seeing, you know,
offers a lot of help with movement. uh
you know doesn't necessarily work with
the tokens you make inherently, but uh
you are able to you know help move in a
deck that doesn't have a lot of movement
otherwise. So Zetto looks like putting
one card back on their mulligan. We're
good to start uh Swag Yolo 420. Yeah,
starting off with two runes and we do
have uh the ramp there. Yeah, we're just
trying to get as many runes as possible.
And Starring is going to be so nice here
as you mentioned, especially with these
reflection uh units that get made by
Leblanc. They are made ready, which
means that if we are able to trigger
Star Spring, they can come back to base
still ready and be moving into that
other battlefield. It does look like
we're going to be using a soaring scout
here, which is exactly the unit we want.
That death nail is that you get to uh
channel an exhausted ruin when it dies.
So we can really start ramping up as
well.
>> Yeah. So that really helps us to get
into late game uh you know a little bit
quicker. Obviously ramping is good for
both. I don't think we really touched on
either. Swag yellow 420. Yeah. Also
already has uh won one best of civer. So
trying to get another one today as well.
Starting 70 means you're already in
pretty good contention. And we do have
the catalyst of aons here. The double
ramp super strong. And uh we could be
seeing an Aurora as soon as next turn.
Yeah, I think Swag Yolo 420i is kind of
just hitting that curve that you exactly
want with Aurora. So fingers crossed for
him that he does have that Aurora for
these following turns.
>> Yeah. And uh we're looking at our five
rune turn for Zetto. Uh something that
I've noticed when I played this deck is
that sometimes uh it's hard to get both
the uh the runes that we need and uh the
cards at the same time. Usually I'm
like, well, I've got all these cards but
no runes to play it or I've got all
these runes but nothing to play with
them. So, it's it's been really tough to
find a balance, but we are going to get
the uh scout there. We are going to use
uh the ability from our uh legend here,
discarding one to make a token. Uh so
now the double death nail can offer us
another two runes next turn.
>> Yeah, that could be really nice. Here we
are going to see that uh reflection come
down obviously of that soaring scout.
>> So, we'll see. See if there's another
unit that we do play. I wonder if we'll
play it to Starring to try to trigger
that that battlefield ability or not.
>> Yeah. Yeah, cuz we can move the soaring
scout back if we want to. Uh it's kind
of funny, but like to you know to be
able to know that the temporary will
work on our death needles will be nest.
Looks like we are thinking about placing
a unit at the Starring. Uh and it's
actually going to be uh the sentry there
and we're going to move the illusion
back. So with that, we are able to get a
quick two points off the sil of the
storm. We are going to recycle one. uh
offer uh after conquering.
>> Yeah. And watch Sentry is another really
good early game that or early game unit
that you want in this deck because what
you're talking about, right? Like you
have this problem where if you either
get the runes or you get the draw and
these two early game units are I mean
that draw and that rune generation.
>> Yeah, really facilitates it. So, uh
thinking about where we're putting the
uh our last card of the turn. So, there
is a decision of like, well, I want to
make it difficult for Elder Dragon to,
you know, hit me as hard as it can. So,
we don't want to play anything at our
base, uh, since it's a third location
that can hit it. But, we got the Black
Rose Dignitary. So, another Death Neil
to channel a rune exhausted. So, even
though we're at four, we could start all
the way at like eight runes next turn, I
think. Maybe even more.
>> Yeah, that would be really nice. Let's
see if they have it. I mean, we are
going to go on and turn one rune. That
is going to put us down to eight.
>> Yeah. So, you know, sigh of relief from
that. All right. Okay. No, no dazzling
Aurora on curve. They did get the double
ramp, but it is really tough to find all
three pieces consistently. So, uh, stack
deck does offer some choices here. Uh,
but yeah, we did pass the the first
check, it seems.
>> Yeah, it's going to be really nice. We
are probably going to spend this turn
trying to find these draw cards though
to try to get to that Aurora as quickly
as possible. uh because there are so few
units in the deck, you don't want to be
drawing into the units. And obviously,
you still want to be able to play those
12 energy uh elder dragons through
Aurora, not by playing them through
hand.
>> Yeah. So, looks like we are going to
play our champion unit civer. Uh and we
can give it accelerate too. So, uh by
doing so, it will offer a chance to
contest one of these uh battlefields.
Mhm.
>> And uh since we did recycle two, it does
have the plus two might and ganking. So
it was six to four and allowing us to
get that uh battlefield there.
>> Yeah, that is also going to help us uh
channel one rune exhausted and draw a
card. Even though we do lose that point
or lose the battlefield and swag yolo is
able to get one point,
>> we are going to start getting more and
more resources.
>> Yeah, we've got the bloom there as well.
Uh so next turn we can help us find some
cards. We've got two runes open. Uh and
again we were able to, you know, since
we were able to kill some units, we were
able to reset our legend. So if we
recycle again, we can make another gold
which is quite handy.
>> Yeah, it's really really nice. Both of
these players, I think, are just trying
to get those resources and gold is going
to be so nice for that.
>> So one to two. Uh, so if you guys don't
know, also the temporary trigger uh lets
you kill your unit before you get the
points for it. So only two points off
that one, but you still get the rune.
And now we'll have to see, you know,
even if we don't have the bait hook,
this is enough runes to really start
getting some uh, you know, bigger bodies
on the board.
>> Oh yeah, that is for sure. And I'm
interested to see what they're able to
play here. Does look like we're going to
go on and bring Leblanc out of that
chosen champion spot though.
>> Yep. and we're playing that out. And for
five, we're are gonna play the glass
mixologist, too. So, a little bit of a
slower turn, but can really set up some
good value next turn.
>> Yeah, glass mixologist is so nice. When
it dies, you will get to play a unit
that I mean, it has a cost ceiling. Um,
but start playing units from your
discard pal as well.
>> Yeah. So, and I I like also bringing the
Leblanc out too because that does offer
the chance to uh play that out again.
one of the better cards for glassologist
to, you know, bring back. Uh, so we do
get the, uh, Skyers Bloom here. So, uh,
we do look at the top two, put both of
them at the bottom, and again, I think
we only have eight runes open here. So,
again,
>> yeah, no, no chance at Aurora this turn,
but we do have the Lunar Boom here, boon
here for a discard one, draw two.
>> And it looks like we did see the Aurora
just one card away, but uh, still good
for the next turn. Uh we can give give
uh the civer ganking if we do recycle
two runes this turn. So currently we do
not have it but looks like we are
thinking about just moving it back.
>> Yeah, I don't think it's a bad idea to
move civer back if only just to protect
it from being able to be killed by Zetto
next turn. Uh or at least from a
showdown at the battlefield. So it is
always nice. You got that point from
attacking the battlefield and one from
holding. So O
>> yeah. So only three cards in hand for uh
versus Zetto and two of them were baited
hooks. So
>> no
>> unfortunately can't get rid of both of
them. Uh but that also happens like
Leblanc kind of has like some you know
it's kind of as I was saying we have a
lot of runes which means that we don't
have a lot of cards in hand. It's a
weird balance between the both of them.
Uh there is a lot of potential for
drawing this turn especially with the
Leblanc uh on the board right now. But
uh you know this might be our uh our
baited hook turn. five.
>> Yeah, that would be interesting to see
that baited hook come down. We can start
seeing some extra uh units from baited
hook and also get some of these death
nails going. Um it might be nice for
Zetto for sure, especially knowing that
Aurora could just be next turn.
>> Yeah. Uh we've kind of like saved it off
enough and like you know uh Swag Yolo
420 Yeah. has done a really good job
drawing and cycling the last couple
turns. So, uh, you know, every turn that
comes closer, you're like, "All right,
surely next turn, they got to be playing
Aurora, right?"
>> 100%. I will say I thought the sabotage
into two baited hooks is kind of funny.
I feel like the few times that I will
sabotage on curve and my opponent
actually has Aurora when I do it, they
have two Auroras.
>> Yeah. And and that's why I feel like the
baited hook uh deck feels like it's a
bit of a weird call into this meta only
because there's so much gear hate,
right? But uh and you get like, you
know, blindsided by it as well. But uh
you know we are going to play the baited
hook and I think we're thinking about
using it on the glass mixologist. So uh
we did make the token here. It will
offer us a way to uh replay the anything
in our in our trash that's three or
less. So it can't be that Carus that we
just played. Um and since we have five
might, it lets us play out something
with six or less might off the top five
of our deck.
>> So yeah, it be really interesting seeing
what we're able to pull off. There's
obviously a couple different options
with this deck uh for six might. Um and
I'm really excited to see what we might
give him. It does look like we are going
to do just what you said. I did miss
what the units they pulled were, but it
looks like there might be a
>> I think there's a harness dragon here,
which would get the most immediate
value, right? Um I think there's a
ruined Rex as well, which could offer
four damage to the civer if it does get
hit by the death kneel. So, uh, but I
think harness dragon,
gut instinct, probably the best one.
Yeah. And, uh, Zetto agreeing trying to
get rid of the civer. No reaction from
our, uh, civer player. Putting the rest
on the bottom. And we still have the
glassologist ability. And it is going to
be able to play a Carus in the back.
>> And Carus is going to be so nice because
it is able to double death nills as
well. And just kind of get that double
effect here.
>> Yeah. So try to play Leblanc out uh onto
the uh onto the battlefield does get
gusted. We just play it back out again
and passing it back to Swag Yellow 420.
Yeah, but luckily uh you know it's it's
very important to be on even numbers
because of like the double conquer
effect. So uh Zetto on three kind of
buys you another turn and we finally
have Aurora. Uh couple turns late but
we'll see what we get. Uh, but man, if
we get rid of the glassologist, like the
Carthus lets you like it's kind of known
what you Oh, just elder dragon, right?
Okay. Easy peasy [laughter]
>> right there.
>> Mhm. It will kill uh
we'll still have to kill the
glassologist and then one of those cards
from the discard uh from the base as
well. I'm interested to see what exactly
they go for in the base.
>> I think it has to be Carus and Glass.
Yeah. And maybe only Carus.
>> Oh,
>> go ahead.
>> Yeah, and only Carus. Okay. So, deciding
not to get rid of the Glas there. And uh
>> trigger.
>> Yeah, cuz it's up to one enemy unit at
each one. So,
>> ah, makes a lot of sense then. Yeah, I
think it's a good idea to avoid killing
the glass, especially when Karthus is
you're having to kill Carth at the same
time. Um, so I like the decision for
sure.
>> Yeah. And it could be just like kind of
recognizing like man uh Zetto doesn't
have that many cards in hand. So even
getting back like a sentry that can
offer another card draw could be good.
So uh we're just going to I'm okay with
them having this five might unit here if
it kind of slows down their potential
for drawing more cards.
>> Yeah, that's a really good point. Um
yeah, especially because like you kind
of want it to die. I think like earlier
we kind of saw a point with that. We saw
Gus get played by Swag YOLO for 20.
And I think that's a card that you
really kind of want like early game to
be able to slow down these Leblanc decks
because by returning it to hand the
Death Note doesn't get played.
>> Uh and so you know like avoiding the
Death Note is the way to go.
>> All right. So uh Flare Blade deals one
damage to all units at battlefield. So
this could also be uh you know just
making sure you get full value from this
too. Uh, you know, if you would have
gotten rid of the glassologist last
turn, they would have been able to play
something at your ba at their base and
then they could have moved it up. So,
this really slows down to Zetto on this
next turn. So, it makes a lot of sense.
I like the play from Swagolo 420. Yeah.
>> Yeah. We'll have to see what they decide
to move up here to that sigil, the
storm.
>> We do still have one rune up
>> if that could be something.
>> Yeah, could be a gust. Uh, having Carus
back out is good. uh obviously being
able to use it to you know if the uh
Leblanc does get uh killed you do get a
two draw which you know I know is that
overly needs that card draw right now.
So
>> we'll see if we want to try to baited
hook for maybe something a little
substandard.
>> Yeah. And we also hopefully can get that
Leblanc ability as well since we are
conquering here.
>> But it does look like we're just going
to be playing glass mixologist.
>> I'd like to hook it.
>> Yeah. And on the baited hook here. So uh
we got a couple of things happening. Uh
we conquered.
>> I don't think so.
>> Oh, yeah. And and the sigil recycle.
Yeah.
>> Um
>> uh so yeah, look top five something with
cost or sorry uh of might six or less
off the top here.
>> Looks like you're going to play another
Carus.
>> Yeah. And so with that uh you know you
will be able to I believe get an
additional trigger off your glass
pixologist. So uh the sentry and the uh
no. Okay. It must it might not have seen
the death nail. so that it it can't get
the additional one.
>> That makes a lot of sense. Uh but we are
then going to be able to play two more
units here.
>> Starting to really like get a wide base
here for the Zetta, which is really what
you're wanting as Leblanc. You're just
kind of trying to build up your base
till some of these later turns. And it
does look like though we are going to be
bringing that elder dragon up against
that Leblanc. And that death nail is
going to happen and we have two cars to
multiply it.
>> Yeah, that is like you were doubling
your hand size, right? So [laughter]
once you get into the late game, you do
get all these uh interactions. Uh being
able to have these caruses, you know,
safe in the base is really helpful. Uh
so it's going to be difficult to, you
know, interact with this uh when they
get more and more of these death uh
triggers.
>> Yeah, I mean that's exactly what you're
wanting. We are going to have uh the
Dazzling Aurora finish off the turn
again. Another Elder Dragon. This is
what I exactly mean though. Like when
they're running so few of the units,
they have one mind spplitter, three
elder dragon, the odds you are going to
hit that elder dragon is just so high.
And so you're just really able to
control the odds.
>> Yeah, for sure. And uh you know, we're
at five points right now. Uh you know,
we could get to six moderately easy uh I
think with Zetto, but again like we
can't win this turn. We've seen it time
and time again. Uh being at five is so
tough uh when you're wanting to try to
go for game because you can only get two
points a turn.
>> Yeah, 100%. Uh and it's just like just
shy of where you want to be. 100%.
>> Uh so we'll have to see what they decide
to do. Obviously that bottom battlefield
Starring is open. You could take that
potentially move up to six and plan
something for the following turn
potentially. Uh or we could just wait,
which is something that I mean I don't
think Leblanc has a problem with
overall. Yeah. So, moving the sentry, uh
asking for a response from our civer
player here. Uh you know, if we do get
rid of it, uh we will be able to draw
two off the Carus uh which would be
nice. But yeah, we've got the lunar boon
there and uh we are able to get a
discard one draw two from uh our civer
player.
>> Yeah. And discarding that elder dragon,
I think, is so interesting. Obviously,
you don't want those cards in hand. uh
it decreases the chances, but also there
are some different uh gears especially
that we do play in Swag Yolo's list that
last rights that can recycle some of
these units from the trash and move them
back into the deck so that Dazzling
Aurora can hit them.
>> Yeah, and we also got the mindslitter
out of there too. So, we should know if
if I remember the deck list correctly, I
don't believe there's any units left in
Swag Yellow 420 Yaz deck. So if we do
have a ways to recycle them back into
the deck, we can, you know, get a
guaranteed Elder Dragon hit, too.
>> Yeah. Or if it's a turn that we do in
that mindslitter, you can just assure
it. So, well, does
>> Yeah, it looks like we're deciding to uh
use our uh legend ability here,
discarding the VI. Uh and then we're
just going to react uh looks like on
that to
>> uh on the sentry.
Yeah, still denying that Death Note
though because obviously you would
really get I mean two cards is going to
be really nice when we did have a bit of
a trouble with our hand size earlier.
>> Yeah. All right. For eight though it
looks like we are going to play out the
Rift Herald. Uh you know pretty nasty
card there. Uh so when you move to a
battlefield you are able to look top
three for a unit and then also it has a
death note to play a unit from your hand
to your base ignoring its energy cost
but you still have to pay its power
cost. but it can play any card from your
deck off of baited hook and plays
another from your hand. So, uh you're
really, you know, getting rid of one to
play two, which is super nice.
>> Yeah, that I mean it is just going to be
so strong. We've talked about how
Leblanc wants to get a lot of units kind
of in this space. Kind of the exact
opposite I guess of Swag Yolo's list
since he's only running those four
units, but just bringing more units out
for
>> a discounted price and then still being
able to play cards of hand is going to
be so nice. Yeah, and it looks like
we're desperately trying to dig for that
last rights. We need it to be able to
get another play off of our Aurora here.
And for four, looks like we're going to
play the catalyst of Aons. We're at the
full runes, I believe. So, just get a
draw one here.
>> And then for two, we are going to play
uh the mobilize again. Continue to draw.
We really just need to find
>> this answer here. And we do have the
last rights. Uh last rights has this
ability. Yeah. So when you equip it, you
can uh you have to recycle uh two cards.
So that could be very good for recycling
specifically uh an elder dragon and uh
you know something else that we need in
the deck, but guarantees that our Aurora
will find that Elder Dragon.
>> Yeah, that is going to be so nice with
Swagolo. I mean, being able to decide
the exact card so strong.
>> All right, so uh yeah, deciding on
potentially what the second card is
going to be. Yeah, so definitely outer
dragon. uh you know it's it's uh random,
right? Uh because you are recycling. Uh
but yeah, you will be able to uh yeah,
put that in the deck. You just need it
in the deck. You really don't care
>> where it's at. So
>> all right. Yeah, there that one's on
top. Randomizing it. Very good.
>> And then you're you're going to see
probably the rest of the deck on on this
one.
>> Yeah. I find it kind of funny actually
when it comes to Aurora, especially when
you're like going through the entire
deck.
>> Mhm.
>> Your opponent actually gets to like see
what's in your deck, which gives them so
much information. Obviously though, when
you're controlling the exact unit that's
coming out,
>> you know, you do have your own
information as well.
>> Yeah. And like at these levels, right,
not only you see what's in the the deck,
but you know what is likely in the hand
at this point, too.
>> Uh we are going to Yeah. just it's just
like yeah I I'm aware I'm aware that
yeah you're going to find the uh the
elder dragon. Let me look at the rest of
the cards from there.
>> I think that also means that we know
that the top deck what that's going to
be right.
>> Yeah. But we the flurry of blades.
>> Yes. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So that's that's
a known draw now from that.
>> Um Yeah. And that's why the
randomization makes a lot of difference
when you know that they have to go
through the rest of their deck.
>> Yeah. And I mean also like flurry of
blades is just like so strong in this
list. I feel like it synergizes really
well uh with Elder Dragon at times. Um
so
kind of like making sh like that
randomization just really matters.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So one rune open for Swag
Yolo 420. Yeah. We've got six points for
Zetto. So they could win this turn. Uh
but we've got some dragons we got to go
over to try to get there. We've got
Baited Hook and the Rift Herald. uh
three different dragons saying if you
take one damage you get uh you know you
get killed too. So um you know a lot of
decision-m for uh Zetto and we'll have
to see if they can uh beat up these
dragons.
>> Yeah and I do think the you know the
pieces for it are in the Leblanc deck.
Obviously if we can find Ruined Rex he
is able to deal out damage. The harness
dragon that you mentioned can just kill
units as well. So,
there are options to be able to kill
these elder dragons.
>> Yeah. And looks like it's going to start
off with a harness dragon here. Uh use
this effect to uh looks like kill off
the uh yeah, the elder dragon here. Very
nice.
Yeah, I think picking star tipped uh
star spring is really nice as well just
because we are hopefully going to be
able to get the maybe even like move
some of these units back uh either to
protect it uh or some of these other
options.
>> Mhm. Uh we're going to use the Rift
Herald effect. So look at the top three
>> draw a unit off it. Go to seven points.
We have a decision for our Leblanc uh
legend ability too.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I mean and definitely Rift
Herald's not a bad one to be able to
copy here.
>> Yeah. And yeah, discard the unit that we
just drew here.
>> Yep.
>> Make a copy.
>> All right. Making the copy of the Rift
Herald.
>> It's only if it moves to a battlefield,
I believe. So, we can't just move it
back and get a draw. But seven might on
the uh the field there. And then for the
last one, we're going to use the baited
hook. Uh likely on one of these Rift
Heralds, I would imagine.
>> Yeah, that's my guess as well
>> that it might be on one of these Rift
Herald just to play something from hand
here.
>> Yeah, and we still get the top five
search. Um we've used two harness
dragons, but if we have the third, that
could potentially win us the game here.
So, uh, if there's one in hand or one
off the top five, that could get rid of
that second dragon and we could push for
game.
>> Yeah, that would be huge.
>> I mean, it also with only one rune up
doesn't seem bad if we're able to do it.
>> Yeah. Uh, well, I think Flurry could
answer it or I think a third copy of
Gust. I think we've played two already,
but looks like we're going to get rid of
the real copy of our riffield there.
>> Ooh. And let's see what's on the top
five. I don't immediately see a harness
dragon.
>> Yeah,
>> but we are able to uh play another Rift
Herald. And then since we played a unit
there, we can use the Star Spring to
move the token back and it is still
active.
>> Yeah, I mean now we are going to have
that means two ready units here in base
as well.
>> Yeah,
>> going to be this.
>> Okay. And it's the thousand tail
watcher. We don't have enough to
accelerate it,
>> but it does mean that uh the Elder
Dragon will be minus three. Uh bringing
it down to I believe nine with the last
rights.
>> Yeah. And with this, I believe we're 10
to 9, but we do have the flurry of
blades here. And that is going to be
pretty tough. So, uh we do get uh both
of these Rift Herald effects though. Uh
so we could play two more units here.
>> Yeah, we we do get the plus three uh
sorry the top three from moving first
but then off the uh death kneels.
>> These died these died first. Don't those
happen first before you draw you like
you you moved here. Put this go on the
stack. I flurried.
>> I think they just
>> so they die. So you put stuff on the
play first.
>> Looks like [clears throat] there's a
discussion here on the sequencing for
it.
>> Okay. I don't know this.
>> Yeah, makes a lot of sense. There's a
lot of moving pieces here with the
Leblanc list with the Rift Herald here
for the
Exactly.
>> I mean, I was really hopeful there for a
moment. It felt really good for Leblanc
moving up there. Obviously, the flurry
of blades kind of setting it back for a
moment. Uh, but still, Swagillo is only
at five points here. Would be holding to
six. And so, we have at least one more
turn to try to push in
>> and everything.
>> Yeah. So, uh, looks looks like we're
Yeah. discussing on on the resolution on
this, too, especially with like some of
these reaction speeds and movement. uh
triggers, right? That is pretty big
here. So, it does offer like what
happens when we, you know, look at uh
you know, when the timing for looking at
the cards and also for the uh the death
nail effects, too. So,
>> yeah, this is
>> Yeah, looks like we're going to take a
call for that. But this is, you know,
really integral, right? Uh with Swag
Yolo 420 at five points right now. Next
turn, they can cap out at seven, but
they can't win next turn. Obviously,
Zetto is currently at 72. So, uh looks
like
>> these don't go.
>> Why? because okay
>> and they're yeah still still having a
discussion on
>> on this one
>> right now it does look we do have I mean
the two elder dragons I'm trying to
think like what unit would be best for
swag to do next turn just like as we're
like continuing on here potentially I
wonder if we might see like the mind
splitter buff back if we're just going
to continue to loop these elder dragons
>> so is it like missed
>> yeah and I I think there is a discussion
here about uh specifically what what was
on the stack first and so if you resolve
the top three that means that you've
decided to pass the death. I think
that's the discussion for it. So uh you
know obviously the judges are going to
be there. They're going to have a
discussion on it but that's that's
pretty big too depending on if you're
able to get the the units on the board
here. So that's kind of the discussion
here. Uh, but you know, it's it's been
so close, such a grindy game to uh, you
know, with with these elder dragons
being able to get them on forward uh,
with with cards having different ways to
interact, right? The the timing become
really really specific.
>> Yeah, it's something that I think is
like so much fun obviously as well with
his riftbound, all these different
windows where you can react or do these
different things, but it does make it a
little bit complicated when we're having
big turns like this. For sure.
>> Yeah. I mean when you have uh you know
additional copies of cards right when
there are move triggers with death
kneels right uh completely understand
like yeah why the sequencing makes a lot
of difference here uh for for this one
so uh judge call on that one but yeah
we're we're closing out this one pretty
close you know or I think we're going to
find a winner in the next turn or two uh
with five points to seven as well super
duper close and uh yeah and we we you
know approaching game two curious to see
what the uh the Battlefield choice will
be moving on the second
Yeah, it'll be interesting to see. I
>> thought there was I think I know the uh
both players I think had aspirin climb
if I remember. Uh so I wonder if like
one of them
>> if maybe we'll see a game with 10
points. That could be cool in some
world. Uh but
>> a whole to six.
>> I wonder what they will decide to do in
like these following games with those
battlefields just because they kind of
do have the similar game plan just in
the idea that like they both do want
that later game.
>> Um so it'll be interesting for sure.
>> Yeah. And so my understanding for it is
that uh we reacted to the movement
trigger. So the movement trigger went in
the stack first and then uh we used the
blade of flurries which would activate
the death kneels. Uh but since you
activated the top three effect first, it
means and that resolves last on the
stack, it means that you just chose zero
for the abilities of your Rift Herald.
So that's my understanding. We're just
going to have that moving forward. And
we do have the mind spplitter off the
hold of the last rights there uh from
the Elder Dragon. So uh you know, being
able to play that out, deciding where
we're playing it, and then with that,
we're able to see cards in hand for
Zetto. So looks like two copies of
Ruined Rex and the sacrifice. Uh, and
yeah, get rid of the sacrifice there.
Going to make it a little bit tough to
try to get that seventh point for Zetto.
>> Yeah, that really does hurt. I think
sacrifice is another one of those cards
uh that is just really able to help you
choose when to have those death nails.
Uh, it also does as a additional cost.
You can kill one of your units. Um,
which can be really nice, but as such
does make it a target for that
mindsitter.
top. Bottom.
>> All right. Using the boon there. There
it is.
>> Playing another one.
>> Yeah. I mean, these wounds are so nice
just to be able to I mean see those
cards at top of your deck drawing the
cards uh that you want to see as well.
>> Um
>> yeah, I mean we saw a Poppy Aurora deck
earlier too and like the consistency
that Chaos gets you is so large. So that
can be helpful. There is a decision on
if we want to be able to uh like move
the Elder Dragon. Yeah. And we're going
to pass uh we're going to say yeah,
there's no units left in deck here.
>> We do get to shuffle them as well. Get a
knowledge of what is there.
>> Yeah, it's a great point. And I mean,
there are a good number of cards still
left in this deck. Uh I mean, we'll have
to
>> I wonder if there's like I mean, I guess
all the units are kind of seeming to be
enough right now depending on what Zetto
has. We did get to see his hand, but
we obviously want to have this board
wider than it is right now.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And uh you know, we're
currently at six points for Swag YOLO
420. Yeah. Uh and we do have seven
points for Cetto. So moving the harness
dragon there.
>> Sure.
>> Being able to get an additional draw.
>> Yes.
>> Off of that. And then we are going to
use the effect for uh once again the
Leblanc. And since again moving we can
move the token back uh after if we play
another unit and then that's active ends
up being again very valuable as we've
seen.
>> Yep. And so we do have another
reflection unit this time. It is going
to be that harness dragon I believe that
we uh reflected. Uh so
>> yeah and
yeah looks like yeah we are going to
>> use that on the harness dragon here.
>> This targets correct?
>> Yep.
>> Okay. Um I could I could spawn the
target or is it just sacrif
>> Yeah. Looks like there's decision on if
he can react here on this play. Just
confirming on it.
>> It is target.
>> Okay.
I mean, if we are able to use that hook
and obviously kill the dragon, then
obviously I think you could bring out a
pretty big unit with that.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah,
>> you have three cards for
>> Yeah. And deciding. Yeah, it looks like
uh trying to react to it
>> as well. Uh you know, there's there's
been sacrifice where killing unit is a
cost. I'm not 100%
>> confirm if you know the bait hook is a
the cost for playing it is killing the
unit which I think is part of the
discussion for if there is a way to
interact with with trying to baited hook
this harness dragon
>> it references the friendly unit
>> I have to see I mean it looks like we
are
>> it'll be interesting to see what they
say here
>> destroy if this were to go away
>> for example
>> when he chooses when he targets this it
doesn't doesn't get the effect correct
Leblanc is definitely such a like
complicated deck deck. I feel like
there's so many different things that we
are trying to do here between those
death nails, between different unit
abilities, between the baited hook
trying and obviously sacrifice. So it'll
be interesting uh what we do here. But
obviously with that there are a lot of
questions with where can you react to
things and where are the different
windows.
>> Yeah. And uh yeah, trying to use the
flurry of blades here to react to the
baited hook. And yeah, that's why we're
so you know important like do uh how how
does the sequencing work for it? Because
if we are not able to kill the unit, are
we able to play something right?
Obviously the unit you get to play
depends on the might of the unit you
kill with mated hook. So uh this is you
know really really important for the
timing here.
>> Yeah. And looks like
>> no response potentially. Uh there could
be I think there's the VI in there. So
we could react by playing the VI
theregger
>> and that will activate the effect to
move
>> the harness dragon back. So that would
activate the harness dragon off of it.
So obviously there's a choice on if we
wanted to play out the
>> what what we move back and stuff.
>> The correct judge.
>> Yeah, it's not. Yeah, cuz the baited
hook doesn't care about I believe where
the location is cuz there are some
location based effects, right?
>> Yeah, for sure. And in case that would
matter, but I don't think this one is
one of those. So, we are going to be
able to continue that baited hook. Uh we
are looking at that top five the deck
and finding one of those cards to be
able to be played here. Uh there's a
couple options. It does look like
harness dragon is what's going to be
decided. Uh which definitely not a bad
option for the situation we're in.
>> Yeah, super strong. Uh likely getting
rid of their Elder Dragon in the front
there.
>> This dies
power.
>> Yeah, we're getting rid of Elder Dragon.
It does leave that mine spplitter up at
that sigil of the storm. Uh [snorts]
which I mean is the same might
technically as the thousand toad watcher
which is ready in base.
>> Yeah. And I also think there could have
been a decision on uh leaving the Elder
Dragon around. Uh currently we're 7 to
7. So yeah, that is a trade there. Uh
but with the Elder Dragon at the
northern battlefield at the sigil, it's
really hard for them to move. It also
means that we can use uh you know, last
rights this turn, we can you know uh
attach it. We can equip it. We can then
play out the mines spplitter when we
conquer again. So uh you know this is
kind of a a weird spot to be in, but
>> we are going to again uh use these
abilities. And you know, something else
that I've been noticing from Swag Yellow
420, yeah, is that we've done a really
good job at um, you know, using uh, when
we're at full runes, we've been
recycling one preemptively just so we
can get that extra gold gear token.
>> Yeah. And that is just so nice to want
to make sure that we have our maximum
resources possible and break a lot of
that.
>> Yeah. So, uh, we are going to play out
the civer though and that will be enough
that we'll be able to get accelerate and
that will get us that northern
battlefield and Swago. Yeah. takes game
number one.
>> That was such an interesting game
watching these two decks interact.
Obviously, uh I think like the main
difference here obviously is Leblanc
does have some early cards that it can
play between those soaring sentries uh
and the soaring scout and the watchful
sentry. Uh but both of them still are
shooting for that late game big uh those
big units as well. And going into game
two, it looks like we are going to be
doing forgotten monument. Uh and I
missed the second one.
>> Uh it is the windswept pillock. So uh
for like this is usually like the
Leblanc uh battlefield that you want. Uh
you know, of the three, this is almost
the guarantee. Uh but with the forgotten
monument as we saw earlier, uh that can
actually stop you from scoring the extra
point that you kind of want. So it's
it's the Zetto's second turn here. Uh
and we know we can move it to the
hillock here. We'll see if there's a
gust. Uh there is instead a lunar boon
getting a discard one draw two.
>> Be really nice to really I mean draw the
cards that hopefully will lead us to
that Aurora which is exactly what
Swagolo 420 Yi is trying to do trying
that Aurora. Obviously it took a couple
extra turns last game but it still led
us to the win. This time he wants it on
curve.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, uh yeah, we do uh have
the potential for again uh using it here
for the uh champion ability and or
sorry, sorry, the legend ability here.
Discarding a card to make another
soaring scout. Looks like the sentry.
>> Yep. And we are going to get that
reflection scout here.
>> And looks like we're thinking about
Okay. Oh, we're playing out our Leblanc
here. And sorry, I I did miss it when we
switched. Is this this is the uh the
other champion unit if I'm looking at
this correctly.
>> Yeah, it does look like this is the
other one. Um really interesting. I feel
like when you not too many decks run the
>> both of their champions.
>> Yeah. So, Leblanc everywhere once I'm
going to assume in the sideboard, but it
has backline, so you have to get damage
last, but also your temporary effects at
my battlefields don't trigger. So, uh
this soaring scouts going to be able to
soar another turn here and uh finally
take advantage of the the hill off
ganking. So, uh we will be at
>> five here.
That is I mean such an interesting
ability for Leblanc because I feel like
a lot of times you are kind of just
wanting right that temporary trigger to
go off. You get your the death nil
ability but
>> obviously we're not prioritizing that
here this time.
>> Yeah. So uh we were able to make another
uh reflection token off of the hold here
and again giving like reflecting that
Leblanc so it makes its own uh if I
remember correctly. Yeah, it it's it's
all temporary at its uh battlefield, but
we do move the scout over. We are able
to get another point uh which is nice.
And uh yeah, we're getting a lot of
early momentum for Zetto.
>> I will.
>> Um
>> yeah, I think Zetto is doing a much
better job this time getting some of
these early units out. Uh it looks like
we are also actually playing Ash as
well. going to be really
>> uh I mean nice to see. Ash is a really
interesting one. When you play me, you
get to choose your opponent and
obviously then they reveal your hand uh
reveal their hand. That is so much
information that you get. Uh and you
also do get to choose one of those cards
and banish it.
>> Yeah. And like when you uh you know, I
don't know, there's not a lot of holding
for Aurora and usually you need Aurora
to start holding, right? So that could
be a potential for it. But when there's
double Aurora in hand uh you know I
think the Flurry of Blades is a a good
card. I think that offered uh you know
Swag Yellow 420 uh a foothold to be able
to get into this game. Uh so we are
going to play out the pack of wonders
for two and then looks like we're paying
another two for the treasure trove.
We're going to use the ability to uh get
the uh ramp one. We get a channel rune
get to draw. We're going to play it out
a second time as well. And you know uh
we know that Aurora is coming.
Yeah, we are getting a little bit of
that like almost like draw package
running as well that Civer does like to
rely on between the treasure trove and
that pack of wonders. Uh, but I also do
love seeing sometimes with things the
pack of wonders where sometimes they'll
return the mind spplitter to hand and
then get to replay spplitter. So, we'll
have to see what all they decide to do
here. But, I do expect us to be drawing
very soon even though we already have
Aurora.
>> Yeah. And again, so I I I just want to
double check cuz I'm making sure cuz
sometimes it says others. Uh yeah, this
four drop uh Leblanc champion does
protect itself and its own temporary
trigger off the uh the token there. So
uh that's super nice to keep that around
uh and you know have some permanence.
>> Yeah, that is going to be really nice.
Uh,
>> let's see. Especially as we're trying to
build up how many units we have and
soaring scout is going to be able to
take advantage of that windswept hillock
ability giving it ganking to move over
to that forgotten monument.
>> Yeah. So after the hold in the conquer
there at five points versus zero for
Swag Yellow 420. So you know over
halfway there. Uh but we know yeah
what's coming. It's going to be the
Aurora likely from Swag YOLO.
Yeah, I'm definitely expected this turn
seeing that we saw it in hand earlier.
Uh, and I mean it is really nice to
already be at five points, but I can
only think that that forgotten monument
was really nice at stopping some of
those early points that may have put us
at six points here, which is, as we've
talked about so much today, a really
important breaker.
>> Yeah, if if Zetto was at five or six
points instead of five right now,
>> you know, you'd feel a lot less safe.
So, you know, it did buy another turn,
and that's what these battlefields uh
for Aurora decks are really trying to
do. So, off the top, we've got the
Mindsplitter
>> and thinking about uh any reaction,
we've got a Rift Herald, a salvage, and
a Hidden Blade. Three very good cards.
>> Yeah, I mean, a lot to think about, but
definitely I do think it is going to be
that salvage as we see just making sure
that that Aurora is safe.
>> Yeah, we we really uh you know,
prioritize that there. Uh but yeah,
Hidden Blade, don't love seeing it. Uh
the Rift Herald, too, going to be a lot
of value moving forward. We haven't seen
a baited hook yet versus Zetto, but
might not need it. We're at seven points
right now, and uh we'll have to see what
their next move is.
>> Yeah, I mean, I almost wonder if you do
want to try to hold here. Obviously,
right now we are at both of the
battlefields and the base, meaning that
since the since, as we know, the only
units in the deck for the most part are
going to be those Elder Dragons, they
can really take full effect right now
with how this is set up. So maybe we
don't want to do that. But at the same
time, we're at seven points. We're so
close to winning the game.
>> I have to wonder what Zetto is thinking
about and what he's going to prioritize
here.
>> Yeah. So, I mean, we've we've put a lot
of effort into this hillock here. Uh,
we've got, you know, eight might
currently. We've also got uh, you know,
a hidden card right now. Uh, we decided
to pass up the chance to put another
Leblanc uh, you know, token there, too,
to make it 12 might, which is such a
lot. And it's not impossible to try to
hold to our eighth point on this next
one.
>> Mhm.
Let's see if they can do it.
>> Yeah, we're going to play out the rune
Rex here. We didn't really see it uh do
anything in the previous game, but uh
we're going to have it back in the base.
Uh we could potentially, you know, put a
lot onto our Hilllock here, but instead
of trying to hold for win, we've decided
we're going to try to uh you know, get a
double conquer, it seems, next turn.
>> Yeah, for sure. Sure. I'm interested to
see what that hidden card is going to
be. Uh especially if we do hit outer
dragon or something like that.
>> Uh if it can stop it because it does
look like we are trying to minimize what
an outer dragon would do if it gets
played by bringing all these units back
to base.
>> Yeah. So for one looks like uh we're
going to
>> in response I'm going to
>> play out the uh flare of blades.
>> Yeah. Which which is curious because
uh yeah because there's no Elder Dragon
out, right? This doesn't this doesn't do
anything. Yeah. Yeah. So instead of
using the hidden blade, you're like,
"Oh, okay. Yeah, sure. I'm down to 3 HP.
What's next?"
>> Let's see. Yeah. Just kind of curious.
And obviously,
it looks like we're potentially deciding
if we want to move this mine spplitter
up into the forgotten monument. Does
look like that's what we are going to
decide to do. It is going to be our
first point for Swag YOLO 420. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, we do get it there. I mean,
this could be potentially to try to uh
you know, we might need more cards in
our uh in our uh what our trash to
recycle. So, that could have been the
the reason to put the flurry of blades
there to recycle it back into the deck.
>> But yeah, we are going to put out the uh
yeah, the last right. So, we are going
to No, instead going to have the fler
blades stay in the trash here.
>> Okay, looks like we will be Oh, yep.
There's one Elder Dragon. We obviously
do have a second Dazzling Aurora as
well, so we will see a second one get
played, but it looks like we're going to
play that outer dragon up into that
forgotten monument.
>> Yep. So, looks like we are going to be
targeting the ruined Rex,
>> so it can do four damage somewhere.
>> Uh, this This dice too.
>> You didn't target it.
>> I didn't target. No, it has one damage
on it.
>> Yeah, it looks like the flurry of
blades.
>> Okay, so that's that's the reason for
for the preemptively
>> for
I'm pretty sure. Yes, judge
>> and asking asking for the resolution
because they preemptively used the
flurry of blades trying to
>> again play around with the reaction
windows for this
>> flurry which gave us one damage. This
came into play. Yeah, so many different
reaction windows when it comes to that
Elder Dragon as well as Leblanc. I think
that's something that, you know, a lot
of players are dealing with this uh this
set trying to figure out like that
window of the dragon, the different
temporaries, things like that.
>> Yeah. And and again, I would say, you
know, wholeheartedly this was not an
interaction that I immediately would
know uh for that either. So, uh yeah,
because it just needs to take one damage
and it took damage previously as the
turn, you know, Elder Dragon does get to
to see that. So,
I was just like
>> no not able to use a hidden blade on
your own token there. So
>> that good man
>> looks like we're just getting a
confirmation for that.
>> I really should
>> as well. It looks like for for that cuz
again this is a you know a pretty
important Yeah, two cards is is a lot.
>> Yeah, that is for sure. And it would be
really nice to be able to grow our hand
a bit as well, but not it doesn't look
like that's what we were able to do.
>> Yeah, for sure. So we'll we'll see what
the the resolution on that is as well. I
think we still also have another
Dazzling Aurora uh activation to to go
through, right? Which at this point, I
think unless unless there's two Elder
Dragons in the hand of three, right? Uh
we will be able to uh get that uh you
know, a second Elder Dragon. And so
having, you know, potentially three on
the same battlefield will be really
tough to handle when again we're
probably getting rid of either the
Leblanc or the Ash. And uh you know,
that that's not a lot of might against,
you know, quite a big battlefield here.
Yeah, I definitely agree. And we're
going to have to see how you come back
from that. We were just starting to
build up that base. We were so close to
eight points and now it suddenly feels
like we may very well only have a couple
units at the beginning of next turn.
>> Mhm.
>> You have an out.
>> I have
I have
>> Yeah. So, we're we're seeing Yeah.
making confirming on the the resolution
on that. And the the situation was uh
you know does Elder Dragon need to like
see the damage or if something already
has taken one damage earlier in the turn
and you play dragon afterwards does it
uh you know it's not even retroactively.
It's just the fact that it has seen uh
you know it's one damage is enough and
something with one damage uh gets
through it.
>> Yeah, that makes a lot of sense. And I
think earlier you did mention like we're
probably going to see another outer
dragon here. I definitely think that
that is going to be the case if it was
in hand. I'm not really sure that we
would see the second Dazzling Aurora
come down just yet, but maybe you still
would just because you're going to go
and get it out at some point. You are
going to use it and you want to use your
runes for something maybe next turn.
>> Sometimes
>> Yeah. And and so the the other thing too
is that you know uh you know effects
getting on the track on the stack are
important. So uh because we activated
the Ruin Rex Death Neil, it does mean
that we uh you know we could have missed
the timing window for it, right? You
know, especially hidden blade when it's
a reaction. So, you have to actively use
it. Uh, you know, you have to make sure
you're using the right timing for it,
too. So, uh, and, you know, it's an
extra step with hidden cards cuz if you
don't have any cards on the battlefield,
it does have to go somewhere, uh,
whether you activate it or not. So, uh,
we're just getting a confirmation on on
that interaction, too. So, uh, but yeah,
it's it's honestly been super close. And
we we kind of mentioned it too, the
forgotten monument here has been really
incremental here for, you know, Swag
Yolo 420. Yeah. To get to this turn,
right? 100%. I mean, I really do think
that if it would have been a different
battlefield where you could have scored,
we would have been at that six. We'd be
kind of playing a different game right
now. And uh I mean, you wouldn't think,
especially with some of the games we
were talking about, like
>> till your third turn, it's not that long
into the game, but in moments like this,
it's seems to be very deciding.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And and you know this is I
think a good battlefield against
specifically Leblanc which we've seen a
good uptick right a lot of people
especially I think as weeks go on and on
more and more people are confident with
their uh Leblanc gameplay obviously
again very specific on timings on usage
on what you get to do with it. So you do
kind of have to be a little bit
confident with it. So um yeah we're yeah
looks like we're just making sure that
they're explaining the situation right.
Uh there is already one damage on the uh
reflection token from Flurry of Blades
earlier, right? And uh confirming on uh
you know what happens with the Elder
Dragon being played specifically.
>> Yeah. And it looks like they are going
to be making that final decision uh with
the different judges coming up here.
It's going be really interesting to see,
you know, what they do decide to do. Uh
but
>> I don't know. It's been great to watch
both these players. Obviously, both of
them are 7 and0. They've had such a
great day here. And I mean, no matter
what, both have sealed their spot in day
two.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, you know, we're trying
to end the day, right? We're uh this is
the eighth and final round for this day.
We will have five more rounds tomorrow
of Swiss into a top eight cut. So, we do
have to have 15 points. So, 62. I'm sure
there's someone in the room who's 503
who's able to get there. Uh so, looks
like uh we are resolving uh that. I
don't believe uh we got the draw and
then we are going to resolve the second
uh instance of Aurora which there should
only be I think one more Elo dragon
maybe two left in the deck here but
going through it.
>> Oh
>> ooh we see Annie. So this is an
interesting sideboard ad for this. It
does offer us a way to get a spell back
into our uh our hand and that could also
be the flurry of blades. So like again
having that in the trash there lets us
pick it back up and even if we quote
unquote low roll with a smaller cost
unit like Annie getting that flare of
blades is really impactful.
>> Yeah, I mean just having access to it
again. I was thinking earlier when uh
like with that last right so they did
not recycle the flurry of blades when
obviously recycling it had been so uh
integral in that game one where we were
able to have as the bottom card. uh and
be able to play it following through
with some of those Elder Dragons. And
this time it stayed in the discard pile,
but that Annie is such an awesome uh
card that just able to bring it back
from the trash pile still.
>> Yeah. So, uh deciding on the sequencing
cuz you know only one open. We could be
playing we know we have to play around
flurry of blades, right? We need to play
around specifically uh you know a gust
potentially too. Looks like for one
playing the flurry of blades yet. There
goes the owl there.
>> So, we do get another one and then we do
get the hidden blade
>> and I I think we're going to be able to,
you know, force a game three here.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Cuz we will be able to move the
Leblanc up. We can have ganking with
Reflection.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Just confirming there. Yeah. Yeah.
And that's going to be it. So, Yazetto
takes game two there uh with the hidden
blades being able to get rid of the
Elder Dragon though. Annie was really
cool. Uh but unfortunately with only one
elder dragon here, getting rid of the
one big one means that we were able to
get there. And oh, we've got an as
[laughter] climb mirror match and we've
got 16 minutes left. We've got 10 points
we have to try to climb to. And man,
what a game three this is going to be.
>> This is going to be interesting. I did
ask for this, I think, in uh while I
remember you asking for this
>> during game one. I'm not sure that I
really
been at 10 minutes.
>> Yeah,
>> but I am excited to see it. I maybe I've
been waiting for this day.
>> Yeah. I mean, yeah, we're, you know, I
saw the end in sight at the end of round
eight. You're like, "No, we're going to
keep moving forward with it." Uh, but
this also I think even though obviously
I think our more aggressive Leblanc
player is going to have a harder time
getting to 10 points, I think it's going
to be very tough for us to finish in
regulation time. So, uh, obviously the
uh, uh, what Aurora decks don't get a
lot of points early. And so if you can
get that advantage when you know end of
time is called that will mean you know I
think Leblanc might have an edge in this
kind of end of time you know procedures
that we're going to end enter soon.
>> Yeah I definitely do think that's a
fantastic point. Obviously we saw that
Leblanc even last game was really able
to get that really strong early lead. We
were saying that without the forgotten
monument we may have already seen six
points before that Aurora started taking
points. Uh and I mean that is enough of
a lead depending how fast or when the
the turn procedures start
>> for sure. So uh we are getting set up uh
you know obviously I don't looks doesn't
I don't think I saw any players change
their sideboard. I think this is
understood for this. We got game three
round eight of Swiss. We're going to see
who ends the day uh you know undefeated
which you know if there's a tie it could
be both players technically right.
>> Yeah I mean it ties are undefeated.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You have not lost a match
yet today. Uh looks like we're thinking
about uh two back for Swag Yellow 420.
Yeah. And thinking about one and two for
Zetto as well.
>> Yeah, I will say, you know, maybe I
wanted the double Aspirin's climb
because I've been having so much fun
with Riftbound today. I just wanted more
Riftbound.
>> Yeah, we uh we got to make sure that
round eight goes into time and time
here. And we got our three runes to go
second for Zetto. And for three, we will
be playing out uh looks like the uh
champion unit here into the base.
>> Y
>> Mhm.
Looks like we're going to go straight to
back to Swag YOLO. Obviously, no
reaction uh or any spot for it just yet.
Uh and so it looks like this time we are
going to be mobilizing trying to get a
little bit extra runes. And
>> Zeta, I'm kind of interested to see like
was there no other early game unit that
could be played and that's why we play
Lilanc or is this more important?
>> Yeah. So, uh we've got two left uh open
here. Uh you know, maybe another
mobilized stack deck maybe. Uh but looks
like we're going to take a pause here.
Uh unsure immediately what it is, but
again, you know, this this is where the
the time is ticking, right? So,
>> uh, yeah, it'll be interesting. I don't
know. I think this is such I mean, I've
definitely never seen a 10-point game
myself, I don't think, if I'm being
completely honest.
>> Yeah, I was, you know, shouts to the the
crew, too. I was like, you know, we've
seen the eight point and the 9point, and
they're prepared for the 10 points as
well. So, uh, really helpful there as
well. Uh, but yeah, waiting for I'm not
really sure what could have been, uh,
the the reason for for the call here.
>> Has passed, right? Yeah, huge shout out
for sure having that 10 points ready.
Not sure that I would have had it ready.
So, huge shout out there. Uh, but
definitely I'm definitely wondering
myself like what it could be. But
>> also kind of I'm just really excited to
see hopefully how this plays out where
we end up with these
>> with our journey to 10 points and we'll
have to see. But
>> it's going to be a bit of a climb either
way.
>> Yeah. And the only thing is uh
potentially and I have no idea because
we don't have the I I don't necessarily
see a champion next to Civer is maybe
the only thing I can think of. I don't
know 100% like it could just be on the
other side. It could be offscreen here.
Maybe that but uh that that's the only
thing I can maybe think of here. So uh
yeah, it's hard to say, you know, with
with so few, you know, one cards played
a piece, right? Uh you know, there's not
there's not much going on. So
>> yeah, we're only into our second turn
here. Uh I
>> mean, who knows what it'll be? Uh, but
>> yeah. So, uh, you know, talking to the
judge here as well. Two open for Swag
Yolo 420. Yeah. Uh, if you guys don't
know how end of the time procedure works
though, well, we have a moment. Uh, so
once the time hits zero, uh, the turn
player will be zero. Each player will
have two turns and then uh we try to
determine one if the game ends, whoever
wins that game wins that game. Uh
otherwise, you have to have a two-point
deficit to be able to win that.
Otherwise, it's a tie. So, I think for
most of these games, we've seen Leblanc
go to, you know, five, six, even seven
points very quickly. Uh and then, you
know, the Aurora decks trying to
stabilize and then it starts getting its
points. So, uh you know, quickly into
this game, you know, it does kind of
favor a more aggressive player. But uh
yeah, looks like we've uh we've decided
what we dec I'm not sure what the uh the
situation was 100%, but we're still
playing. We've got four runes and we're
going to keep moving forward.
>> Yeah, and we'll have to see what we get
here. Obviously, still two runes up on
Swag Yolo's side. We are though going to
be moving that LeBlanc first into the
southern aspirants climb.
>> Yeah, and Gust is going to push it back.
Don't love to see that. And again, looks
like we are our hand is a little bit
heavy sided for Zetto. Unfortunately,
having to recycle two runes already from
playing this Leblanc twice and passing
it back to Swag Yellow 420. Yeah.
>> Yeah, I would say Gust is probably
almost like the Achilles heal for uh the
Leblanc deck. It I mean, it's kind of
twofold. Obviously, it is stopping those
early points here from Zazetto, but it's
also just denying these death nails,
which is going to hurt for Leblanc.
>> Yeah. All right, going to five. Uh, and
it doesn't look like, you know, any uh,
you know, we we saw the one bit of ramp.
Uh, we do have the chance of Aurora
coming down next turn as well. First
point of the game, uh, of potentially
10. There's that. Also, uh, you know, we
did update the timer. There was some
extension due to the judge call. So,
good to see that as well. So, 15 minutes
is quite a bit, I think, of time here.
>> Yeah, we have a good amount of time and
with 10 points, we may very well need
it. But, we are going to go and discard
a Carus it looks like.
to create this reflection unit.
>> Yeah. So, uh you know, being able to get
an potential draw one here is good. Uh
we could decide to maybe move it
backwards as well. Uh prevent it from
getting like gusted. Uh and maybe Yeah.
Okay. It's going to be the Ash here.
Okay. Uh what cards are in hand? Double
copies of Aurora again. That is so tough
to see.
>> Yeah, it really is. cuz I also have to
wonder like at times like with this
since you're banishing it, it's like if
you could actually run into a unit like
the let's say like the Elder Dragon,
it's not like you be able to last rights
it back uh or anything like that. So
could be nice, but obviously it's not in
hand right now. We are only going to be
able to banish one of those Dazzling
Auroras though and we are going to nine
runes next turn which does mean I think
it's Dazzling Aurora time.
>> Yeah. So, but we have seen already that
uh you know there might be uh more units
in the deck than we're used to. We'll
have to see what's off the top here.
It's an elder dragon and that is exactly
what Swag Yolo 420 wants to see. So,
getting the double removal on the uh
what the Leblanc and the Reflection
token drawing two off the Death Neils
here and passing it back to Zetto. Yeah,
I do think I did see a hidden blade get
drawn off that which is going to be
really nice since we kind of need it.
That or the harness dragons to kill
these elder dragons. Uh so it's going to
be nice to see it set up here
>> and the salvage. That's so nice. Uh we
obviously saw it get ripped out of hand
earlier in the match with the uh mind.
Uh so or yeah with that so that does
mean that you know this is you know one
Aurora is in the trash one is uh
banished one is likely still in the
deck. So uh if we can interact kindly
with this elder dragon that's going to
be a lot of momentum for Zetto.
>> I think the type of interaction that the
Zetto wants to do with that Elder Dragon
uh Swag Yellow 420. Yeah. Is not going
to think of it very kindly.
>> Yeah for sure. So passing it back. No
units at the battlefields right now.
Currently one point to zero. We've got
12 and 1/2 minutes left before we hit
that time. Uh we're going to start off
with the stack deck as well. Looking at
this top three.
>> Mhm.
It does look like I think we potentially
took that gust was exactly what we want
versus the Leblanc list like we talked
about earlier. Uh we're obviously going
to be trying to dig deeper into this
deck, try to find that third Aurora
because otherwise it's going to be
difficult to play a lot of our cards.
>> Yeah. And so we're going to play out the
Civer. Uh it's going to have Accelerate.
He did uh he short-handed it a little
bit. Uh we recycled one and used the
gold and then we produce a gold off of
our civer legend. So that's why I just
tapped the gold sideways. Uh understand
when they're so pressed for time why
that would be the the solution for it.
But having something on a battlefield
means that uh if they do hold, we do get
a dazzling aurora back for our trouble.
So we do kind of have to interact with
this civer. We'll see uh what the
solution here is for Zazetto.
>> Yeah. And we'll have to see if he has
some options here. Yeah, I mean, I'm
sure he does. I feel like Leblanc has a
lot of options and so many different
tools in its toolbox to deal with some
of these decks.
>> All right, looks like uh we're playing
three and recycling two perhaps,
>> which could be a mere image.
>> Mere image against the Elder Dragon. You
mean we're playing the same game, right?
It's It can be pretty scary.
>> Yeah, I think some of those interactions
like that though are so nice. But it
looks like instead we are going to be
doing hidden blade here onto that civer.
It will give Swagulo two cards. So
allows them to draw a bit deeper in, but
it is going to kill that unit.
>> Yeah. So now we're not worried about
specifically uh you know, they can't
hold, right? So their their other Aurora
is still uh banished, right? Not in
usage here. We do get the uh additional
uh soaring scout there. So we can make
the uh additional reflection token if we
want to by discarding one.
>> Yeah. And I mean, just being able to
generate these runes from that soaring
scouts death nail will be really nice to
start I mean building out our runes and
hopefully starting to get this I mean
just all of our units set up.
>> Yeah. So we did discard one. We still
have to place the reflection token I
believe.
>> And
yeah, we're playing out two more. So
>> yeah, and there's the reflection token
right there. So
two or one might there. Passing it back
to Swag Yolo. Yeah. Still has the Elder
Dragon in the back.
>> This last one. Uh
>> I will respond to the last picture.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. Okay. And just passing back. Yeah.
Thinking about our response.
>> And there it is. So, uh back to Swag
Yellow. Yeah. Having I believe 10 runes
right now. So, uh a pretty good amount.
It means that if we don't recycle any,
we can play another Elder Dragon from
hand as well.
We do have uh the trove.
>> Yeah, the treasure trove is half of that
draw engine that Civer loves to use. Uh
so at least it is getting set up here
potentially. Uh looks like dragon is
coming into that southern aspirin's
climb just to kill I believe both the
soaring scout and the soaring scout
reflection. That's going to be two runes
generated. Uh two runes
>> played.
>> Yeah.
>> Played.
>> Yeah. Uh so and we do get the recycle
there. Uh and uh we are able to use the
challenge there for the civer
>> and passing it back. So we've got six
open. But the uh you know the elder
dragon is vulnerable here on this
aspirin client, right?
>> Yeah, for sure. I mean there's so many
different I mean problems that it could
have. Obviously if we do see harness
dragon getting played, it could kill uh
the Elder Dragon. That hidden blade can
access the Elder Dragon. now that it's
in one of these battlefields as well. So
definitely kind of vulnerable, but
Swagula really needs to start getting
points here, especially since only eight
minutes left on clock. We are currently
tied for points. And I mean, if you want
to win for points, we still have eight
more to go.
>> Yeah. So, we're looking at our runes
here. I think there is like a mirror
image in hand as well. So, thinking
about playing that uh you know, if you
played your uh Elder Dragon for a
discount, I'd like to play it for a
discount as well.
>> I would love to see it. Yeah, we've got
the Soaring Scout moving to our uh
battlefield. We're gonna mirror image
>> over there.
>> I am so excited.
>> Yeah, mirror image is such a nice
signature spell for Leblanc. I think it
works so well with her. You choose I any
unit on the board, your opponents or
your own, and you can play a ready
reflection unit to your base of that.
Obviously, it does have temporary um but
it's I mean that does mean right that
you can make an Elder Dragon of your own
now.
>> Yeah. So, uh we're we are thinking about
just attacking Elder Dragon to Elder
Dragon, right? Get the mirror image
trade here. We had to use a flurry of
blades just to not uh like lose to the
smaller unit here.
>> Mhm.
>> And thoughts on our next card from the
Zetto here? Got you know a lot of runes
open.
>> Yeah, still a good number. It looks like
we do have I think that's going to be
six that baited hook coming down here.
Obviously, I'm not sure we're going to
want to
>> H.
>> It looks like we are going to play the
baited hook instead.
>> Okay.
>> And thinking about uh activating
a response to it.
It's a Heedless Resurrection.
>> Ooh.
And that will be able to interact with
the Elder Dragon there and use that to
get rid of it on the reaction to it. So
no baited hook response and yeah Swagiel
yeah still has their uh you know their
dazzling aurora stuck banished here
because they have to hold but yeah a lot
of back and forth here.
>> Yeah I mean I mean that seemed to be a
fantastic card there especially for such
a situation. Uh and we are just going to
try to obviously dig a bit bit deeper
again here for Swag Yolo. is trying to
hunt down that third dazzing Aurora. It
looks like we did find it.
>> I don't think we have the runes for it.
So,
>> yeah.
>> Uh it looks like we're paying for four
for a
>> Yeah, being able to get the temporary on
that card there.
>> Very good with the
>> uh the Fading Memories.
>> Yeah, I think it's our second Fading
Memories today uh that you and I saw. I
think the first Fading Memories was on a
dazzling aurora and then this one taking
out that baited hook.
>> Yeah. So, five uh and change left for
this round here. And Zazetto. Yeah.
Playing out double glass mixologist and
the ruined Rex get the recycle two and
passing it back.
>> Yeah, we're just trying to get set up
here. Hopefully, obviously that glass
mixologist has such a nice ability to
try to get our base a little bit wider.
When it dies, you are trying to place
some of those smaller units from your
trash. And I mean just slowly build up
that base. When you're going to 10
points,
>> I want to say you have the time, but
with 5 minutes on the clock, time is not
on your side.
>> Yeah. So, uh, asking for cars in the
trash. Uh, we are going to challenge.
So, it currently, I think, has taken 10
damage. Six from the rune or sorry, six
from challenge and four from ruin rex.
So, uh, shouldn't that shouldn't that be
enough, right? Cuz isn't it six and
four? Does unless it has 11 somehow.
It is
>> or it not, I guess.
>> Yeah, because you you do damage back and
then it takes the the four, right?
>> I I could be wrong. There might be
another situation I'm thinking. But
we're going to keep moving forward here.
>> We are just playing that Dazzling Aurora
though at the end of our turn. It is
going to be that Annie that we hit off
uh off Dazzling Aurora. It will let us
access one of those cards from our trash
as well.
>> Yeah.
So deciding on what card to bring back.
>> Yeah, I mean there's so many different
options as well. It feels like does look
like we are going to be bringing back I
mean kind of the MVP that took out our
Elder Dragon earlier.
>> Yeah, it's the Heatless there. So moving
back to Zetto here.
>> Let's see what our play here. And yeah,
obviously that's been super strong. Uh
if we have another uh elder dragon in
the trash, we are just going to use the
uh harness dragon to get rid of it. So
uh strong for Zetto here.
>> Yeah, and it does seem like that will
also kind of stop that Heedless from
being uh able to summon another Elder
Dragon. Uh so I mean really nice harness
dragon there.
So, we'll have to see what they're able
to do, but it does feel like Zetto was
able to clear out at least a lot of
those Elder Dragons. That being said, if
we can find a last rights, we could
potentially recycle them back into our
deck.
>> Yeah. So, uh we're putting the uh
reflection token back in, uh the base
and then we do have options to uh you
use the glass of myologist to bring
cards back. We're at 423
right now using the the boon there or
bloom. Sorry. There's there's blooms and
boons in this deck. You got to you got
to be real careful about it.
>> Let's see.
>> Play the last rights. Okay. So, that's
going to be helpful for making sure
we've got uh you know an elder dragon to
put back into our deck
>> and challenge here.
>> Ooh. Okay.
>> Yeah, I think both these cards going to
be really nice for Swag Yolo to
potentially draw into or not draw into,
dazzing Aurora into and then also
hopefully draw into at some point.
>> All right. And so we are going to use it
to play out a civer here.
>> And since I think we've recycled enough,
we are at six might and we have
accelerate here.
>> So we do get rid of the glass
vixologist. it will let us play out a uh
you know a carus here. So we do get the
double removal or what revival. Uh we
get to play two cards off of our trash
here and we are going to use uh our
elder dragon here and we're going to use
it to likely just get rid of the carus
I'm imagining.
>> Yeah, I assume that Carthus is going
straight to the trash and it does. I
mean Carus is so great at doubling those
death nails and that's exactly what I
swag doesn't want to happen.
>> Yeah. So, uh, you know, you activate
everything and then we got our beginning
step here. So, uh, you know, we do have
to play out, you know, whatever we play,
uh, rested, right? So, uh, there's the
Carus here.
>> Okay. I mean, they tried to take the
Carthus out, but the Carus will not stay
out. Uh, so also another ruined Rex as
well.
>> This could be good across the board of a
lot of four might. So, we, you know,
Andy right now is five with the uh with
the last rights here. So yeah, we're
going to use sacrifice here.
>> It's all good.
>> Yeah, that is so nice being able to kill
the ruined Rex. And because of Carthus,
it is going to be doing eight damage out
as decided. It looks like we are taking
out the civer.
>> Yeah. Uh we do have Carus out, so it
should be able to be a double death
Neil. Uh so would be able to deal four
damage to Annie.
>> Mhm.
>> Not that I think that matters
specifically too much because it looks
like we're going to send the harness
dragon here anyways. Flurry.
>> Yeah, there's the flurry. Yeah, gets rid
of the harness dragon.
>> Got my triggers. Oh my goodness.
>> Yeah, there's the sentry. But that's
finally a hold for Swag Yolo. Yeah,
means that they should be able to get
the Dazzling Aurora back as well. I know
that happened forever ago. It's late in
the day, but with that hold, even if we
lose out, uh, you know, that does offer
there. So, six points here.
Yeah, it definitely feels like Swag Yolo
is kind of starting to take back control
of the board. He's starting to get more
points. We are at six versus four here.
Getting close is at uh that two point
difference.
>> Yeah.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah. And it's it's looking good for
them here. Uh you know, pre being able
to be ahead by that amount of number
like it's going to be tough for Zetto to
get into the clear here. Uh but time's
ticking down. Yeah. Sweet. Halo 420 as
going to be turn zero uh here for our
final match of round eight.
>> I'll just go to
>> All right. So, we're going to be using
the Dazzling Aurora effect again. I
think we do have a uh dragon in there,
>> believe so as well. Uh yep. And there is
that dragon.
>> Yeah. So, Carus again likely going to
take the the damage here. We're going to
put it on the uh the north one with any
>> Carus can like can't stay alive. I feel
like in this matchup.
>> Yeah. So, uh and then yeah, notice the
dazzling Aurora uh off off screen here.
So, unsure where it goes.
>> This is exiled by Ash. I did hold this
turn.
>> I forgot that Aurora trigger or he
forgot. It's actually his trigger,
right? His ash.
>> Really?
>> I think it's a no.
>> It's not my Ash.
>> Yeah. And he's asking about the Ash. And
you know this this is an interesting
conversation because you know it is an
effect that's owned by our Leblanc
player too. So uh judges there we're
going to decide uh where the dazzling
Aurora goes since we did hold as
mentioned previously. So
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. I would say that yeah we got the
one Aurora out. You know obviously
>> as many as we have out we we'd love to
have it but we'll we'll see
>> the uh the decision on that
>> trigger.
>> Yeah, it'll be interesting to see. It is
obviously banished off of that Ash I
believe is the keyword they use. So,
we'll have to see what happens. Um, but
I think that, you know, Yulo
Swag Yolo is definitely in a very
commanding position here, holding both
of those battlefields. Obviously,
already having two Elder Dragons set up,
one Dazzling Aurora as well. Meanwhile,
it seems like the only thing on board
for the Zetto is that Watchful Sentry,
>> which this late into the game doesn't
feel super watchful.
>> Yeah. So, we're going to uh decide if
the dazzor where it will go, right? Uh
with the conversation being, you know,
it was the Ash effect, right? Uh that
activate where it went and where it
goes, right? Uh you know, it's the card
owned by Swag Yellow 420. Yeah. But it's
the Zetto's effect, right? So, uh we're
we're just getting a confirmation there.
Again, I it doesn't matter, I think,
specifically. Uh I don't I'm not sure if
they're going to be able to play another
Aurora, right? Uh but it does kind of
make a a difference. Sometimes like you
if you have like a discard one and you
just having extra card you know you're
not going to use that can make a
difference.
>> Yeah, for sure. Uh and I mean when
you're in round eight and you're
currently undefeated, you want to make
sure that you have it correct. Uh and
>> just remind me that is it trigger or my
trigger?
>> Yeah. So just confirming yeah on the
ownership of the trigger
>> it trigger
>> for for that one. Uh we do have what
looks like uh seven runes open for Swag
Yellow 420. Yeah. Uh which is quite a
lot here. I think we've got maybe like
two or three cards in hand.
>> That's not correct because it it gives
me an advantage like
>> Yeah, I think both players have a couple
cards at minimum.
>> It's not okay if I if I otherwise I can
miss it on purpose, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
>> Like if I can misg
obviously both have a lot of runes as
well. So so many resources on both
sides.
>> Matter of the way, but like
>> Yeah. So just getting a confirmation,
you know, where it goes to, you know, I
don't want to
>> deepen it, right? cuz you know like
there's like the
uh triggers that aren't yours, right?
But it's it's you know your
responsibility too. So we're we're going
to get the confirmation on that. So just
deciding uh you know you know what's
what's the miss window for Ash? Uh if
there's a miss window who owns the
effect. Uh again getting dazzling or I
think I heard Swag Yellow 420 gas say
you know not super large about adding
that to hand but uh you know we do want
a confirmation on it.
>> Yeah. And as they say, judges are always
your friends. You never never feel
afraid to ask any questions at any time
during the tournament. So they're always
there to help.
>> Yeah, for sure. So they're just getting
a confirmation on that for for there.
Currently, it's seven points to four
right now. Uh and then Swag Yellow 420.
Yeah. Uh does have turn zero here. So
we're going to go to turn one once we
pass fully to Zetto here. And Zetto has
to get a good amount of points. So I
think at this point Zetto uh is kind of
just in contention for getting the tie,
right? If we get two points over two
turns, the most we can get is eight,
right? Uh which means that not enough to
win the game or even get the the victory
uh you know the point more. So yeah, uh
you know just wants to get that plus two
deficit. So currently at seven if we
double we go from seven to nine and
since this is a double Aspirin's climb
game, we do need to get through that big
10. Yeah, that 10 continues uh to
surprise me so much. Even though I did
ask for it earlier, I just was not ready
for it. 10 I mean nine is already
difficult to get to. 10 is a little bit
crazy. And I mean
>> getting even lead going to nine points
will feel really confident
>> for sure. So uh yeah, just getting a
confirmation on that too like yeah and
this Ash is you know a new card from
Unleashed, right? And it's it's been one
that I've been seeing a lot of
popularity for, right? Uh and you read
it, right? You're like, "Oh, yeah. I get
you I get to temporary discard one. Is
that kind of worth the the effort for,
but when you're playing against a deck
like Aurora where they don't really hold
until late game, you really get that
discard one for the majority of the
game?"
>> Yeah. I mean, it just it does feel
really strong, even though it may not
seem like it at first. Uh, and but
obviously
>> especially in some of these more
complicated decks, we're still trying to
figure out exactly how all this really
works out.
>> Yeah. And uh yeah, it looks like if if
I'm looking at this right, yeah, it's
saying that it was a mis trigger for
this Ash. So, the dazzling aurora will
stay banished for for this one. So,
we're moving forward on that. We've got
the carus hitting the board here and uh
we'll see what's up for Zetto, but
again, we're we're kind of in the back
foot. Swag. Yeah, I think at this point
because we're in time um
>> guaranteed at least a tie can uphit into
a win here. [snorts]
>> Yeah, and we'll have to see if is that
okay to bring this back to, you know,
getting that tie like you mentioned. Um
or if Swago is just able to get this
win. Looks like we are bringing that
watchful sentry up into that northern
aspirants climb. My assumption is we're
just doing this to try to get that draw.
Uh and it looks like Zagulo did not try
to react at all to that. And we've got
uh I think we got a mirror what the
signature spell right off the top there.
So that can be really good. Again, being
able to get your own copy of Elder
Dragon can be super nice here. So we'll
see if that ends up being played.
>> Uh but looks like the Zetto saying, you
know what, I I can't do anything here.
>> Yeah. And uh there's the fist bump
making sure we got contact. And yeah,
Swag Yellow 420. Yeah. Able to go 80 for
the day. End of the day with a perfect
record so far.
>> What a fantastic job by uh Swag Yolo
[music] 420. Yeah. I mean, even just
playing this far into the tournament,
eight rounds, super tiring, but both
these players [music]
did such a fantastic job.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And even with, you know, a
seven record, we are in high contention
for tomorrow. And uh yeah, looking
forward to catching up on Zetto as they
continue their uh run tomorrow.
>> Yeah, it'll be interesting to see how
they continue to do. Both these players,
as you said, uh still in a really great
spot. They both have their day two
locked. Uh, and it's going to be really
interesting to see how they continue.
Obviously, such a long day already today
and tomorrow, as you said, five more
Swiss rounds then going into that top
cut.
>> Yeah. So, uh, you know, as we go into
tomorrow, anyone with an X2 record,
including these two players, will be
qualified into day two. Five more rounds
of Swiss and then top eight of Swiss
standings will be into the top eight
single elimination cut.
>> Yeah, it's going to be I'm cannot wait
to see who ends up being our top hook.
Even just watching tomorrow, it's going
to be so much fun to really see like
which decks made it today, too.
Obviously, we have such a diverse meta
here, so many great leaders, but
tomorrow the cream of the crop.
>> Yeah, for sure. I mean, we've seen so
many uh good players already. Uh and
looking forward to seeing like a full uh
what legend list as we get it tomorrow.
See how many players qualified and
should be a good day.
>> Oh my god, I cannot wait. It's going to
be so much fun. I I just do love day
twos and getting to start seeing some of
those best ofs. Probably there's some of
the legends that did lock today, but a
couple of them are still going to be in
contention and fighting for that awesome
best of card.
>> Yes, indeed. So, uh I know it was a long
game, so we have Silverfuse doing a
quick rundown of some key points. Let's
send it over to her.
>> That was a great game by Civer. And one
of the big things that we saw is that we
saw Annie as one of the sideboard
choices. So a big question is why are we
seeing Annie in this deck? It's
something that we don't usually see
outside of Annie the champion herself.
So a big reason for is this deck wants
to have a lot of recursion. We are
playing the last rights and we are
playing the elder dragons as well. So a
big thing with that is we also run out
of spells or the blades of flurry fury
fury of the blades of course and so
Annie allows us to get that back. We can
also play Starcross on her to get it
back as well. So, so this deck no longer
has to worry about running out of units
or running out of spells. So, that's why
we see Annie come into play in these
long grindy matchups such as the Leblanc
deck. And thank you so much for tuning
in for this.
>> All right, so that is the, you know,
analysis on Annie. Again, a really
particular choice there, but being able
to get these spells back. I think a
really good analysis there.
>> Yeah, I think that Annie was just so
unique in that sideboard, but I think
we're going to have an interview where
maybe they'll be able to explain it as
well. So, we're going to I think send
into that interview in a second here.
Going to be really, really cool to see.
>> Yeah. And I think we are going to get an
interview in just a little bit for our
server players. So, we're going to make
sure they're all set up for that. Not
sending it right now, but uh again, like
this is the end of the day. You've
played through all eight rounds.
Definitely a lot of emotions, a lot of
thoughts on your game play so far. Uh,
you know, we were able to get that in
game three. Currently undefeated and,
you know, this is not their first time
having quite the run with Civer, right?
>> Yeah, definitely not. Uh, Swag Swag Yolo
420. Yeah. Has already gotten one best
of Civer. They're obviously a fantastic
pilot of the deck. We saw that just a
moment ago, but it has to feel really
confident going into being undefeated at
the end of day one. Yeah, and you know,
it's it's been pretty clear that there
are a lot of interactions, a lot of
specific timings for it. So, being able
to notice that one big thing that I
noticed too when they were playing again
when they were at the uh full amount of
runes, they were able to, you know,
preemptively recycle, which means that
they were able to get more of those gold
gear tokens, which I know a lot of
people were just kind of not thinking
about it that much, but that does come
up. That is an important resource. You
want to make sure you're playing to the
maximum abilities of your legends.
>> Yeah, that was such a great choice by
them. I mean, it is being able to
maintain your resources in that way is
so smart. I definitely would forget to
do it personally. I know that. Uh, and
it just seems like such a great way to
grow your resources even past those 12
runes.
>> Yeah, and it looks like they are ready
for their interview. So, let's hear
their thoughts of the day.
>> Thank you so much for an excellent cast
to a magnificent match to end the day.
I'm joined by the wonderful YOLO Swag
420. Yeah,
>> that's me,
>> Ollie. Ollie.
>> Ollie. Um, I just got to say I one of
that was one of the best matches I've
seen at such high level gameplay at the
end of a very rigorous and long day
because I learned so much about the
intricacies of playing something like
Dazzling Aurora, which I do think kind
of gets a bit of a bad rap on on how
much skill it might take and knowing the
rules of the game and the fact that I
could hear you explain everything. I
leveled up as a player. So, first of
all, thank you.
>> Oh, that's awesome. But also
congratulations on going 8 and0 on the
first day or of Vancouver.
>> Thank you so much.
>> You already have been prolific in this
dazzling Aurora deck with a best of
civer already in your pocket.
>> Bringing it here again and now having
such a dominant performance in day one.
How do you feel?
>> I mean it feels really good. I put a lot
of work into this deck like over the
over the course of the last few months.
Uh it's going to see it pay off. I know
people hate on Aurora, but like I put a
lot of work in this this version of it.
Uh
>> it shows.
>> Thank you so much. I'm glad uh I'm glad
that I'm able to showcase it. I think
it's too early to like celebrate because
there's still five more rounds tomorrow,
but I'm happy to be here. I'm happy with
my result. I'm proud of myself. So,
>> well, I know I'm celebrating because
that was such an amazing performance and
you know, we've been watching you across
all these different events. You know, I
say I say hi to you almost every time,
you know, do an interview with you from
the best of, of course, and you know,
you're on your way to kind of prove why
Dazzling Aurora is such a good deck, but
you know, it takes time and skill to
sort of master it as well. So, I guess
I'm going to ask you as we go in, you go
to bed, you rest up and play a long day
two tomorrow as well. But what are you
trying to look to avoid? Cuz I can tell
you right now, there's quite a lot of
known names also going in undefeated on
this day two and you might get paired
against them right at the start of
tomorrow.
>> Yeah, honestly, I don't I don't mind any
particular player. The only thing I
don't want to play against is like
Victor. Hope hopefully hopefully he's
not 80 Victor. Everything else I can uh
bounce around or play around. Uh, yellow
is kind of rough overall, but Annie
helps over helps uh, solve the yellow
matchup.
>> And I was kind of convinced that Leblanc
was a hard matchup. And don't get me
wrong, that was a tough match to play
and the intricacies behind it, but um,
showing that you know how to do it and
navigate it. The Annie, I know we've
already talked about it a little bit
from the analyst, but incredible tech
bringing back those valuable spells that
you need to kind of reuse those few
amount of units. Impeccable play. And
I've got to say again, Last Rights is so
good.
>> Last Rights is good. Yeah, Last Rights
is good. Annie's great. She's my
daughter, [music] I guess. I don't know.
She's She's great. Uh, it was I don't
know. I love this deck. I love all this
game. I'm sorry to be here. So,
>> and I love watching you play it at a
masterful level. But that's going to be
it for us on interviewing. We're going
to send our players away so they can
rest up for day two. Ali, thank you so
much. And we're going to send it back,
>> of course.
>> All right. And that's going to be the
end of our day. We've got to close it
out real quick, but it's been a lot of
fun being able to watch all these games
that we've been able to do. And again,
we're only halfway through this weekend.
>> Yeah, I cannot believe and I'm so
excited to get to cast even more games
tomorrow and get to watch these
fantastic players at playing some of
these decks they've been working on so
long. Even even uh
Swag YOLO for 20 uh was just talking
about how many months he's taken to
build this deck and they're just so
excited to play it.
>> Yeah, and you know, we've got a good
amount of different legends that popped
up. I think, you know, going into round
six, we had about, I think, 22 unique
undefeated. I'm thinking going into day
two, I think the majority of legends
probably have a representative or two in
there. So, really exciting to see uh,
you know, we do have Leblanc
automatically getting in there, too. Uh,
the rest of the casting uh, couch likes
to see Diana do well, so hopefully one
or two snuck in there. I think we're
pretty uh, fortunate for that. But, uh,
yeah, a lot of great games so far.
>> Yeah, and I definitely think you are
going to be seeing some Diana tomorrow.
We saw that I think Allen's EQ had
already
gotten his spot in day two as well. So,
a lot of great players, a lot of great
decks.
>> Yeah. So, looking forward to that. Uh,
you know, I was looking at some of the
kind of unusuals. I knew we did see Ar
Le uh finish at least 6-1, right? They
could be 7-1 right now, which is
phenomenal. I I can't imagine. I don't
think I've won seven games with let
alone uh maybe even six games. So, that
doing that in a tournament this size is
already just amazing.
>> Yeah, it's a feat within itself. So, I'm
really excited to see that happen. Even
maybe more players might play Leon now.
Maybe they'll try the list. Maybe
they'll enjoy it. I think Leon's
definitely a League of Legends favorite
as well. So, really cool to see. And I
was really excited to see that Pike was
able to make it 61 as well.
>> Definitely. So, we'll have to catch up
with those uh decks tomorrow. We're
going to close it out today. And let's
go to Barrett and Alex to close out the
night.
>> Thank you so much for a wonderful final
cast of the day. I mean, I'm glad I got
to interview um Ali there because that
was such an amazing way to end the day.
I feel like the matches as we get
further into the tournament, Alex, are
always better and better and because
we're going to see the high level
gameplay and that's what I'm excited to
see going into day two.
>> Yeah, there's a lot of excitement and of
course like there's a lot at stake as
well. Like you can feel the intensity
with the players, there's a lot on the
line. We got best on the line and of
course ultimately the championship as
well.
>> Yeah. And with that championship that
means we have a bunch of players that
are going to be going to day two. We
have some standings for you all and we
hope to go over them quickly. Of course,
we want to highlight a lot of these 8
and0 and seven and one players. So,
we're going to start things off. Dewali,
an great name that we know about. Of
course, we just watched Swag Yellow 420.
Yah there. Flex Duel we watched earlier
today. Of course, CTT Allen EQ who is
very prolific of course. Pog Chungus,
we've also was in our last round there.
Um, went undefeated. And so, like look
at these eight and right here. Eight
people currently going in and there is a
diverse level of legends here.
>> Yeah, no kidding. I mean, you do have
obviously Aurora representation with
Civer, but we have Kai'Sa finally going
8 and0. That's a huge story. I think a
lot of people were starting to doubt the
power of Fury. We're seeing it in full
force here. And of course, we do we do
have uh Pog Chungus or I have I have to
such a beautiful name. Also on Draven
going 8 and0.
>> Absolutely. Not just these incredible
legends to represent and prove us wrong
that Fury is here to compete with Kai'Sa
and Draven, but you know in the same
diversity as you can kind of see a
couple of civers and more dazzling
Auroras. Of course, we got some more
players that are qualified. Some seven-1
players including Randy and Prismaticism
right next to each other. Bolan Zang
also pretty prolific playing Annie as
well. Quite a few Annies here in the
running because I can only imagine on
the next side we're probably going to
see even again um Gonkra who we got to
see pilot that earlier. For me, it's
really exciting to see Azir going seven
and one. I think that this is an
absolutely remarkable deck, remarkable
legend. It's going to be one that thinks
it's going to be very relevant for the
time to come. So, it's great to see a
7-1 result here. And yeah, it doesn't
surprise me to see Randy and
Prismaticism near the top. Back to
focusing on that Fury domain as well.
There's a Pike here. So, even more
representation really proving me wrong
about how strong that domain might be.
So, I'm excited to see even more of
these legends. Of course, we got more
Dazzling Aurora decks, more Civer here,
Gonkra. There we are with another Annie
deck. Rice Master I've seen T1 win. We
had featured on the stream as well. I
had to get that last loss there in that
last round. Rock Low still another
representation of Azir.
>> Yeah, and obviously that is a
tremendously talented player that has a
number of best of I believe four best of
Azir. Uh no veggies running Poppy. Look
at that. A seven and one Poppy. You
absolutely love to see it. Master Yi
being shown here as well. And uh as a
result of that, I mean Master obviously
is the first to have two different
legends. Unfortunately, we're going to
talk about some of the legends didn't
make it. We have at least one Master Yi
that's going to make Top Cut.
>> Perfect. Absolutely. And you know, I'm
excited to see all these different
Legends diversity. I see the Fiora, of
course, but we're slowly going to start
creeping into more of these 7 in1
players. Of course, more Leblanc, a Lux
up there. That's right. We've got a raid
browser there for Lux, Lady of Lumosity,
Sam D. Sherman, 7 in1. We got to
highlight that earlier. Rengar moving
into day two as well. So some of these
unleashed and dare I say another Draven
there at X and one with Exhale.
>> Yeah, seeing Sam D Sherman have success
here as well. Obviously the winner from
Vegas. It's great to see here again we
do have more Azir Lilia showing itself
for the first time with Gail wins. That
was a game that I had the pleasure of
casting. I absolutely love Lilia. It's
one of my favorite legends in the entire
game. So going seven to1 is a massive
result.
>> Man, I the fact that we saw Gail wins
all the way earlier on in round one
today. Being 7 in1 with that Lilia
really makes me happy. Speaking of,
we've got Z-Rob from Challenger TCG on
Kha'Zix here. Another representation
here from Fiora from Hcore. And we are
going to zoom a little bit quicker as we
are now going to get a little bit past
some of these 7 in1 players. More
Kha'Zix retentmentation. Another Rengar.
And as we get to the 60 and2 and 61
and1, you know, we're down to the 70th
seat. And the reality is as we get and
show these names off, we can kind of
really let them fly by. But I got to ask
you, Alex, you know, even with these
players that are X11 right now, I mean,
it it's really hard to squeak into that
top eight. You basically have to go into
tomorrow and win five more Swiss rounds
in a row.
>> I mean, at at the end of the day,
getting into the top eight is always
going to be an incredibly difficult
task. There's so much talent on here
that the skill expression in Riftbound
is so extreme. But it is worth
mentioning, we do have some legends that
ultimately did not make it into the top
cut. Those will include Jax, Jinx,
Master Y, Wuju Master, Garen, Leona, and
sadly fan favorite Rumble.
>> So, no day twos on those ones. Is that
what you're telling me?
>> That's no day twos.
>> Well, that means we might find out, of
course, we will find out some best of
winners as those players are going to be
going home representing those legends.
We'll be going home and figuring out who
are going to take those home. But that
means everyone that you didn't list is
here in this day two. And I cannot wait
to see who we are going to see in our
top eight and who at the end of it will
be the Vancouver regional qualifier
champion.
>> There's a lot more of action to come in
day two and honestly I got to tell you I
couldn't be more excited. There is so
much talent in this field and
realistically anybody can win.
>> And tell me about the room. I mean this
is your first regional qualifier. I've
been to a ton of these. But how has it
been feeling the energy in these this
Riftbound regional qualifier? It's
electric isn't it?
>> It's honestly amazing. I'm not just
saying this. There's a it's just a
fantastic feeling on all corners here.
There are people who have never played
Riftbound before that are here for the
first time at the learntoplay section
having an absolute blast. There are
others that are competing for the best
ofves that again are having the time of
their lives. You got side events. There
is so many reasons to come and just take
in the atmosphere of these events.
>> Well, Alex, I'm exhausted and [music] I
think our viewers might be as well as
well as our players. And with that,
we're going to start to say farewell.
Our viewers at home, thank you so much
for tuning in today as we have another
round of five Swiss rounds to conclude
[music] and then our cut to single
elimination. And here we have it.
Vancouver players like Sam D. Sherman,
Allen ZQ, Dewali, all [music] qualifying
for this day two play here in Vancouver.
Will we see a brand new regional
qualifier champion? Will we finally see
an [music] unleashed legend jump from
the brushes and climb to the top for the
victory as we finally [music] crown a
brand new regional qualifier champion?
Everyone at home, you must please join
us at 10:00 a.m. [music] PST tomorrow as
we can conclude this final fantastic
journey and crown a brand new regional
qualifier [music] champion.
>> [music]
>> Heat. Heat.
[music]